this video is sponsored by the king of
online military games War Thunder
with the final Arc of Jiu Jitsu Kaizen
seemingly underway now and the idea of
kinjaku's Cullen game becoming more and
more of a footnote and the history of
the Jujutsu Kaizen series I feel like
it's the perfect time to take a walk
back through the Cullen game Saga and
revisit everything that has happened in
each and every single culinary that led
us up to one of the most climactic
points throughout the story before we
dive straight back into the story though
a few necessary things that we kind of
like have to discuss here like the fact
that the Cullen game hasn't technically
Ended as probably the biggest one in a
narrative perspective I feel safe enough
to say that it has ended and we have
like moved forwards any story into this
final Arc but I won't explain like why
exactly here for that you're gonna have
to sit through this entire video and
find out the moment where it ends and
why like I can't be spoiling you lot on
literally the outcome of this video
anyways as someone who busted straight
into Gecko and the juicy cousin manga
after their first season ended I started
reading the Cullen game as it was
releasing on a weekly basis and it
became the first ever series that I
experienced in that format there were
moments where I felt like things slowed
down to a grinding halt but that's all
for the very specific purpose of
developing the story and the world
around through allowing the world to
grow throughout the Saga here Giga added
an entire new cast of extremely vital
characters who might not seem important
at first but after spending over two
years in our own time with him it's
obvious that they are everyone adds to
the lineup of dope characters that Mr
kutami or should I say uh Mr Charles
Bernard had already created and I I
guess he did kind of need of the
character count after what just happened
at Shibuya either way if you are new
around here and want to watch more
massive Arc explained videos just like
this one but for a variety of different
series then be sure to hit that
subscribe button and push this video to
5K likes so that I know you want more
either way sit back and relax as we dive
into the culling game from Jujutsu
Kaizen
so as we start back out we find
ourselves in the middle of a Japanese
criminal trial it's explained that in
Japan 99 of criminal trials into their
guilty verdict a young man sitting
opposite the newest Qi hegaruma who I
introduced right at the end of the last
video explains that he had a care who
was lost and while looking for it he was
confronted by the popos being struck
with a difficult Choice the young man
decided to flee because his cat would
have died it's where he lives it's a
rule that he can't own any pets we find
that in March of 2016 a mother and
daughter were both slain and Mario Kart
City this caused the prosecutors of the
case to instantly suspect the young man
they arrested him and charged him with
suspicion of murder and robbery after
Kisa fled the initial questioning by
police officers they followed him to his
home and found it bloody blade which is
like bro why have you got this knife
dude it ain't exactly looking good for
you here anyway once a lab analysis was
completed it confirmed that the blood on
the knife was matched to the DNA of the
two victims despite the outstanding
evidence and practically being caught
red-handed by the cops keita insisted
that he was innocent while reviewing the
case with his co-worker Shimizu higuruma
explains that Kita told him he picked up
the knife even though it wasn't his
obviously Shimizu doesn't believe that
that could have possibly happened and
instead thinks that he fled from the
authorities because he was simply guilty
here for some reason hagaruma argues
that he only fled because in the past
he'd been illegally harassed by police
officers causing him to always be weary
of them he claimed he was going to give
the knife to the police later because
his hostile was skitchy as hell and
didn't allow him to call the police
there the reason for this is because his
job around the hostel was to care for
the elderly who have nowhere to go
employees in the hostel are given a
place to stay and some food but I only
paid money under the table on a new year
while at the same time still being
overcharged each month for rent
obviously as you could imagine this
affects how all of the residents would
love more than a few of the residents
who do live there have criminal records
and ever since the 2011 earthquake
Relief Fund money started pouring into
the region causing more shady non-profit
business to begin appearing hegaruma
believes it's likely that the weapon was
actually lying around and Kita indeed is
telling the truth so well obviously big
kuruma is a freaking G man is working on
the higher cognitive frequency and is
probably the only damn lawyer in Japan
that is adamant and taking on the courts
themselves plus freaking Giga again
added in that 2011 tsunami slash
earthquake reference there I absolutely
love how it makes us feel as though this
could actually be going down in Japan
right now or he's retelling an event
that actually affected the world over
the past few years anyways anyways
hegaruma forms a plan to take on the
case he'll continue gathering
information while his overworked
assistant takes care of pretty much
everything else the sexy big brain Duo
go ham working tirelessly until the day
of the trial then on the day they
somehow managed to earn an innocent
verdict for keita Shimizu was surprised
they actually got the verdict but
hegaruma knows the prosecutors will
immediately appeal in a post-trial
meeting hegaruma reveals to case her
that nothing from the robbery that was
stolen was ever found in his room and
someone disappeared from residents soon
after the crime happened above
everything else cater also appeared on a
convenience store camera at literally
the same time as the time of the death
hearing this he thanks hegaruma but they
lawyer simply emphasizes that there will
be a second trial sobbing Peter
specifies us that he means he just wants
to thank her garuma for believing in him
however as per usual at the retrial the
broken Japanese Judicial System
unfortunately found cater guilty and the
young man was sentenced to life in
prison it's explained that independent
defense lawyers like higuruma rely on
limited funding and no Workforce public
prosecutors have access to tax money and
much greater Manpower because of this no
new evidence was ever presented at the
second trial and the court passed out
his sentence on the shaky argument that
there was no reason to suspect the
random person who just happened to go
missing straight after the murder which
is like Nadu that pet guy straight up
gaptive because he committed the murder
and now you're completely locking up an
innocent person here a cane anyway
because of this a third trial before the
highest court is unlikely as they refuse
to hear most cases hidden a fear hearing
is improbable and the system itself
unfairly branded cater is guilty from
the very beginning and sadly this is
just the reality of the situation in
most countries from the US to New
Zealand it's an issue of Blake being
said in front of the jury you already
have somewhat of a bad connotation put
over your head it was so like moral of
the story obviously it's just don't get
yourself in a situation where you're
going to be charged for something in
court obviously you can't always do that
but anyway disparate and angry cater
looks at heguruma was sorrow and
disappointment in his eyes standing
there shocked her groomer just asks
himself why his clients always look at
him this way losing touch with reality
for a moment he thinks back to a
conversation he had about his mental
state there he replied that it was his
intention to save the week he's always
been the type of person who couldn't
just ignore things Justice is supposed
to be blind and people close their eyes
to spare themselves from The Hearth
truce of reality but even if he's the
only one her guruma says that he wants
to keep his eyes back in court now the
judge announces that if there are any
objections that they must be filed
within 15 days not freaking happy though
and wanting to make a damn change he
could rumor abruptly interrupts and
slams his table with a mallet that turns
out to be a judge's gavel of his own
this leaves absolutely everyone in the
courtroom surprised and as shizumu
begins to move away a large dark curse
begins to form behind hagarumar refusing
to allow the trial to end in this unjust
Manor a rumor snaps and tells everybody
that nobody is allowed to leave because
now they are having a re-trial as per
usual with other gecko you're skipping
away from this straight away and going
over elsewhere just before 6am back on
the 1st of November when we find
ourselves with kinjaku who's legit like
creeping onto saski by the way just
gonna blow your minds if you guys
haven't realized this as well this is
the freaking girl from the very first
episode or chapter yuji's old friend
like the one that like he saved right at
the beginning so what the actual hell
does kinjaku have in store here like
with her anyways anyways petrified as
you would be with waking up and finding
a man like in your beard sitsuko asks
who's weirdo is as explained to her that
he is a sorcerer who placed a barrier
over scene dye and that the region has
been chosen to host a lethal contest
where players will fight to the death
the remains of an execution site nearby
serves as the center of the barrier with
a radius of around five to six
kilometers which is super interesting
like I wonder if he had to set up a
bunch of these like execution sites
throughout each barrier in his thousand
years or so proceeding this event Sasuke
who are already inside of the barrier
are given one chance to leave so this
explains the confusion on how they were
going to be like notified of the current
situation with the barrier he says that
as she chooses to leave she'll awaken
outside of the barrier confused with his
word him of just like everything says
asking questions if she's still dreaming
but kunjaku replies that the space
between dreams and reality is a curse I
don't know if this dude was the only one
to show up personally to Sasaki but he
takes a hold of her hand and warns her
to be careful then as he slowly guides
her to the safety of the barrier exit we
get to witness the current Carnage
taking place Battlefield then skipping
back to the duo just before the part
weighs for good kinjaku mysteriously
thanks asarski for getting along with
his son and suddenly after she wakes up
outside of the barrier with the other OG
friend from the first chapter or episode
a Gucci who's glad to have found someone
that he knows so it's always good to see
a Gucci doing well again as we left on
the note that he was in hospital and
everything anyway he points out the
gigantic barrier wall and explains that
everyone saw the same man during their
dream however to further go on to my
point on him physically mixing her
unlike the others Sasuke asks if the man
had mentioned his son but that isn't the
case with him skipping away from that
now and back to the present day which is
the 11th of November Eugene Megami
continued planning for their part of the
game they're unable to find a player
named Angel but apparently they'll know
who it is when they see them bikakari
decides that him and his boy panda will
go over the Tokyo 2 Colony while Yuji
and mega me will head into the number
one and Carrara stays outside of the
barrier by the way it's recently come to
my attention that apparently Carrara is
neither a male or a female so apologies
for not realizing that in the last video
but it does go to show just how like in
touch Giga is dude just knows everything
that's going on with our culture and
today's generations and all I absolutely
love it anyway Curry plans to handle
this mysterious Hajime kushimo himself
since they're the player with the most
points and likely as the strongest Yuji
begins to bring up their perhaps he and
Megami shouldn't travel together due to
how zakona has been acting hella sus
with him recently however Megami just
tells Yuji to just shut up and stop
being so self-centered because the
others can't exactly change their roles
after a little squabble between the boys
it skips forth to 12 p.m the next day
when everyone all reaches their
designated barriers inside of Tokyo
before entering Korean explains to them
that inside the barriers the lethal
competition no one is the culling game
is taking place and asks that the new
players are willing to enter and declare
their participation in the game and
probably the exact same time Mega me
Yuji Panda and Hikari don't hesitate and
all agree to enter her diving straight
into Tokyo Colony number one we find
this babe hanyu asking for a signal from
a dude she's forcing to work for her
called Ren he tells her that he can't do
anything though if no one shows up which
leaves hanyu annoyed she activates her
curse technique snapping your hair to
this real like topaz looking chair on
her back and threatens to run run over
if he mounts her off again outside and
approaching the colony Megami explains
to the absolutely confused Yuji that
they just need to be weary of incarnated
sorcerers that have lived throughout the
past eras still somehow confused over
this Mega me says that some of the
players are from over a thousand years
ago and even those from only a hundred
or two hundred years ago have a
completely different mindset compared to
the modern day ones first and foremost
they are Sorcerers who valued life
differently and fighting to the death
was a normal thing for them some people
even desire to achieve an honorable end
in battle and that's why Mega me thinks
they've agreed to become players to
achieve the warrior-like deaths they
couldn't before nigami doesn't believe
that they'll be able to negotiate with
past Sorcerers to which juji adds on
that they need to be wary not of just
people but curse Spirits as well they
knock on the barrier wall of Tokyo
Colony number one and immediately
cocaine appears to greet them it
announces that the culling game is
taking place inside and anyone who
enters will become a player in the
deadly competition Megami declares his
participation but oddly like maybe you
guys all saw but maybe doesn't exactly
pick up on it here kogay never asks Yuji
if he actually wants to join the game
determined to save his sister though
Mimi reminds Yuji that the first move is
to get information on hiromi higuruma
the duo steps inside the barrier however
they both suddenly separated sent
randomly to different locations inside
of the colony Yuji finds himself falling
from the sky confused by his
circumstances while also wondering where
in the world Mega Millers as then
explained to us that when a player
enters the game's barrier they're
transferred to one of nine different
locations student individuals position
themselves at those locations to
literally spawn Camp unsuspecting people
who don't know this unspoken rule it's
giving back over to the sump who's
actually just one of those spawn campers
he notices Yuji falling from the sky and
uses a guiding like baton to Signal hanu
using uku's technique to propel herself
can you bursts through the air raming
directly into the chest of Yuji she
carries on and smashes them straight
through two buildings with an attack
that would have utterly pulverized most
players however you hear just freaking
built different like man is constructed
of a different material and somehow he
quickly recovers from the impact
surprising hanu sliding back across the
roof of a building Gucci manages to get
some foot in and takes his fighting
stance recognizing her opponent's
toughness hanu calls her partner to her
side but Yuji quickly throws a rock he
picked up in the previous attack they
had tanu in her stomach seriously
injuring her heavily injured she slowly
begins to lose altitude before falling
into the building below her behind a
surprised Yuji hanyu's partner who's the
type bulky ass dude called hubba appears
using his helicopter-like curse
technique to levitate he angrily demands
to know what Yuji has done to his woman
over on a nearby building Ren notices
that helper has appeared and that hanu
was easily taken down thinking on this
newcomer for a second Ren thinks that he
might know him before remembering
someone named itadori meanwhile mikami
who I tell you ain't no simp knocks down
a female player and draws his curse talk
she asks him why he'd do that but Mega
me angrily replies that it's because she
literally attacked him he asked this
hella cute girl like oh my Lord that
hairstyle is too freaking fire like
chill anyways anyways he asks her
for important hug Aroma but she
instantly starts acting difficult she
says that she'll only give him the
information if he acts as a night and
protects her reluctantly anad agrees but
not the way she wants which annoys her
he tells her to walk in front of her and
only promises to protect her if she's
telling the truth if this isn't the case
he implies that he'll literally go demon
time on your ass and get some points
unlike Yuji Mega me literally does not
care about racking up 100 points on his
own if need be unintimidated though the
girl responds with a devious smirk and
tells me to instead call her Remy back
over the battle with Yuji he begins his
fight with hubba by tossing his Stone
charged with cursed energy directly at
him this doesn't pose much of a threat
though as he easily destroys it with his
fast rotating propeller saying this Yuji
uses the opening to close the distance
he runs across the roof of the building
and uses his correct physical strength
to LEAP into the air grabbing his
enemy's leg he then flanks his ass
directly down and drags him through the
side of the building utterly destroy
nerds hubba manages to get loose and
tries counter-attacking but Yuki sees it
in time and decides to retreat he
realizes the harbor isn't taking
advantage of The High Ground and only
attacks with a weapon on his head by the
way I just noticed but both of the
people ugs fought here so far have had
some like weird ass obsession with
turning their heads into some sort of
like military vehicle like hanu's got
her jet here and obviously this dude's
got some kind of fetish for helicopters
anyways anyways Yuji ends up leading the
student doors where it's much more
confined however hubba instantly drops
down after Yuji confident that his
propellers can literally shred through
everything inside finding home hubba
spins towards his opponent head first
like a drill attempting to a blitz erase
everything and his path thinking Yuki
believes that hanyu was easily defeated
because of her hair based technique that
left the rest of her body unguarded by
cursed energy but no matter how tough it
is the kid will always remain a vital
spot so as long as he can hit them
without touching the propellers you see
is confident that he'll be able to
destroy his opponent as his adversary
finally closes in yujiko's pure demon
mode and punches hubba directly in the
top of the head and simply stopping him
in his tracks and leaving the bulked up
dude bleeding from the top of his head
still despite his brain getting
absolutely pinged around inside of his
own skull hubba remains standing he
begins laughing and overconfidently
assumes that Yuji had broken his hand
then just as he says that Yuji is
finished our boy just doesn't even care
and casually finishes hubba off with a
kick sitting and flying back through the
corridor standing there shaking off the
damage that he just took usually
realizes that he still needs to ask this
man about her garuma yet as the confused
Yoji goes to ask him Ren suddenly
appears behind him saying that he knows
about hagaruma and asks if Yuji actually
remembers him Ren by the way is just
another random dude from like a sister
school to Eugis that kinjaku has
probably done the duty with he wasn't
friends with Yuji and yujifily enough
doesn't even recall who he is here Ren
notices that Yuji is obviously
suspicious of him so he says he really
only knows him as the tiger of West
Junior High which embarrasses Yuji back
with mikami as he walks through the
streets of the Remy he asks her if she's
not a sorcerer from the past she
confirms she's from the modern day
prompting Mega me to question her reason
for fighting to which he explains that
plays who began inside the colony have
been experiencing the culling game for
12 days already she's not participating
in the game to win most people like her
are just trying to survive Remy claims
that she's seen players go mad with
power and tells Mega me to stop thinking
in terms of time periods as it's
pointless now hearing this they give me
realizes that he accidentally mislead
Yuji with their plans earlier due to
this Mega me tells roomy to wait up and
reveal where she's leading home
instantly raging at him though redmi
refuses because migami could simply
eliminate her after he gets this
information but he argues that he could
lose like a rumors location if Remy ends
up dying at the same time she asks
renway's helping since he was just with
the previous Sorcerers but Ren reveals
he was being forced to work with them
and would have been eliminated soon
anyway hearing this Yuji finally stops
and asks where her garuma is then
there's some pure cheekiness as revealed
through Wren and Remy they had a groom
his location as in one of two different
areas so obviously one person is lying
here Ren claims hegaruma is an ikibukuro
or Remy says that he's in Shinjuku
having both gained this info separately
Yuji and migami hope that the other is
headed to the same destination yet as we
know one of them is indeed being misled
and it's instead shown that someone has
actually taken them to another
mysterious but absolutely ripped man
hoarding receipts skipping away for a
second we go into a flashback where we
find friend and any other student who
are approached by bullies big brain Wren
using his like 1000 IQ didn't stand up
to the aggressors but he knew how to act
so that the bullies wouldn't get
agitated and would instead stop
bothering him he knew the bullies were
arrogant despite not being smart or
athletic so he focused on staying out of
their way here we smiled and went with a
flow even at other people's expense
because nobody would bother him however
in that same instance how young Legend
refuses to sit by and watch someone else
get bullied Ren who was just standing
there just assumed that another
had showed up who didn't know like how
to avoid trouble but it turned out to be
the infamous tiger of West Junior High
big freaking Yuji itadori the bullies
attempted to beat on the newcomer but
all three of them are utterly photorized
and brutally knocked out just by a
single hit age turning to Ren yuhi asks
if he's next but Rin was just too
shocked and could only stutter in
response skipping back to reality and
over with the two lovebirds is a hit off
at a station migami immediately
expresses some concerns about going
through ikibu Toro he believes that they
should have taken a more direct route to
Shinjuku instead but Remy argues that
the route is simple for her and she has
a base nearby which she wants to rest
and bathe meanwhile Ren takes Yuji to a
theater aniki bukuro the heger rumor
uses as his base excited to have quickly
located his Target Yuji thanks Ren
consumed though Ren asks Yuji if he's
really going to go inside alone to which
he says that he's in a hurry to meet up
with an ally and assures run that he'll
be able to escape if anything goes wrong
Yuji like the Happy he is Skips
off into the theater without a care in
the world while Riddler means sitting
idly by unable to stop him after
entering the theater and rolling down
some stairs someone else introduces
himself as Reggie but as per usual with
gigay and him skipping around all
throughout this like section of the arc
right here he's not greeting Yuji No in
fact migami has walked into an ambush of
his own inside of Remy's so-called base
where another player was indeed waiting
for him Reggie reveals to mikimi that
Remy had tracked item which immediately
seems bigamy into an utter rage pissed
off he looks back at Remy who simply
tries to taunt him now that she is
supposedly safe not worried at all
though our female loving Mega me tells
her to shut up then instantly summons
has a Divine dog totality stating that
they're wasting his time remember how
Yugi was just surprised before this well
Yuji upon entering the theater finds
hegoroma chilling in a freaking bathtub
filled with water while he's still fully
clothed in his suit but man I love
higaroma dude gets the coolest
introductions and honestly looks so
freaking clean here I'm not sure what
film as well this is from but I know for
a fact that this whole clothed and
chilling in a bathtub is definitely from
a movie that I've seen but I just can't
remember the exact one right now anyway
lying there and that Belle Delphine holy
bath water hegaruma claims that it feels
better than he expected we're just like
holy dude chill man he explains that
he's going off the rails and doesn't
care about anything anymore so he's
trying stuff he never thought he would
have done in the past Harry and ramble
Yuji finds it kind of funny but since
he's the Pro-Tech he tries to get
straight to the point and asks the
suited man to talk but the lawyer claims
it cost 5000 Yen per every half hour
hegaruma says that this was just a joke
though because he wanted to play the
part of a greeting lawyer for once Yuji
who's obviously like yo what the is
this dude on quickly realizes that he's
not an incarnated sorcerer from the past
to do a genius itadori deducing this he
believes that they can communicate and
make a deal instead of fighting but you
know if you go for Remy's saying then
right now Yuji is utterly stuffed either
way and won't be able to tour anyways
anyways YouTube Reveals His and mega
me's points plan but hearing it
hagarumita climbs Because he believes
the Cunningham presents a few
possibilities he's interested in so
obviously our ex-loy has gone a little
bit nuts here with his sudden power and
wants to know more about the rules of
the Cullen game in comparison to that of
societies he Guru presents the question
of what if the Cullen game punished rule
Breakers without charges prosecutions or
trials we're fully in that Law and Order
Arc right now boys Japan's Rogue lawyer
recognizes that the rules of the game
aren't perfect but he still doesn't
preserve the basic mechanics of the game
and see the curse technique removal
process for himself Yuji who's probably
like just chill man tries to get
hegaruma to understand that the culling
game is a ritual for sacrificing
everyone in Japan but he just doesn't
believe it instead he points out that
the cullingham's rules celebrate
permanence something Yuji can't argue
with because he literally doesn't even
understand it himself when Innovative
options and patience Yuji let the muscle
hide ears Ops for his own form of
persuasion getting ready to throw some
freaking hands he demands that he let
him use his points however soaking wet
just like myself after reading this Arc
hegaruma stands up out of the tub and
asks Yuji if he's ever killed anyone
then armed with the gavel in his hand
and his shikagami by his side hegaruma
claims that it feels better than he ever
expected standing opposite him Yuji
knows hegoroma has eliminated at least
20 players because of this he decides to
stay on the defensive to anticipate an
attack unexpectedly though you he is
caught off guard as her groomer
instantly activates his own main
expansion deadly sentencing noting the
immediate danger you rushes the lawyer
and tries to attack him before the
kurstick knee can activate Yuji throws a
head kick but his foot slows and slops
right before it can reach his opponent
higuruma explains to him that his domain
forbids the use of physical violence on
each other which causes Yuji to be
transported back to the other end of his
Court's room judgment which is the name
of the shukigami begins stating that
Yuji is Under Suspicion of entering the
Pachinko parlor on July 16 2017 and
Sendai City despite being underage Yuji
isn't sure what's happening at first
until he remembers The Parlor the
Judgment was referring to as per usual
Yuji literally can't lie and makes it
pretty obvious that he has been there
higuruma explains that judgment knows
everything about everyone and the domain
it's explained that hegaruma isn't privy
to all of this information beforehand
and the verdict is solely decided by the
arguments presented in this courtroom
additionally as a confused Yuji reacts
to this some evidence in a folder
randomly appears that's been submitted
by judgment to be looked over it's not
necessarily conclusive but our boy who
physically like cannot lie won't be
informed of what's inside either instead
his goal is to defend his case and
dispel all doubts to win an innocent
verdict from judgment so yes well you
all thought the perfect preparation Arc
was crazy with some of the techniques
like Remy's and how they all worked but
I can tell you for a fact that father
Giga was just warming up as holy pencil
right there like my brain writing these
scripts sometimes and figuring out how
these techniques exactly work as mental
everything just feels so well thought
out with him anyways anyways this
trial-based Goose technique makes Yuji
realize that he's being prosecuted by an
actual lawyer the absence of a fatal
attack in hagarumus domain makes you
remember a past convo worthy thumb or
explain that a domain expansion was a
more common technique for Sorcerers of
the past because they didn't incorporate
guaranteed hurts what is different to
today's as I think so far throughout the
series everyone who's cast a domain has
had a sure hit guarantee old school
domains used to be used in such a way to
force people to obey specific conditions
of the occurs technique constructing a
domain will can't miss attack like
dickons or jogos for example requires a
lot of skill and the number of users
will theme heavily decreases over time
due to them fighting obviously which is
why most people have to bear on
Surviving this short hit domain to
defeat the enemy whereas Yuji surmises
that hegoroma's domain as the old school
type meaning it isn't necessarily lethal
and can't physically harm him if he
sticks to the conditions that hagaruma
explained beforehand continuing to
explain a rumor says that both
participants each have one chance to
make a statement once both parties have
made their case against each other
judgment will deliver a verdict Yuji
asks what happens if he's found guilty
the hagarumer isn't sure how to answer
that question instead he tells Yuji
here's one of three options as a
response silence confession or denial
surprised juji asks if it's fine if he
lies in court to which hikaroma points
out that there will be no need for
trials if everyone was just honest in
their first place then tells Yuji to
hurry his slow ass up and make his
statement because judgment is impatient
taking a moment Yuji thinks about how to
properly defend him self he knows that
he did go into the pachenko parlor that
day and even won on the machines this
means that line is his way to get off
clean but he isn't sure what the
evidence is after going over all of the
hypotheticals if you decide to go with
the second option which was confession
and claims that he only went inside the
building to use the bathroom however
hagarum is a part of the goddamn
Yu-Gi-Oh universe and had set up his
trap he instantly reveals it retorting
with the evidence which turns out to be
a damn photo of Yuji inside of the
Parlor using a cash exchange absolutely
dumbfounded with his own stupidity Fuji
face Palms while Sido Kaiba himself adds
that after gaining all of this evidence
it puts his supposed restroom story into
question because of this he states that
is certain Yuji into the Pachinko parlor
with the intent of playing on the
machines Yuji trying to be cheeky asks
the lawyer what law he's breaking in to
which is explained that the premises
forbids the entry of miners currently in
Japan there are unevenly laws for
actually punishing those miners over
this but it's still considered illegal
puzzled he's I said this is an unfair
trial puzzle he states that this is an
unfair trial because there's nothing he
could have said to win however hagarumu
reveals that Japan only forbids miners
to gamble meaning cash exchanges are
separate entities in themselves because
of this if Yuji wanted to win the
verdict all he actually needed to say
was that he'd never seen The pachenko
Parlor before having come to a
conclusion judgment finds Yuji guilty
sentencing him to confiscation finally
we can stop with all the Yip yep and get
to the proper Beatdown material and like
y'all don't realize this but after this
fight here we don't see Yuji for an
extremely long time to savor this fight
before we move on to some of the newest
and coolest characters in manga anyways
so randomly the domain is dispelled and
judgment disappears as it does so
hikaruma immediately attacks by throwing
his gavel which connects with yuji's arm
dealing way more damage than it should
have smelling blood in the water
hegaruma closes the distance and summons
his gavel back to his hand he then
charges it with cursed energy to
increase its size and proceeds to smash
through yuji's defense sending him
crashing through several seats in the
theater getting back up YouTube realizes
that he's in an even worse situation
than originally thought now he's
completely lost the ability to
manipulate curse energy but honestly
hegaruma probably got the worst match up
here as we all know for a fact that our
boy's physical strength is so damn
broken it's comparable to having a
freaking Heavenly restriction on himself
continuing to attack her groomer
launches and smashes down his Mallet
atop ug seeing it in time though Yuji
jumps back to avoid it but this insanely
big brain lawyer makes the gavel appear
in his other hand allowing him to
quickly attack yet again after the
barrage ends YouTube who had narrowly
managed to dodge trust a counter-attack
with an elbow bag Aroma instead of
switching hands like he just was now
morsely shape of the devil into a
flexible Hawk which manages to wrap
around yuji's elbow before tossing him
away it's actually crazy when you think
about how strong hagarumo really is like
the student didn't have a curse
technique up until extremely recently
and only in the basics of barrier
techniques by analyzing his own domain
expansion somehow there's some mad
genius had worked back from there and
gained an instinctive grasp of how to
reinforce his body with curse energy so
somehow within just 12 days of Awakening
hegaruma managed to blossom into a
fighter who's comparable to someone like
freaking an army or even meimei but
probably even stronger before entering
the colony so literally for no point he
exercised a few cursed spirits and then
soon after has eliminated at least 20
players becoming one of the two current
Front Runners in terms of points
standing there he asks Yuji if he can't
control his curse energy which confuses
him because he thinks hegaruma is the
reason for it but apparently the
confiscation penalty takes away the
person's ability to use techniques in
the first place so because Yuji doesn't
possess any kind of technique the
effects literally fell to stopping him
from utilizing cursed energy altogether
concerned over this haruma quickly
surmises that it must be due to an
incredible physical prowess determine
the crush Eugene with all of his might
higrumah shifts his gavel into a staff
and attacks with a flower of swings
using his insane agility though Lucy is
able to avoid each swing then grabs onto
the staff's middle section only for
hecaroma to make a theme instantly
vanish before he can pull it away
jumping back Yuki then kicks the bathtub
directly towards the lawyer however he
simply destroys it with his gevel
unleashing A Rush of water and broken
tub pieces erupting through the water
hegaruma increases his gavel to a
freaking massive size and slams it down
on top of Yuji however like someone
please explain to me how even this isn't
enough to crush Yuji it even freaking
impresses her garuma who Compares his
experience to fighting an indestructible
doll Yuji who realizes that he's in deep
water though considers hegaromistic name
to be exceptionally strong and things
that this muscles will mean that there's
some sort of relative weakness he
frantically records his interactions
beforehand and remembers the mental
notes he made about the trail-based
cursed neck then in a moment that plays
even me away every time I read it Yuki
calls out and demands a retrial like how
does he even know what this is in the
first place because of this it instantly
transports them both inside of the
domain to some sort of momentary safety
due to what happened in the previous
trial a Fuji doesn't confess his guilt
outright he can request a free trial
that can't be refused yet this play of
his utterly backfires is in this new
trial judgment announces that our boy is
being accused of mass murder and Shibuya
on October the 31st 2018. then like last
time hagarumo received some evidence to
go over but before he even has the
chance to speak who she immediately
confesses his Guild as we all know by
now he won't let alone can't lie and
will refuse to deny what happened
shocking the lawyer bleeding from his
eyes with rage the eraped Judgment
declares Yuji as guilty he punishes Yuji
with confiscation again as well as an
additional punishment which turns out to
be no other than the freaking death
penalty so for those of you who are
wondering yes this is the third time now
that a boy has been sentenced to death
in some kind of manner after judgment
gives Yuji his penalty hagarum is gavel
transforms into an Executioner's sword
which has the added effect of being able
to kill its targets with just one heart
hegaruma believes emphasizing with
people means understanding all of their
weaknesses but he can't help but
perceive that fragility itself is ugly
including Yushi everyone is weak and
ugly to himself regardless of their
aspirations to improve in life while
hagaroma continues screaming who he
tries to keep him back by launching
several theater chairs in his Direction
then penis cheeky old self luji throws
as a Jutsu hijacket of the strict Aroma
leaving her a moment to get in and
behind him quickly higgerum returns but
in that moment also notices Yuji who now
throws his hoodie and manages to block
the lawyer's sight momentarily dropping
to the floor Yuji throws a sweeping Kirk
a hagarumer who's somehow able to keep
up is able to just jump above it as he
floats there he can remove appears to
land his final blow but the Executioner
sword while Yuji below prepares to land
in Upper cards and the usual manga
fashion though we get absolutely cucked
as it goes away into a past conversation
between Mr Josie Kawa and her current
mentally insane lawyer there haggaruma
refuses to become a judge because he
felt like his Ambitions in life weren't
good enough let's explain that he's
reminded of his memory because Yuji for
some bizarre reason confessed to a crime
he did not commit the evidence on the
retrial was about sakona's Massacre and
hegaruma knows that Yuji wasn't the one
who committed that crime so he can't
seem to understand why Yuji would
confess to something that he didn't do
because of his confusion over this
hagarumo willingly deactivates The
Executioner's sword allowing yuji's
insanely strong uppercut like this is
just pure physical strength by the way
like look how ripped he is right now
boys this punch directly hits him in the
body probably cracking a rebel too and
seated him crashing back into the seeds
before he even bothers to get up and he
hurts he grew mistakes to Yoji that the
absence of reason or control signifies
non-components he adds that sakuna was
in position of the body and since Yuji
didn't surrender control willingly he is
innocent who he doesn't see it that way
though and he still claims
responsibility for it believing that
death really only occurred because he's
too weak Yuji who's still confused over
why he deactivated his technique in the
first Place asks him so getting back up
now hegaruma explains that he remembered
why he got into law in the first place
as there are still other weak people out
there who need his help heguruma invites
Yuji to sit down after he's gotten his
clothes back on and it creates the
government's 100 points however before
he does so he asks the young sorcerer if
he's ever killed anyone on purpose
twitch Yuji somebody responds that he
has then in a quick flash we see the
moments preceding keita's trial and how
hecaroma had brutally murdered the
prosecutor and judge thinking on this he
asks Yuji if he felt awful about it as
well
so that there officially brings the
first Beatdown of this like amazing
of this amazing colony to an end but one
thing I do want to say is I goddamn love
pick a roommate and I really really hope
that he sticks around any story after
this point even after the culling game
like ends it would be nice to have him
as a great addition to like the Jujutsu
Tech staff honestly I think he is just
truly a good person who is blinded by
just how Society is and his insane
increase in power that he just received
from kinjaku which makes me also wonder
are all these new techniques and modern
day civilians have found themselves
worth actually just another
reincarnation and instead of a person
being reincarnated it's technically a
curse technique itself that's being
placed inside of an individual who meets
the right conditions anyways now that
the two were just chilling out hagarumo
tells us cocaine to add a new rule to
the culling game that allows players to
transfer points between one another as
usually anxiously Waits cocaine relays
the message to the game master but just
moments later he breathes a sigh of
relief as the rule is allowed and
hegaruma transfers one of his points to
to Yuji so that neither of them will be
affected by cursed technique removal for
at least 19 days abruptly getting up now
and leaving her groomer says goodbye but
Yuji who's just like your weight up dude
asks him what he's going to do now he
explains to him that he wants to use
hegeuma's strength to help them in the
culling game but the law explains that
he killed a few people before coming to
Tokyo due to how he feels about this now
he wants to take responsibility and plan
to turn himself in once the barriers
reopen but until that time happens he's
going to ponder his best cause of action
and doesn't feel comfortable staying
around Yuji because it just makes him
hate himself even more sadly hegaruma
leaves the theater leaving our boy alone
to lament of this situation despite
accomplishing his goal now we move on to
the next round of heat boys seeking
massive Battle of this dopas Arc here I
don't know if you've seen like gigay's
recent posted with Hana and him honoring
Takashi sensei's ethereal level of
writing but dude said he hoped he could
warm the pages to a similar degree to
Takashi since his writing and years to
come I don't like actually believe how
humble all this goat is I he doesn't
realize he's already sitting his pages
on freaking fire and it's definitely
become one of the hottest dudes on the
Block where they constantly releasing
manga each week especially in the
western side of the world meanwhile and
over the other side of the Tokyo Colony
regica means mikami as he says he can
already tell that the young man is
strong just based on a shikigami
unbeknownst to Remy Reggie was actually
just using her to lure in potential
allies and now seeing migami here he
asks him to join their group and asks
what he knows about the culling game
well that means any Master thumb making
me reveals that it is a ritual for
bringing Japanese people to the other
side so that they're no longer
considered human hearing this
explanation Reggie cracks up and asks
smigami if he knows kinjaku surprising
the younger sorcerer as he had figured
he'd run into a person with a connection
to kinshaku sooner or later Richie
explains that the ritual explanation is
probably just the cover for kingjaku's
real plan and hold I don't want to spoil
anything I want to like catch up and
probably reveal like the true play
myself because Reggie may look like a
silly mofo but this dude is a genius for
stating this cheeky foreshadowing right
here continuing with his big brain
explanation assuming that 1 000 players
were equally divided among 10 colonies
Reggie suggests that each colony of a
hundred players is top heavy in regard
to the player's skill level players like
hashimo and hegoroma are much stronger
than most of the other combatants and
between the two of them they have
already eliminated roughly 60 players
within just the first 12 days which
makes sense to Megami is like the Tokyo
calling number one has been extremely
quiet ever since he entered he asks
Reggie if all these strong have already
waited out all of the Wake that's early
on in the game and if the game has
reached a deadlock due to those
circumstances Reggie confirms this then
goes on to explain that the transferal
process isn't just a way to spread out
players but actually a way to stimulate
a second Awakening of new modern day
peoples curse techniques some of the
Waker people even die during their
transfer process but this doesn't
benefit the ritual in the same way that
a drawn out merely would Reggie drops a
freaking bomb saying that kinjaku is
currently overseas in China meeting with
the government officials there so like
why is that Beijing I don't know what Mr
G and his boys are doing over there but
anyways he explains that he's pretty
soon that kinshaka will drop his own
metaphorical bomb on all of the players
once Only The Strongest Ones remain at
that point Reggie believes the Cullen
game will have served its purpose so for
now he's just focused on Gathering
strong allies and storing points nikumi
asks how Remy fits into his plan because
she's obviously a weakling with no value
to which Reggie clarifies that Remy is
useful for learning people as they tend
to drop their guard around a woman
making me asks regi at the total points
of everyone in the group adds up to 100
to which originally confirms that they
have over a hundred points in total
having been confirmed on his suspicions
making me reveals that a new rule will
soon be added that allows players to
give points to each other he demands
that Reggie and all of his allies hand
over their points to him and only then
will they consider joining them
immediately Reggie is like oh oh well I
guess this tour has broken down causing
a random fodder player to shoot out
behind me me and try to attack him with
a set of claw hands so obviously this
dude is another of the guys I like to
call it body modification curse users
with Yuji we had the cap dude and of
course the rocket here girl now we've
got claw man right here Mega me manages
to slip into the Stone's Shadow then
there's this Divine dog attacks Reggie
he reappears from below the fodder claw
man picking him up and simply throwing
his ass off the side of the building
it's per usual though Megami always
double Taps his opponents and commands
in a way to dive from him shocking the
player and slamming him into the ground
below probably murking him back in the
building two kitchen knives are suddenly
shoved into the Divine dog's mouth
incapacitating the shikagami as Mega me
turns back Reggie says that he knows
what he's up to and wants his adversary
he'll die if he doesn't fight for real
on cue a random eye suddenly appears
over the side of the building next to
Mega me and abruptly detonates causing
an explosion which almost takes out even
Reggie above them we find a player named
iori hazanoki one of Reggie's allies and
another of those body modification users
the now one sorcerer begins breaking off
some more of his teeth while asking if
the target is dead however nigami is
saying quickly darting out of the smoke
and immediately avoiding a follow-up
attack sent by Remy he manages to grabu
here and slams her onto the ground
aggressively he asks her if she's
heading north but before she can answer
hazanoki jumps down from the floor above
and tosses his teeth at Mega me at the
same time Reggie also sends through a
few receipts that transform into gas and
splash all over Mega me soaking hum then
in some crazy ass combination with the
gasoline hazunoki detonates his teeth
resulting in a massive blast that erupts
through the top of the building
seemingly taking out both Remy and mega
me exit in a room Reggie asks if they're
finished but hazanoki says he saw megamy
duck into another room to avoid taking
damage inside of that said room making
me moves a door that he used to protect
himself in Remy and asks her if she
understands now as the explosions could
have easily killed her as well proving
that she's completely and utterly
disposable making me tries to leave her
behind but Remy attempts to stab him
again with her hair then certainly
switching up she desperately begs Mega
me to say that he likes her and then he
will protect her disgusted making me
realizes that Remy is the type of trash
who only cares about words rather than
someone's actions chizuru so like
remember that random dude making me
disposal right at the style of the
scuffle well it turns out he didn't
actually die and stupidly the man
decides to reach when they battle he
compliments Mega me for getting the
better of him before but notes that this
student must be in rough shape now he
mentions it was a pain scale in the
building and hearing this Mega me is
like yo what what are you dumb dude why
didn't you take the stairs suddenly both
of their vehicle games appear and
announce that a new rule has been added
to the culling game so this is obviously
the point in the arc that Yuji and
higgeruma's battle ends with them
finally adding that new rule surprise
and reinvigorated making me Smiles
instantly he restarts the fight kicking
he fought a full back and summoning his
prolific Max elephant which materializes
inside the building completely
destroying the upper floors as it comes
thundering down sticking with light in
itself nigami then uses no way to catch
himself allowing him to mount chizuru in
mid-air after getting on top and still
falling making me slashes his face over
and over with the health of a sword
before jumping off and kicking him into
the ground below having crashed heavily
into the ground Chooser who curses
mikami yet before he can even get up
Mega me who ain't no damn Yuji simply
slashes his face open with his sword and
eliminates him for a moment make me
questions what he's doing because I need
more points in the future but quickly
refocuses by reminding himself that
tsukomi won't have to participate in the
Kelly now as cocaine rewards him with
five points migami reaffirms to himself
that he just needs to deal with the
difficulties as they come descending
down to ground level with their
opponences Reggie has left surprise and
even embarrassed by chizuru's lack of
skill back with our boy he notices that
he's still at number two to one and is
now feeling the effects of the first
explosion thinking on what to do for a
moment he deduces that he can't Flay or
use his domain expansion because the
environment still isn't compatible with
his technique before he can think up of
anything to do hasn't Nokia abruptly
spits out another one of his bomb teeth
but completely and utterly out of
nowhere someone literally no one saw
coming showed up until they blast face
first like an actual champion to protect
him as all of them stand there utterly
confused the newcomer named for Mexico
takaba who was the failing comedian that
I introduced right at the end of the
previous Jitsu Kaizen video or it might
even be the one before that one now well
he and one of them might Superhero level
voices states that two-on-one fights are
unfair and calls Richie and his minion
complete cowards he adds that their
attacks have done zero damage however
it's shown that the attack completely
busted open his face and hid making it
clear that he was in fact hurt confusing
Mega me looking at Mega me takaba
decides to help him because their 35
year old can tell whether someone is
good or bad just by their face yet after
looking at him again he realizes that
Mega me actually has a bad face but
writes it off is all revisionist which
is just obviously wrong I mean to say
relative making his just left stun with
this new person but regardless of his
personality this random man just saved
him so the Jiu Jitsu High student is
willing to trust him for now Regine
hazunoki don't even recognize takaba
they try asking what time period is from
to cover though who isn't even listening
to them explains that his costume is
based on a funny superhero causing his
intimidation factor to suddenly flare up
while preparing to tell another
absolutely terrible joke the enemy Duo
prepare for an attack but to cover darts
into a JoJo whisk pose and tells a joke
they could say did silent reaction
takaba screams that damn it's a tough
crowd but continues to Hype himself up
nonetheless even though his opponents
are stiff takaba will continue to do
what he does best because he's an
Entertainer of the highest degree he
screams flying forward and delivering an
insane double-footed flying dropkick
that connects with hazanoki's face
sending him crashing into a nearby
building sending there Reggie notes the
shift into Carver's output of curse
energy and quickly realizes that the
failing comedian is actually super
strong takaba stunting on all of them
does a handstand while explaining that
he's an old school performer who's
pro-violence using the Kim confusion to
his Advantage Megami tries to launch a
surprise attack on Richie from his own
shadow but his foe manages to jump away
from the ground in time to avoid it now
back with his new teammate migami tries
to explain to him as a noki's exploding
body part but only ends up getting
annoyed telling takaba to stop getting
so close to his face bringing out
cocaine they use him to confirm that
hegaruma was indeed the one who added a
new role he's surprised and is sure to
see that Yuji had completed their
mission because of this he states that
he's done with this colony and tells
Reggie he'll let him go if he backs off
Richie just straight up annoyed now
refuses because he needs to make up for
his teammates lost points over in their
absolutely ruined building hazunuku
recovers from the Dropkick that he just
suffered and calls out to zakaba the
comedian though still just absolutely
ignores him and instead introduces
himself properly to Mega me since tacaba
is most likely going to end up killing
the bomb guy making me requests that he
take hazanoki's point if possible to
which he accepts on the condition that
he continues to entertain as first and
foremost he is a performer satisfied
takaba begins sparking almost exposing
himself to the young man while hazanoki
in return sends an explosive eye directs
the atom not phase to cover simply
knocks it away with a random paper fan
he manages to close the distance on his
opponent sliding in behind him and
utterly destroying his rectum with pervy
sages Infamous 1 000 years of pain seen
in his enemy into a severe belt of pain
enraged and getting utterly photorized
as the Noki swings at him but takaba
immediately follows up with a powerful
kick to his dorm that sends his opponent
through another building standing there
Mega measly flabbergasted with takaba's
show of strength and expresses that he's
glad he isn't his enemy twister Carver
tells him to stay alive while he goes
off and pounds his opponents some more
over with Reggie he stands there
thinking that zakaba is toast either way
because hezonoki will go all out after
being mocked so much with his objective
complete Megami tells his adversary to
worry about himself so that he can fight
him for real instantly he summons his
max elephant leaving Reggie blown away
they're making me have such a large
chickagami in his Arsenal Max elephant
attempts to spray regime with a torn of
water but he somehow manages to dive
away from the burst attempting to take
him by surprise he can be leaps from the
building above but Richie notices in
time and throws a receipt which
transforms into a net and ensnares the
recently created rabbits Mega me himself
though narrowly avoids the net and jumps
onto a chain-linked fence to break his
fall as Mega me jumps back into the road
rigid activates his innate curse
technique contractual Recreation and
transforms several receipts into kitchen
knives those in knives fly forward
towards mikami as projectiles but he's
able to deflict them with a blade of his
own some rabbits are pierced by these
knives allowing rigidism eyes that
unlike the other shikigami they can
reappear regardless of how many are
destroyed which he figures that migami
has likely figured out how acoustic Nick
Works due to this he uses a receipt to
recreate the contract and endows himself
with a relaxing two night stay at a
five-star Japanese Inn in contrast Mega
Millions worn down from the constant
fighting on top of having you seem
lowering his overall capacity Bridget
surmises that Miami can't reconjour his
shikigami after they're injured and
without the flexibility the Divine dog
provides him he's Limited in his options
the old school ads that both of them
lack big finishing moves and will need
to pick away at each other over time to
achieve Victory torch Megami is like
yeah bro in that case I'm absolutely
so I'm a run for now out of
nowhere no waiting swoops down grabbing
Mega me however Reggie quickly summons
the trash taste boys drones equipped
with the lost luggage cameras to follow
his opponents through the sky while he
watches on a phone then summoning your
moped Reggie begins to pursue his
adversary through the streets and tracks
migami's position to a gymnasium Reggie
questions whether he really tried
escaping or if he's in fact trying to
lure the fight inside of the gym Mickey
is glad to see that the area is spacious
looking up though he suddenly sees
Reggie appear on the balcony who asks
what his opponents is plotting making me
replies that big Reggie is likely
planning something as well and the
letter claims that it's hard to tell
because Sorcerers are nothing but con
artists which is completely utterly true
and I love the whole idea of Reggie's
thoughts on Sorceress here it's all
about like conning your enemy into
believing you've played your final move
but actually you've just laid a trap and
con him into a false sense of security
anyways with the main part of this
absolutely insane battle begin suddenly
two trucks appear out of nowhere and
come crashing through the walls of the
building acting quickly making me is
just able to slip under the vehicles yet
as he watches them crash into the other
wall two potted plants are recreated
above Mega me they drop down onto his
head cracking his skull open Richie
follows up by repeatedly slicing
megamy's back and left arm with a small
knife Megami tries to retreat but gets
distracted by the unorthodox projectile
Richie had just created he's taken off
guard when these silly old carrot begins
to break apart and reveals a hidden
kitchen knife inside shooting forth the
nice stabs directly into migami's elbow
while Richie then follows up with a
brutal front kick to his face having
been knocked down Mega me slides across
the gym floor thoroughly overpowered
it's explained though the things Reggie
recreates behave like shikigami
obviously knives and other things like
that can't normally fly through the air
but Reggie is able to get them to do so
with a single command big freaking Mega
me though a man made of a much darker
material response by stating that
barrier techniques are difficult for him
and he's simply unable to make an
artificial environment over a real one
however Megami doesn't need to
physically create a barrier no instead
he can use the entire gymnasium as a
perfect space for his domain as planned
Mega me casts has got a damn domain
expansion the insane Chimera Shadow
Garden and forcibly encloses the barrier
around the gym to trap Reggie inside
ceiling has faked Richie who really
didn't think migami was a sorcerer
capable of using domain expansion as
utterly taken by surprise immediately
though he activates his special
anti-domain technique called Hollow
wicker basket which if you see my video
going over like all of the jjk barrier
types you know that this is the original
4 of the current simple domain Reggie
believes he successfully protected
himself from the domain until four toads
appear from the liquid below his feet
and wrap up both his legs with their
tongues confused where he doesn't
understand how he's been hit after using
Hollow wicker basket and to explain that
technically Reggie's technique does
nullify this seed guaranteed hit from a
domain but because megami's domain isn't
complete and doesn't actually have a
can't miss attack it only serves as an
extension to his cursed energy and Tin
Shadows technique that soul and
Perfection has taken Reggie off guard
and mega me notices his expression
change before Reggie can finish berating
Mega me for getting cocky he's ambushed
by two Shadow clones Reggie is unable to
avoid the barrage of hairs due to the
Toad's times preventing his movements
after getting pummeled over and over
Richie falls back to the ground and
summons combat knives to sever the
Toad's tongues free to move again he
summons a machete and prepares the
counter attack however nigami's client
prevents Richie from gaining any
momentum by coming up from below to grab
his League then the Clone throws Reggie
towards me to give his main body who's
also armed with his sword and already
bringing it down on Reggie somehow
though Reggie is able to block this
attack like his reflexes are literally
insane here but now the only reverse
cards being played by our boy and it's a
three-on-one with the other Shadow clone
appearing and elbowing him directly in
the dome heavily damaged now regi just
narrowly defends a slash from Mega me
and commends the Sorcerer for his
increased function of the curse
technique considering it worse than a
lethal domain Reggie is aware that if
Megami uses Max elephant and showers him
with water he'll lose this fight
refusing to allow that to happen he
activates his coustic neck and releases
a multitude of receipts into the air
above his head making me tries to
destroy the receipts using no way but
it's just not quick enough to stop
ridge's contractual Recreation from
activating three cars are suddenly
generated from the receipts was shot
straight into the shadowy floor Reggie
understands that the entire domain is
migami Shadow but notice that Megami has
only kept one curse tool on onto the
length of this entire fight he theorizes
that this is because me Jimmy has the
barely weight of anything kept within a
shadow and now Reggie is using the cast
to turn the domain's conditions back on
mikami heavy mean forced to the ground
under the immense weight Richard
believes migami might be able to summon
shikigami still so he keeps his guard up
and plans to keep on piling weight until
his opponent is completely crushed Mega
me though like we all learned this
throughout the first battle against that
silly old cursed womb he literally is
insane and the dude does not care about
life anymore to the point that he tells
Reggie he's forgotten something
important who reminds him that an
incomplete domain is still a domain and
there is Shadow All Around the both of
them Megami who doesn't care certainly
conscious Max elephant from these
Shadows above Reggie causing the massive
shikigami to drop down directly on top
of him having turned their fire into a
10 weightlifting competition nikkimi
remains confident as he asks Richie
which of the two of them will be crushed
first as explained that the average
human being can withstand about five to
six units of G-Force before losing
Consciousness making me weigh 60
kilograms and is currently carrying 2.4
4 tons of weight which equates to 40
units of G-Force a fully matured
elephant weighs three to six tons and
megami's domain increases the Precision
of his curse technique replicating Max
elephant's weight realistically with an
intense weight falling atop him Reggie
fractures his right fibula and heel bone
due to the pressure alone hidden laments
over not saving the trucks he used
earlier for more weight at this moment
he's been soaked with water by Max
elephant but there are still receipts he
can release including the special Ace
that he has up a sleeve Reggie wonders
if he can enter the shadow below him to
release his Ace and finish off Mega me
he dismisses this idea though because
anything caught in the shadow after it's
dispelled might be unable to escape
furthermore he's unsure of what it's
actually like inside of this sticky
shadowy substance he decides this option
is too risky and tries to withstand the
elephant's weight while releasing his
Ace attack regi attempts to hold up the
elephant with one arm while taking out
another receipt but before he can fully
activate his contractual Recreation
Regis Academy to Max elephants immense
weight and falls into the shadow below
him without any buoyancy or resistance
inside of the Shadow Reggie Falls and
begins to lose Consciousness due to the
lack of oxygen laying there above his
likely defeated opponent making me wait
until he's sure that Reggie is dead
before dispelling the domain and
emptying his shadow suddenly and coming
back like a damn King riding one of his
cars would he flies back exploding
through to the surf first rescue from
certain demise now he can means making
me strength and admits he's a strong
sorcerer before immediately stating that
he's even stronger though he activates
another contractual Recreation and
summons a swore two-story freaking
wooden house that weighs at least 30
tons to crush mikami in the next second
Mega me makes an extremely drastic move
despite using his Ace Richie somehow
abruptly finds himself underwater again
and being strangled from behind as
explained now Mimi is using his extreme
weight to drown Richie but because of
just the immense Force that's being
placed on him he has to deactivate the
cursing and then register the weight of
the objects before he does actually end
up dying himself coming to Reggie is
able to swim back to the surface and
realizes that he's inside of a pool on
the basement level of the gymnasium
making me fled back into his shadow and
entered the domain making it so that the
house broke the floor and forced Reggie
into the pool below it's unclear how
mikimi was able to move despite the
immense weight but Reggie theorizes that
he did so by ejecting himself from his
shadow kind of like a seesaw making me
strolls up on his opponent and tells
Reggie his receipts are too weak to use
now normally splashing the receipts with
water isn't enough to make the print
fade so that alone isn't enough to stop
Reggie from reducing things however so
can the receipts prevents Reggie from
fulfilling the condition that requires
burning of the receipts Reggie also
notes that making me can't summon
shikigami anymore to which the sorcerer
agrees stating that from now on this is
a straight up physical fight to the
death Reggie though doesn't actually
believe this he expects megaming to
summon a sugigami and plans on
countering Megami as soon as he leads up
dartinan Reggie's initial beta Tech gets
palmed off but as he planned he uses
that momentum to send megami's sword arm
bouncing back having no defense left
Reggie lifts loose with a multitude of
kicks smashing the young sorcerer over
and over again making me admits that
Reggie is a tough opponent made evident
by his ability to withstand Max elephant
he's also a talented martial artist with
some really dopas techniques but he just
isn't fast enough just before Reggie is
able to land a direct hit on Megami a
portion of the far left side of Reggie's
face his ear and much of his left
shoulder are completely sheared off by
someone he thought that he dealt with
already having suffered a lethal blow at
blinding speed Reggie looks back to see
no one other than the Divine dog
totality which is just pissed atom by
the dog even has two scars in its nose
from the knives it's explained that Mega
me was waiting until Reggie had
completely dismissed the dog and hearing
this Reggie repeats that a sorcer is
indeed nothing but a con artist as he
collapses to the ground and a pole of
his own blood Reggie lays bleeding out
on the ground looking up at Mega me and
realizes that the domain and the Paul
concealed that Mega me could still
strike with his Divine dog megaming
didn't flee into the gym using no way
instead hit Lord of Richie inside
standing above him making me inquires as
to what ridge's relationship to master
tinken is it's Sean but there really
isn't much of a relationship he only
knows him as the hermit who is Immortal
and isn't surprised to find out he's
still alive at this time defeated with
dignity Reggie tells his cocaine to
transfer all 41 of his points to Mega me
which a boy is a little annoyed about
but Reggie tells him to just consider it
a good deed before death he ads that
he's just a spectator and isn't close to
kinjaku at all well his final words said
Richie tells his executioner to let fate
toy with him before he also dies like a
fool moments later mikimi receives five
points for the death of Reggie Starr
damn it's actually such a firefight like
I love how much foreshadowing for future
events are papered throughout the story
here like is that how Megami is going to
end up dying having sukuna who is fate
in this context I guess toy with him
before he kills him like a fool and
again those who are like past chapter
200 now also know big Richie was correct
when it came to this just being the
beginning of something even larger back
to the fight over the other side of the
city a massive explosion a set off on
the roof of a building hazanoki who's
still fighting with takaba wonders if
he's finally had his Target yet the
comedian appears right beside him and
comically encourages him to stay focused
because his opponent is a tough one
until continuously irritated by takaba's
Antics hazanuki tries to punch him only
for his first slide off this new dude's
weird Saucy coating hazanuki is just
really frustrated by this fight as he
doesn't understand why takaba won't take
any damage regardless of how many times
he gets bombed kogane interrupts the
battle for a moment to inform them both
that Reggie has been eliminated surprise
hazunoki decides to walk away from the
fight entirely initially takava is fine
with us telling his opponent to bathe
and brush his teeth once he gets home
but after thinking for a moment and
sticking with the original plan takaba
starts to piss the hazinoki for his
points only to be repeatedly denied as
it skips away from them it's explained
that big fumuhiko's curse technique is
called comedian it's actually like too
broken of a technique so broken in fact
that it has the possibility to even
rival that of gojos by anything that
takaba thinks is kind of funny or is
funny in general becomes reality itself
for him but unfortunately noticaba is a
little bit mentally lacking and is
completely unaware of how this even
works Alice swear she's the stress
because she's always been told
throughout her life that men are
supposed to be wolves who would tear up
but they've always come to take care of
her which is what do you mean by getting
torn out a pin and New Zealand there's
some crazy ass slang anyways she doesn't
know how to go on and still thinks that
wolves will continue to help her until
she's cornered by a deadly Hound which
turns out to be migami's divine dog
before Megami can make good honest
threats to kumi's voice randomly appears
and tells her brother to stop before he
kills someone in Cold Blood causing his
Divine dog to disappear and Remy
surprised that she's been lit go annoyed
and just completely exhausted now making
me tell the sister to just shut up
before he collapses to the ground
unconscious just as happens though like
literally something I didn't even think
like happened throughout this Arc
happens no one other than the angel
herself hanakurasu descends upon his
body hold on just before we do jump into
the next part of the culling game though
did you know War Thunder is the most
comprehensive vehicle combat game ever
made you can jam on more than two
thousand tanks planes helicopters and
ships in Dynamic combined arms PVP
battles the collection of vehicles and
War Thunder spans over a hundred years
of development from the early 1920s to
the present day every vehicle is
incredibly detailed and modeled down to
the individual components offering a
highly immersive combat experience like
no other this isn't enough for you
weaves you can also download the anime
voice pack mods to alter the dialogue of
your crew what blew me away with this
game though wasn't the top of the line
Dynamic and detailed vehicle damage
models it ain't like the normal
generalized hit points that you usually
get instead Vehicles suffer proper
damage to specific components and their
crew a damage EXO shows exactly what
happens to you or your enemy's Vehicles
as it is damaged or destroyed my
favorite vehicle in the game is actually
the Japanese ah1s helicopter kisirazu
which can be purchased in game and
features an anime design actually used
by the Japanese self-defense Force you
can jam War Thunder for free now on PC
PlayStation 5 Xbox series X and S or the
previous console generation so do it by
clicking my link down in the description
option below or the top comment Plus
what's even better is that if you do use
my link you get a special 3D body pillow
that you can place at any location on
your tank along with a bunch of boosters
and a hundred thousand silver so I'll
see you in the game we have now left the
Tokyo Colony number one with Gucci and
mega me are to fly over to Keke's other
main character they no longer depressed
Yuta akotsu who's currently in the
Sendai Colony there are currently four
powerhouses at the center of the
conflict and just like the Tokyo Colony
Cinder here has also reached a deadlock
due to only the PowerHouse has been left
over drove lock dewala is a veteran of
the Civil War of War A Wharton which was
like literally him versus everyone else
so the dude must have been pure Insanity
it's explained that he currently sits at
91 points and has the ability to use two
kinds of independent shikigami that can
compose a domain with their like
orbiting thingies somewhere else inside
of the Sendai Colony we find a damn JoJo
character under the name of Ryu shigori
this man currently sits at 77 points and
has the highest curse energy output of
all of the players in The Killing game
so like does he even surpass Yoda
perhaps anyway shooting over to another
Powerhouse called takako uro as
explained that this babe of a character
is the former captain of the sun moon
and star Squad who are a group of deadly
assassins directly affiliated with a
fujiwara clan what you now own will the
fujiwara clan prospered for around 1200
years from the 600s dominating the
Imperial Court until 1868. so gigabin
Giga has probably taken her directly
from a specific time period throughout
those 1200 years and assuming she's
insanely strong it was probably during
the golden period or the hean period of
794 through 1185 where they held most of
their dominance in the court anyways
skipping over to this bug who's
kuroroshi which is a special grade
cockroach curse that kinjaku had
released from kiddo's curse Spirit
manipulation and it was probably one of
those like very few special grade
Skittles keeping hidden during the night
parade let's explain that it currently
has 54 points and is line dormant until
the unfavorable conditions disappear due
to their conflicting abilities in
Natures the four powerhouses forced
standoff rather than Alliance however
they did lock falls apart when one side
eventually collapses Drew flock to Wyler
you said old school fart is cut down by
Tokyo Jiu Jitsu highs infamous second
year student Utah akotsu who now has 35
points so like man has literally become
demon mode throughout this part of the
story remember how uh he had also lost
his uh ranking after the end of jjk zero
well it's explained here that he
reclaimed his rank three months after
the night parade of a hundred demons and
still possesses unusual strength second
only to satiro Gojo so the hype for this
battle is absolutely insane right now
takako and Ryu who are nearby observe
the developing situation and the Sendai
Colony due to Utah being himself to
reflect a while has fallen and is
patrolling shukigami are disappearing
Ryu uses his cocaine to check who
defeated dhruv and discovers the player
as due to akotsu takaku does the same
and while she's glad the ugly shikagami
are disappearing she's concerned about a
new threat that will surely emerge back
with Ryu he realizes that he was only
able to get close to Drew without
provoking him before because he was
occupied and battled Future these two
new Sorcerers both know that following
Drew's to fade kuroroshi will likely
emerge next back over with our boy
though after cutting down truth he
regroups with a crowd of civilians he's
been protecting he tells them that it's
time to head north at the edge of the
barrier but notices a mother and
daughter struggling to go on because of
this he changes his mind and tells all
of the civilians they can rest inside of
the stadium that was serving as Drew's
base suddenly though he's interrupted by
a buzzing and cluttering sound that
indicates some sort of danger due to
immediately orders everyone to hurry
inside of the stadium and he draws his
Katana he looks out and sees an
overwhelming swarm of cockroaches
chasing people it's funny like cutting
myself off for a second you know it's
like a mega miguji Fusion like The Best
of Both Worlds man will murk anyone when
necessary and also save the helpless as
much as possible anyways anyways ljjk
Hannah Montana jumps four thinking he
can save the remaining man but as Duty
grabs the man's arm he's unable to pull
him away in time and sadly the
cockroaches Devour the civilian's lower
body then as the Cockroaches jump from
the man's body to attack you to quickly
blocks with his Katana and notices that
all of the bugs are indeed real and sex
reinforce with cursed energy the Swarm
attempts to rush past Utah to ravage the
other civilians but he summons Reiki to
stop them the Demonic Powerhouse himself
then uses that curse level IQ and
smashes down on a bridge collecting the
structure on top of the Swarm forcing it
to go back towards Utah the special
grade sorcerer then abuses Katana with
curse energy and swings it with enough
Force to create a large blast of cursed
energy that disintegrates the whole
swarm in one shot watching the action
from afar Ryu comments that while yuda's
cursed energy output isn't anything
special his overall cursed energy
manipulation is extremely impressive
also observing tsukaku outro states that
YouTube's overall curse energy is
bottomless and that the Cockroach curses
are disgusting so this elbargo it's
explained that he was a poor matchup for
drove so to play things safe it went
into like a dormant Stace until droof
was eliminated the curse has an endless
ever appetite and eating stimulates its
ability to perform parthenogenesis which
in our monkey brain terms and that took
me five times to say just means This
creepy old bug can self-reproduce not
needing a male or female partner now
awakened the Cockroach curse is starving
and its instincts immediately lead it to
devour you to her while preparing the
face off against kuroroshi you'd upon us
his objective in this Colony he knows
his resources are finite and it's only a
matter of time before overall allowing
passage in and out of colonies is added
however dangerous players like truth
can't be allowed to leave the barrier
either with the likelihood that there
are other players just like him usually
knows that communication between
colonies is necessary to prevent anyone
dangerous from leaving them in addition
to the rules Megami proposed in the
meeting with tingen Yuta understands his
allies need a means of communication and
a way to move in and out of the colonies
so in total that's four rules the group
needs to create to get a handle on the
culling game which is actually insane
because that's at least 400 points or a
majority of the reincarnations kinjaku
has actually brought back anyways Yuda
feels at the Shibuya incident exhausted
all of his allies and he doesn't want to
make his sense say Keller's best friend
again poised and ready to engage the
enemy player with his Katana usually
resolves to kill kinjaku and obtain 400
points all on his own so let the
absolute bloodbath begin noticing yuda's
battle starts kuroshi bulks up and
reveals a curse talk called the
festering life sword an enchanted blade
that mixes life and death itself armed
with the festering life sword kuroroshi
ferociously attacks only to have his arm
immediately cut off by Yuta the sorcerer
then uses his Katana to pen the kusa's
arm to a rock literally disarming it by
turning the arm into a freaking barbecue
sword skewer you do then quickly follows
up with a dared level backhand strike
that since kuroroshi's getting back
across the water the Cockroach curse
tries to fly up above the bridge but
Yuda who's just too damn quick jumps on
top of the bridge first then grabs and
flings a piece of railing that hits
kuroroshi in the chest taking this
moment Yuda capitalizes on the opening
he created by sending kuroroshi down and
to the water below where they sick
diving slash as the water clears though
it's revealed that the curse managed to
stop you displayed by using a swarm of
cockroaches you just swipes this one
away with a sword while kuroroshi
manipulates his bugs into a twister of
cockroaches to malevently stand on below
uterus aware that has been watched by
the two other players with high scores
he knows he can easily exercise kuroshi
by driving reverse curse energy into his
body in a similar fashion to how he
revived Yuji in their fall out however
Yoda doesn't want the observing players
to see that he can use a reverse curse
technique additionally he can't call
Enrique because she's protecting
everyone else at the stadium kuroroshi
is indeed a dangerous opponent but Yoda
wants to exercise her without relying on
either of his two backup techniques out
of nowhere though this bug somehow
manages to speak which you know actually
makes sense it's over time special
grades can like easily develop a
language anyways it asks you to why he's
interfering with his fading referring to
her not letting him Munch down on those
civilians back there Toyota responds by
asking the curse white kills people and
Kuro simply replies that it likes the
taste of iron then going on to chart
binding over and over again kuroshi uses
its Earthen insect trance technique to
summon small and seek like curses that
carry these unproportionate looking nut
texts with them instantly a swarm of
cockroaches shoot down and around you to
forcing him to stab the shallow water
below him to create a shock wave
allowing him to hide once the Swarm
dissipates the curses from kuroshi's
previous technique attack user from
behind Judah slashes them apart but
sadly the toxins from the big ass sex
blind him for a moment giving kuroshi an
opening the Cockroach curse retrieves
the history life sword and slashes at
his Target Judah manages to block with
his Katana but he festering life sword
shoots something into his shoulder as
her boy darts back he figured that the
curse tool might be able to shoot
projectiles but he instantly realizes
something's wrong and more insect-like
curses suddenly grow out of his shoulder
wound taken by surprise Judo tries to
cut them off with his Katana but this
gives kuroroshi another opening to
attack closing in the cockroach slashes
Yuta across his abdomen opening up
another wound and causing more curses to
spawn from it Ryu and takako watching
shock as kuroroshi then grabs you at his
body fully expecting her to devour him
yusu though plays the infamous Ono
reversal and grabs the cursor's face
before sinking his teeth into
kuroroshi's exoskeleton then as is
munching down he drives a reverse curse
energy blast through his teeth into the
Cockroach compromising the Integrity of
its body and exercising this special
grade curse kuroshi Falls to Paces while
you just spit its remains onto the
ground earning himself another five
points from kogang where the curse
Spirit out of the way and Utah in a
vulnerable state uru decides to take
advantage of the situation and confronts
him directly levitating upside down
behind a new rival uru Whispers into
juda's ear taking him by surprise before
Utica can confront the danger directly
though or reduces their dopas curse
technique the heavily distort the space
around them instantly this Distortion
fractures the terrain around her and
launches you to backwards taking the
hurt head-on you know minimizes the
damage and starts to wonder how exactly
she caused so much destruction but
before he has time to think Oro follows
up her attack with a punch Yuda is just
able to weave past the hurt and tries to
counter with a punch of his own however
Oro grips down and warps the sky around
his first completely stopping his
counter-attack and turning his hand into
some spaghetti ass noodle which like
reminds me of Harry's hand after the
Quidditch game and Chamber of Secrets
anyways anyways while Judith stands
there confused by his distorted
appendage Ro knocks him back with
another attack now out of combat yuda's
arm quickly returns to normal without
any damage leading you to assume aura's
curse technique manipulates space
without actually crushing anything
within it similar to how like a lens
Crest Distortion that's just an idea but
I I wonder if she could also create some
sort of pocket Dimension or Wormhole
hear me out it does sound kind of crazy
but as she could grab two specific
points in space and distort those points
to make them touch technically that's
how we think a wormhole might work over
a 3D plane and from that it opens up
this series too like the idea of time
travel or a high domain like the fourth
dimension or something anyways you know
it sounds a bit bizarre the reason I say
this is because Oru discloses her
ability right now and reveals her curse
technique treats the sky as a surface
for example Ora can physically grab an
open space making it a tangible object
which in turn allows you to manipulate
it as if it was some sort of curtain
both of the previous attacks on Utah by
passes defenses and scent of flying so
he figures that there must be some sort
of tractor ability if warped surfaces
are able to accomplish that impatiently
uru waits for her opponent to attack so
she can counter with her technique but
instead Judah asks her a question he
asks if a roe wouldn't complain if she
were to be killed and why exactly she's
seeking out conflict he understands that
powerless people get desperate but this
doesn't apply to uro because acoustic
need makes it such a formidable opponent
compared to the majority of other
sorcerers in the killing game uro
explains to him that she doesn't take
receiving a new body lightly as
essentially incarnated Sorcerers have
returned from the shadow realm she feels
like someone without regret wouldn't
have joined the killing game in the
first place so as the first step in her
new life she is prioritizing points and
that's why she's attacking still
confused probably even like more than us
reading right now because it made no
sense to me what she said there Judah
asks if uro has a lover or a companion
she's fighting for the reason he asks
this is because he simply can't
understand why someone would spend time
killing people thousands of years later
even if they have regrets listening to
you to blame her on though uru gets more
and more pissed off all culminating in
the point where Yuda asks her how she
could possibly be so desperate that
she'd only return for her own selfish
game I write and literally blown blood
vessels on a dome Oru asks a future as a
descendant of the fujiwara clan claiming
that someone of his blood wouldn't ever
understand her which I don't think he is
he's a michizani's descendant so I don't
think that's fujiwara someone let me
know down in the comment section below
were you though remember that like
random apparently op JoJo's character
from before well his ass interrupts the
conversation by using his insane Granite
blast Safari massive wave of cursed
energy from his head at both players
leaving the previously beautiful city
now just a pile of rubble having
attacked from a nearby rooftop Ryu
claims Yuta and uro's floating is making
him hungry for battle era decides that
there's no reason to let Ryu go now now
that the colony's deadlock is broken
Yuta and uro simultaneously decide it's
time to take Ryu out they both Dash in
straight towards Ryu exciting the
long-range fighter who responds with a
volley of cursed energy beams their
weave after the approaching Fighters
Judah is narrowly able to avoid the
initial barrage using his agility but a
second wave of attacks appears to take
him off guard decimating him and the
bridge is standing on however once the
Smoke Clears Ryu who thought he landed a
direct hit notices that Yuda is gone
suddenly Judah leaps up from behind onto
the roof to confront Rio directly
forcing him to realize that you'd use
the whole Rika made in the bridge to
avoid the beams and get out of sights
having successfully closed the distance
between them Yuna attacks the ancient
sorcerer directly before darting back
into his fighting pose and declaring
that it's time to bring the fights into
a close range amused by yuda's display
of skill Ryu asks if fighting up close
will satisfy his hunger elaborating on
his comment Ryu asks if someone should
tell a child in front of her face to
calm down and eat slowly Yuda suggests
that someone should do that and Ryu
actually agrees admitting that it was
probably a bad example lighting up a
city Ryu says he didn't have any major
regrets in his first life where he
fought worthy opponents and had met a
good woman even so he still suffers from
a thirst that no one understands and
because of that he's still unsatisfied
he says that cigarettes have a sweet
aftertaste but his life has never had
that kind of dessert instantly Ryu
unleashes a flurry of attacks causing
you to quickly respond with punches of
his own giving them both a chance to
feel for each other's combat prowess
Judah notes that Ryu has an explosive
cursed energy output combined with very
precise and quick movements even without
his Advanced toughness a direct hurt
from Ryu would cause significant damage
after exchanging several blows and
parrying one another both Fighters
turned to land a spinning attack however
Ryu clashes his back against Utah and
expels a blast of cursed energy that
sends the latter flying back off the
roof due to crashes to the top of
another building losing his footing for
a moment but quickly manages to regain
his balance immediately where you heavy
notices stumble follows up with another
Granite blast attack sitting in a beam
of energy directly at you sir but
somehow you're just able to deflect it
with his bare freaking hands like some
Harry Potter spell without a wand level
of holy then Yuda in a damn flash
quickly closes the distance and tries to
crush his opponent with a fierce right
hook to the Dome crushing Ryu into the
roof and cracking the concrete floor
below him however it actually seems that
Ryu had condom into a false sense of
security as he counters with another
beam of curse energy that Utah is unable
to fully overpower as he blasts you to
back where you tells him that you are my
desert Euro who's like just rolled up on
the scene takes advantage of yuda's
unfavorable positioning in mid-air and
targets him with a curse technique let's
explain that technically she doesn't hit
the person with technique but strikes
the surface of the sky and steered
having revealed the extent of your
Technique or it breaks the surface like
thin ice and smacks your opponent
straight down onto the brick road below
irritated by the interference where you
shoot a wave of curse energy at a row
and tells her that she's in his way
telling him to silence himself though
Oru uses her technique to warp the space
around the cursed energy beam firing it
right back at him and heading him
directly injured Yoda then manages to
return to the battlefield which amuses
uro who claims it's great that he's
tough as she's going to toy with him
eljojo wannabe who's still recovering
from his own attack notices that Yoda is
constantly using his reverse curse
technique to heal himself and using up
all of his near bottomless curse energy
leaked down by his opponent's receding
strength Ryu comes to the conclusion
that Yuda is not the dessert he had been
searching for to quench his gluttonous
thirst thinking on what to do himself
Yuda knows that Ryu doesn't Target
civilians but he wouldn't care if they
ended up as collateral damage in an
attack Judo knows that he wanted to put
more distance between him fighting and
this day Stadium where the civilians are
just in case but that isn't likely to
happen anymore instead you decides to
use his full strength now he pulls out
and puts on his ring then calls upon
Riker and asks her to give him
everything Rika suddenly manifest as a
curse Spirit right next to him leaving
both Ryu and uro confused by this turn
of events we're always shocked yet it
wasn't already using his full power and
Ryu doesn't understand how yuda's curse
energy is already filling back up for
those of you like confused think of
freak her like a water tank of cursed
energy and when Yoda decides to open
that tap he can just refill his deflated
curse energy on top of that Rica tears
open a chest to display a freaking
arsenal of cursed tools kept inside her
body for you to choose from so reiker
the curse is technically different to
Riker orimoto and once the young child's
spirit peacefully passed away at the end
of ggk0 the cursed Spirit itself stay
directly connected to yuda's ring and
while the connection is active Rika is
capable of storing curse energy for Yuta
completing her full manifestation to Aid
him in best title and can even Supply
curse talks for him though he can only
maintain the sustained connection for up
to like five minutes having chosen the
missile arm Rika attaches the casing
around yudu's right arm to improve his
overall striking power ready to
re-engage in the now three-way battle
Judah Begins by having Rika saw through
the air towards a row who now prepares
whose Sky manipulation technique and
response however Utah suddenly create
superlific snake eyes and fangs schedule
of the inumahi clan on his mouth and
activates cursed speech commanding all
of his opponents to not move Oru tries
to cover her ears but she's just too
late and is immediately immobilized
which I wonder if that implies that the
inumaki clan had been around from the
time that eru was previously alive as
she reacted like she knew what the
ability was anyways unable to defend
herself Aura was pummeled by a large
barrage of strikes from both Yuta and
Riker cylinder shooting off yusuthing
drops down and launches himself off
Ricky's ahms like he's a goddamn
volleyball towards uro continuing to
pressure her Ryu tries to intervene in
their fight and launches a beam of
cursed energy claim I mean that Yoda's
approach is too soft Ricky though cuts
it off and slices the attack in half
with one hand and pressing Ryu who
believes that Riku might be even more
durable than Yuta himself irritated by
the pain Rika angrily lashes out
punching Ryu in the face and seeing him
flying off the roof he tries to follow
up with another strike but Ryu quickly
counters with an explosive punch of his
own smashing Rika back into the roof of
an opposing building excited with the
potential to satisfy his hunger Ryu
fixes his hair and claims he has an
appetite that calls for an extra large
helping back with the other two though
you just summons a bunch of small flying
shikigami by using strains of his hair
as an intermediary uru destroys one of
them using a technique and claims that
members of the fujiwara are only
standing away because they fear her true
potential going on that typical anime
level Spiel she explains that she is the
leader of the sun moon and star squads
Affiliated directly with the tour of the
fujiwara clan there were assassins that
pursued lies or selfless devotion and
the shadows and didn't even bear names
particular Sorcerer of the fujiwara clan
though gave takako her name only to
execute her as a proxy to cover up his
own crimes of killing someone else and
the clan suddenly though Ura was cut off
from its sentence and cut across her
chest and herps by the chicken Army
those trajectories are the shikigami
constitute o domain which uru
immediately recognizes as Drew's
technique remember like that old man
from the very beginning of the fight she
realizes that Judah isn't a cursed
speech user with the ability to summon
shikigami instead he's a sorcerer with
the ability to copy others curse
techniques Yuda proceeds to follow up
and knocks uru down to where Ryu and
Enrique are fighting he tries to
capitalize with a straight punch but uro
manages to stop his attack and break his
armored shell with the Icebreaker effect
of a technique uninjured by this
exchange though Yuda tells uro that
regardless of what his ancestors may
have done living for herself will only
get her so far yet those words just hit
a complete block and only served to
further annoy uro who claims that saying
things like live for others is something
only those who who have achieved
something can do the conversation is
interrupted though when they both notice
a massive search and reuse curse energy
Ryu thinks his opponents need to shut up
because words are utterly pointless at
this stage of the fights are you guys
already as if three of them suddenly
look at each other prepare to bring
these three-way battle to a climax the
trio of sindo's strongest sorceress all
activate their domain expansion
simultaneously instantly and like
because of the three overlapping domains
they cancel each other's short hit
functions out without that Advantage Ryu
and uro know that they need to stop yosa
from taking the initiative by keeping
Reika out of the barrier for you know
that he had already knocked Rika over 20
meters away so it was unlikely she would
be able to reach the barrier in time but
outside it's shown that the last
advantages of Rika or imoto's will
inside of Rika couldn't accept that she
was unable to protect Yuta causing her
strength to wretch it up another notch
suddenly kuroroshi yes remember that
damn cockroach from back at the
beginning of the video that just got
milked by user randomly appears and
infiltrates the freaking barrier while
it's cockroaches outside occupy recur so
remember how I said this dude was able
to self-reproduce and all that kind of
stuff well before going dormant
kuroroshi actually reproduced via his
parthenogenesis after Yuda exercised the
parent roach the country's curse energy
of fear was transferred into the new
Offspring kuroshi the player is indeed
perished but Karoshi the curse spirit is
still completely active three
overlapping domains are more complex
than two and the conditions imbued
within their barriers complicate things
even further with the addition of an
unexpected Intruder the barriers are
completely compromised and begin to
shatter falling to Pacers falling out
themselves Yuna notices that uro is
totally focused on kuroroshi obviously
this is due to her technique being at a
complete disadvantage with the roach
because of this Yuna takes the
opportunity and literally kicks uro in
the back while she's distracted sending
her flying towards the ground almost
like cementing her death seeing her
coming down the cursed roach rushes the
War II or the festering life sword root
tries to respond by activating a curse
technique however as we all know from
the past events with mojito curse
techniques are difficult to use
immediately after using a domain
expansion and uru's ability to
manipulate space Burns away in her hands
leaving it open takura Roshi's assault
the roach curse slashes uro's left arm
and quickly these disgusting and
sick-like curses spawn funny wound
severing her limb completely Rika who's
also there acts quickly by devouring
uru's are before the roach could
impressing Ryu he notes that Yoda is
thorough and that it's unlikely that uro
can regenerate her entire arm even if
she uses a reverse curse technique I
write over the loss of her arm or
angrily calls out to The fujiwara
Descendant cutting her off though Ryu
tells her to stop because she and
kuroroshi uninvited to his table yes if
you have noticed everything to do with
Ryu ishiguri has something to do with
eating food like the dessert thing from
earlier or now the whole like you ain't
invited to this table you can eat from
this table type thing anyway anyway it's
explain that ryu's curse technique is
called cursed energy discharge and is
the only sorcerer capable of outputting
the same amount of power regardless of
if his technique is active or not
instantly he blasts uro and Karoshi with
another jacked up Granite blast
incapacitating Euro and partially
destroying kuroroshi making it simple
for you to exercise with his reverse
curse energy excited for his dessert now
Ryu fixes his drip and welcomes Yuta to
the table he charges his cursed energy
and takes aim while opposite him you
don't knows that his own curse technique
has yet to replenish but with yusa and
reiker working together to counter the
ancient sorcerer's next move the table
is set for the final battle as in
explained the Yuda can only unleash a
direct beam of cursed energy while Rika
is completely manifested even at full
power Judas blasts are slightly weaker
than reuse in order to win The Exchange
unit intends on a rapidly building up
cursed energy and firing first before
Ryu reaches maximum power however ryu's
Eyes Express over 400 years of hunger
waiting to be satiated and his gaze
pleads with Yuta to use his full power
although Utah would never find true
meaning and conflict reuse gaze melted
his heart melted my damn heart as well
look at those eyes it's so damn
beautiful anyways Yuda agrees to go all
out on this just once and both Sorcerers
unleash their curse energy the blasts
Collide and they curse energy beam
struggle that's extremely reminiscent of
an old-school DBZ Blast Off sadly though
Yuda is quickly overpowered by ryu's
blast the duo are seemingly hurt and
sent back into a nearby building which
Ryu immediately expresses How Sweet the
first taste of his dessert was the
gleeful sorcerer is quickly surprised
though when he begins to feel his
opponent's cursed energy swelling up
wanting a male hit his eyes he screams
in us for another being struggle in
retaliation Rica fires a blast of curse
energy while Utah simultaneously rushes
forward it's showing that Yoda actually
jumped forward at the exact same time
the blast hurt launching him at high
speed towards the enemy's
breaker is also able to shoot completely
on her own but Ryu believes he's jacked
enough and somehow he Blocks Your Beam
with his bare hands as well claiming
that he can do whatever you to can he
takes aim at quta and expects to finish
him off for this next attack due to the
cursed energy he extended on top of just
using a domain expansion however as his
Granite blast shoots out and unbeknownst
to Ryu yuda's curse technique had
already replenished he takes this moment
and uses oru's ability to warp space
redirecting ryu's blast up into the ear
shocked Ryu realizes tayuda can actually
copy people's curse techniques and tries
to symbolize what condition he must have
fill to do so he recalls Riker devouring
Euro's arm and figures that there must
have been when he satiated the condition
yuru notices ryu's lack of focus
capitalizing on it and scores a direct
hit to ryu's chest with oro's thin
Icebreaker move quickly he follows up
with another combination downward punch
using Riker that hits so hard it causes
Ryu to begin bleeding profusely from his
head so remember how there was like a
time limit on Ricky's infestation well
five minutes have now passed since you
to donned his ring causing the
connection between him and Rick is
actually in Ryu takes advantage of this
by hitting Riker with his full power an
attack that was too much for her to
handle even more fully manifested
because of this Reiki quickly reaches
the limit and disappears from the battle
leaving Utah to continue fighting on his
own the big man himself Ryu is excited
that there's even more to their battle
even after clashing at full power he
happily declares that this final course
is the dessert he has been longing for
standing there you'd have surprises the
Ancient One by grabbing him with both
hands and pushing their weight down so
hard that it cracks the ground Beneath
Your Feet after effectively immobilizing
them both due to claims that the fight
is over confusing Ryu while shigori is
looking down at the cracked ground his
Granite Blast from earlier yes remember
that one Juda shot up into the sky using
uro's technique well it rains down to
rexley on Ryu and surprises the
unsuspecting sorcerer completely
toasting him still standing there though
like like an actual Champion but still
defeated where you quickly realizes that
he was just hit by his own beam as Judah
redirected it back down using uro's
technique at the same time Rica had hit
him despite his defeat for he was
satisfied with the high level of battle
he participated in and thanks you sir
now that his stomach is finally full not
gonna lie getting those the terminology
of the saying so damn well and we all
just ate as well as Ryu ishigori did
right here boys anyways anyways
following the end of the battle in the
Sendai Colony you the first talks to the
defeated uro in order to retrieve for
points she tells you to this like
extremely ominous statement they
probably will 100 play a role later on
in the story she says that his strength
has a limit and she's seen a power
Beyond the Horizon of the strongest
Fighters and curses with their very own
eyes in that moment she imagines
sakuna's original form and claims that
such power takes the form of
overwhelming a Christian that disregards
anything else like a Calamity
UDA then moves on to Ryu who tells him
that he's too soft and he won't receive
praise for his actions you don't applies
to him though that takako also told him
something similar that there was no
value in sparing an opponent's life
having heard this where you were
surprised to learn that uru survived and
believes his blast must have been
weakened after using domain expansion
which like I brought up earlier makes
sense as most of the time after using a
domain someone's technique will slightly
falter in comparison too before the
domain was used anyways anyways Ryu sits
up and asks what uru kept getting upset
about during the fight and asks if it
was a lover's quarrel you'd try slowing
him off but after persistine explains
that anything he could have said to her
would have just led to violence because
he's blessed Ryu doesn't really
understand what you'd mean by this but
still respects his words after a brief
break our man decides to get back on his
mission and asks Ryu to hand over all of
his points the ancient sorcerer is like
kind of an initially confused by uh what
he means about this but cocaine explains
that a new rule was added a while back
that allows players to transfer points
to one another Ryu believes he
understands that's why users spread
their lives now but still us if he would
have killed them without their rule Yuda
suggested it definitely was a
possibility and smiles while telling Ryu
to just be grateful to his new comrade
which you know could be uh interesting
with that little comment there for what
could happen in the future
tag team like Duo anyway thanks to the
point transfers from uro and Ryu on top
of the points he already gained from
eliminating drift and kuroroshi Yuda now
has a total of 200 points putting him at
the halfway points and their plan to
bring down the coloring game
so to start things off here we're
actually throwing away any idea of that
silly old culling game and going back to
before the Countrywide idle
Transfiguration where a young man with
blue hair and blue eyes named Charles
Bernard filled out his visitors
registration at shuacia's Publishing
House in Tokyo two of the staff members
noticed and discussed if he brought a
manga submission in also commenting on
how unusual it is for a gaijum to do so
Charles later ends up meeting a show
Asia staff member to review his manga
submission while I'm probably sitting on
the desk Charles expresses that he's
always pondered what makes a manga
Creator they don't need licenses and in
child's opinion experience doesn't
necessarily validate a creation either
which you know does make sense like you
see armor for example never hitting
manga before Attack on Titan but anyways
anyways the employee looked over at
Bernard's manga while hardly listening
to his words wishing that he would just
sit in the chair he only commented on
the foreigners Japanese saying that it
was pretty good but Charles responded by
repeating the same sentiment bag
confusing the man hate to cut myself off
again but if you guys watch anyone who
like makes Japanese content and lives in
Japan as a farna this is a pretty common
thing to hear to the point that it's
like almost an unhand insult by the
Japanese people to like Outsiders living
in Japan anyway anyway the employee
stated that it's obviously the case
because he's Japanese and Charles
reveals that he was actually born and
raised in Japan although his parents are
Fringe the employee apologized for
assuming and Charles dismissed it
because he believed it would be the
start of a long relationship between him
and the publishing Studio yet this dog
of shueisha employee is mostly
unimpressed by Charles's manga
submission and critiques the story The
genre the tone and most of all the
artwork he is one example of one panel
where a character's finger is bent too
much in One Direction the employee tries
to show Charles by pointing his own
finger in demonstration but Charles
immediately breaks it to match the
Marcus our hearts irritated Charles told
the man to watch movies or stare at
photos of he wanted realistic artwork he
believed a publishing house should
appreciate the passion that can't be
replicated in precise artwork Charles
finishes his tirade after assaulting the
employee and storms out of the building
deeming the experience is a waste of
time so yeah I don't know what that was
all about probably just a small warning
from gig8 any future Publishers about
his artwork skipping forward now to the
fateful day of November 12th we find
that somehow this pure manga reading
degenerate Charles is outside and on a
ferris wheel with akari Kenji inside of
the culling game he asks hikara if he
knows what makes someone a manga Creator
yet as we could probably imagine an
annoyed Hikari answers that he simply
doesn't care just lacking there and
chilling out Charles is thankful that
there is still electricity power in the
area but akari isn't and suggests that
he normally wouldn't ride a ferris wheel
with another man Charles points out that
he could have refused the ride but akari
wants to scope out the area and Casey
brings a girl back one day because you
know big brain thinking and all
pre-planning for future events as the
man knows that the Cullen game ain't
gonna murder him for sure but anyway
Charles is surprised to Carrie believes
Tokyo will recover from the Cullen game
claiming that he is the exact opposite
as someone who's only come to gaze upon
the end of a tall ever since curses fly
to Tokyo there haven't been outlets for
manga and creators that Charles
respected are giving up Charles asks a
car to give him a reason to fight
because the heroes and battle Marcus are
always fighting for positive reasons
while the culling game only incites
fights for negative ones Charles asks
akari to provoke him enough to instill
hatred inside of him to the point where
he could take him out without any
remorse hearing this Hikari decides to
oblige and thoroughly insults child he
says that it would never read Charles's
creepy manga because his gloomy
disposition might affect him then and
probably one of the best and tired damn
lines so far of the manga he also tells
Charles to stop whining and start
fighting creepy otaku insulted and with
tears in his eyes Charles asks what he
would say such a mean thing related to
fight Hikari for his rude comments
Charles conjures the g-war stuff a
pin-shaped sphere immediately he
attacked bursting through their pod and
forcing the carry onto the Furious wheel
whereas the soul continues Charles
thrusts his spirit akari's head several
times while quoting a poem from a
Creator he admires Hikari simply avoids
his strikes and jumps off the Furious
wheel onto a building below causing the
Frenchman to chase after her standing
there is showing that our special great
is a little annoyed because Charles is
actually quoting a comment from katsura
hashino which akaro just doesn't
consider it as a poem Charles expands
upon the poem by explaining that a
mangaka enters a fictitious space in
their minds where anything is possible
because to them reality just isn't
satisfying he continues by stating he
believes his reality has been overtaken
by Jujutsu and because of this he has
lost his motivation as both a margarita
and a Creator he asks Sakari what that
feeling is called and the suspended
student just simply replies that he's
just getting bored with this as his
fighting Spirit then begins Rising
Charles suggests that they fill in his
God is called Despair and steered fueled
by his sorrow for his opponent Charles
strikes hard with his g-war staff and
scratches akari's cheek open drawing a
bit of blood at the pin's tub noticing
that the spear is a pin Hikari asks him
if it's okay for a mangaka to use their
drawing pin for violence but Charles
argues using a reference from Captain
Tsubasa following this he activates the
condition for his curse technique and
Mark zakari with a glowing Square
curiously confused Hikari asks what's
going on as he throws a flying kick but
Charles is able to avoid it and
immediately counter attacks with an
attack surprising the former easily
though Hikari maintains his balance as
he's knocked back several meters from
the blow although he personally didn't
take any damage his sleeve was cut wide
open while examining the tear Hikari
also analyzed the way the Frenchman
moved and decides that it has to be more
than just a simple reflex noticing the
special grade sorcerer took his hands
out of his pockets for the first time
Charles taunts him for it and then
explains that the glowing square is
actually a manga panel that lets the
user see their opponent's next move
currently the Frenchman can only see one
second in advance but as the pins tip
fills with akari's blood the former will
be able to see further into the future
having heard this her caridash is
straight at Charles to confirm this
ability as effect and nearly lands a
powerful right Hawk with the letter
admitting that it would have taken him
out if not for the effect of the g-war
staff quickly after Charles counters
with his attack and had to carry across
the head with a blunt end of his spear a
filming to Hikari that the Frenchman can
really see the future however Hikari is
unimpressed by the student's ability and
just disappears from Charles's line of
sight before he reappears and punches
Charles in the back stating that he
needs to be able to see him in order to
see the future through his technique to
counter Hikari attacks Charles
repeatedly from his blind spots without
letting up in an attempt to retaliate
Charles tries to stab akaria in the back
but the letter has already anticipated
that he would try that and intercepts
before striking him again before Charles
can turn around and recover Hikari
completely and utterly blitzes him while
stating that he can't just go easy on
him because he knows Charles would just
selfishly attack someone else later
continuing Hikari believes that in order
to stop this he needs to utterly break
Charles and hits him with an extremely
powerful punch he then quickly goes to
get behind him but Charles is able to
recover from the previous punch in time
and reactively Strikes his blind spot
cutting the Curry's forehead I rate over
how the battle is going now Charles
claims that the abyss will container in
his heart is broken and is spilling out
in a gush of emotion hears it now due to
gaining more ink in his pin he can see
two seconds into hikari's future and
will be waiting in his own blind spot
confused used as the waihekari is an
intimidated though Charles asks his
opponent why he's just standing there
posing while in the situation I don't
actually think Charles has ever bumped
into anyone who can use the domain
expansion and due to this while Hikari
stands there he uses both his hands to
form the proper hand sign to cast his
domain expansion the idol death gamble
due to his domains guaranteed effect its
rules are instantly transmitted to
Charles's brain instantly the soon-to-be
mangaka begins to understand the rules
of akari's domain expansion it's shown
to us that the idle death gamble is
based on the Japanese Pachinko machine
inspired by the Shoujo series sea yard
private Pure Love Train during the
domain's active phase the user must hit
the jackpot by getting three of the same
symbol which will allow them to get a
bonus there's a flow of three different
levels of determines the percentage of
increased probability and also the
probability of the jackpot through a
visual effect which akari can choose
though ultimately this depends on the
so-called luck Hikari refers to also
certain Richie scenarios can be
activated at points throughout this
process us and chance boosters allow for
an increase in the chance of a jackpot
having heard all of this child yells at
annoyed by the sudden info dump that was
literally just implanted into his brain
as the first stage of akari's domain
begins quickly kanji releases a green
and red vigil effect attack which
Charles Dodges out of the way causing it
to activate into a Reiki scenario
changing the scene around them it's
explained to the confused Charles that
if the character Yuki passes through the
gate then akari immediately hits the
jackpot Charles attempts to swipe at it
but it's just a visualization so nothing
happens meaning all he can do is wait to
see the result which is you know like
kind of sucks it's almost just a
guaranteed jackpot whenever a right here
scenario pops up I wonder if like that's
a house rule type thing referring back
to how his domain is based on pachinka
machine but anyway anyway we're going to
take back over due to the indicator
being weak the Richie scenario fails
causing them to reset back at the
beginning of the domain's expansion
these awkwards of events leading up to
either the reset of the domain or a
jackpot are considered one of akari's
full roles giving Charles a very strict
time Limited defeat the gambling
sorcerer standing there Charles thinks
about how he can't use his manga curse
technique to predict the outcome meaning
that the process will repeat
continuously until he defeats him or
Kenji draws a winner which he knows will
result in a loss for him however to
kenji's surprise watch House's most
infuriated air is the presentation
taking the Beloved private pure love
trained manga and turning it into
something bizarre for gambling he
continues to try and attack questioning
how long he will keep up with the
jackpot rate being only one in 239
however Hikari is still able to easily
Dodge each attack while confidently
stating that he's never gone past 30
times this time Hikari activates a
Raichu scenario with an 80 success rate
leaving them too anxiously watching as
they continue to Juke it out he's unable
to focus on kenji's future attacks as he
tries to pay attention to the reichi
scenario calling on the Yume character
to get on the train and hopes of
preventing the jackpot sadly for him
though the train leaves and Hume
disappears allowing Charles to slice a
takari's side Chelsea explains while
confidently standing there that if it
was a game of skill rather than luck
Hikari might have won but as he turns
around he is utterly shocked to find
Hume is still standing there saying that
she mustly train meaning that Hikari had
actually indeed won the jackpot quickly
Hikari darts in and kicks Charles away
declaring that he used his skill to grab
a hold of luck elsewhere in Tokyo number
two Colony Panda sits alone atop a
shipping container in a shipyard upon
smelling the air he notes that roughly
three people have been dismembered
nearby he can also hardly sense the
perpetrator's presence which might
suggest that they can freely activate
their curse energy Panda reviews the
plan that he and everyone had agreed on
beforehand they'd planned to leave the
fighting just to Hikari but the barrier
just like over in Tokyo Colony 1 with
Yuji and Megami split them up upon entry
to one of those random spawn locations
after a bit more thinking Panda decides
to take off and rolls his cute behind
off the shipping container to go in
search of Hana once he landed he looks
both ways and size a breath of relief
however at that exact moment Hajime
kashimo walks right around the corner in
a split-second reaction Panda plays a
real-life Panda and initially this does
work however Hajime has an omega-sized
brain and summons Tesco gang to his side
to ask if that Panda was actually a
player with a letter pretty much
instantly confirming nerds witnessing
this happen in front of his teddy bear
eyes Panda was surprised to learn that
they have that function yet before Panda
really had any time to react the ancient
god-level sorcerer Hajime had quickly
charged at him and delivered a powerful
blow to his torso completely erupting
and large portion of his stuffing
holding him together before following up
this brutal attack and completely
electrifying him then not done Hajime
while insulting his strength hits him
with his staff and knocks Panda back
into a container having been brutally
beaten Panda notes that hajime's cursed
energy is similar to megami's new way
where both have electrified cursed
energy surging through their bodies with
his Panda form destroyed the Puppeteer
begins transforming into his gorilla
mode and Strikes Hajime with the
prolific unblockable drumming beat
noticing a change Hajime takes a
defensive start and endures the
multitude of blows he says that the
attack wasn't too bad but it wasn't
great either and follows up by using his
staff to tear off the Panda's right arm
then continuing with his old school
brutality he throws Panda's own arm
straight back into his face completely
blinding the defenseless spear allowing
the sneaky sorcerer to approach him for
the puppet's right dartinan he delivers
a flurry of absolutely brutal hurts
directly aimed at the Panda's face
sending him shooting back into another
container as the broken sorcerer strolls
up on the Beast and Panda he calls him
pathetic and weak before asking if he
knows the current whereabouts of sukuna
taken by surprise Panda doesn't know why
he's interested in him but quickly comes
to the realization that he wouldn't be a
good matchup with Yuji so while trying
to think up an excuse he says he doesn't
know noticing the massive amount of
stalling before answering his question
though Hajime realizes that he's indeed
lying and demands that he spit it out as
he'll show Mercy if he does having
thought up an excuse now Panda says that
his uncle goes by the same name so
hearing it took him off guard initially
Hajime who easily figures out that he's
still lying doesn't appreciate being
looked down on by the cursed puppet and
tells him to stop playing with him
annoyed now Panda rhetorics by saying
he's the one being looked down on and
tells him to be aware of his sister as
anyone who meets her eyes she tries to
kill at a pure embarrassment all of a
sudden a massive horn is seen from
Panda's nose as his body begins to
transform and this head Morse into a
giant Triceratops skull however in that
exact moment Hajime charges up his own
attack and a lightning bolt appears
between them as soon explained that
kashimo separates the curse Energy's
charges like electricity when he strikes
an opponent so like all of the hits of
these Lanes on Panda earlier it
transfers a positive charge into the
target then when the negative charge
that lays inside of kishimo as discharge
and launches directly at the Target
without shooting off any other surface
this results in lightning that like
literally cannot mess as it will travel
directly to its opponent pretty much
taking away any need for Kashima to
actually use the domain as this is kinda
a short head technique in itself sadly
for panda as the transformation is still
happening that said lightning bolt
strikes and absolutely decimates Panda
mortally wounding him standing above the
now fallen puppet Hajime once again asks
Panda about sukuna's whereabouts ah boys
here here's the saddest part here's the
saddest Panda chapter so far as we flow
into a flashback we see a young Panda
being beaten up by his big brother
gorilla the young Teddy screams for a
sister's Aid and an angry Triceratops
marches over demanding that gorilla sees
the bullying yet the young gorilla tries
to say that they were just fighting like
a dude from a game here and there
Triceratops says that Panda should get
the next turn to fight back with gorilla
being completely fine with it listening
to his older siblings Panda looking like
hella cute man rolls up to smack his bro
if you few times however he quickly is
punched in the face by the letter making
him cry even more completely blown away
with what she just witnessed Triceratops
then runs off in Pursuit while Panda
continues crying out behind them later
on panda is seen holding a Santa Claus
ball while trying to follow his older
brother and his puppet friends not
wanting him to follow because they find
the lake training wheels absolutely lame
the fox Whispers something and he
raccoons ear and he tells Panda that he
can actually join under the conditions
that he throws his ball into the river
initially Panda hesitates claiming that
it was a gift from Santa but after the
two pressured him and seen his older
brother's grumpy steer Panda tosses the
ball into the river Blown Away with him
actually doing it the raccoon and the
fox tell him they're throwing stuff into
the river is illegal as it would harm
the environment before they ran off
aiming to tell the police which is like
who is Gorilla hanging out with these
are the worst puppets I've ever met
gorilla really asks a sad and Panda way
through his ball into the river telling
him that it was a precious gift from
Santa breaking down in tears even more
Panda screams at him that he just wanted
to play with his big brother at night
before bedtime Triceratops berates
gorilla for bullying Panda instead
telling him that when other kids peck on
him he has to be the one to stand up for
him gorilla counters this by stating
that she plays with the other girls and
wouldn't understand because of this he
says that he can never have fun with
panda around as he holds him back and
only ever seems to start crying when she
shows up gorilla thinks that she's far
too caution him but Triceratops views
this differently she knows that no
matter how main gorilla is to him Panda
strikes off all the bad things and
cheers up by the time it's time to eat
he literally doesn't have a bad bone in
his body and believes that that's how
Brothers should always be she belittles
Gorilla by saying then maybe he's the
spoiled one as Panda always ends up
forgiving him for his transgressions
suddenly interrupting the two of him
pending storms into the room with a
beetle and shows it to gorilla who
immediately points out that it's
actually a dorkest Titania stag beetle
and screams while throwing it out of the
window in horror before going to beard
gorilla and his sister to open the piggy
bank to see if they have enough change
to buy a replacement ball for panda as
he then begins trying to sleep he just
thinks that an idiot like Panda would be
fine with any ball suddenly though in
the middle of the night a voice tells
him to wake up coming out of a daze he
notices they're both he and Triceratops
are being led by a strange ghost man
who's obviously like some puppet version
of masamichi for real but anyway he
quickly recognizes this figure as their
father and asks where they're going and
for how long to which their father
answers that there's no reason and that
it's permanent at that moment a
terrified Panda bursts out of the house
desperately searching for his big bro
and big cerseus gorilla screams back for
panda and tells his father to stop
however the ghostly man just tells him
that that's enough gorilla Cuts in by
saying that Panda can't survive without
him since he's literally terrible at
everything he does and we get left
behind because he's completely helpless
by himself not understanding what's
actually going on though the father
tells him that they're the ones being
left behind and not Panda so be a good
big brother and say okay goodbye I
confused gorilla gets defensive
wondering but how in the world he was
going to buy a ball for him tomorrow and
that he needed him there to talk to
these shopkeepers instead of their
sister but sadly after a second thought
he finally catches on and fully begins
to break down in tears not wanting to
leave this world and his little
brother's side back in the real world
now Hajime kashimo stands over the
bloodied mess of pandas obliterated
corpse while prodding the beer he knows
that he didn't gain any points from him
before realizing that he probably hasn't
found the core of the panda years he
picks up Panda's head with his staff and
asks once again about the whereabouts of
sukuna but Panda simply replies like the
true friend and Legend he is that pandas
are very tight-lipped taking this as an
insult Hajime threatens to fully destroy
the rest of panda yet just as he raises
blood loss to do so the legend himself
with his cursed energy already fully
flared up and with the anger of the
entire Jiu Jitsu tick on his back drops
in completely destroying a shipping
container in the process instantly he
screams at his boy asking if Panda has
lost some weight seeing his classmate
arrive panda is happy and shouts at
akari's name while an initially confused
Hajime begins to get riled up
supercharged with an incredible volume
of cursed energy akari rushes in to
rescue Panda from kashimo he delivers a
right Hawk so powerful that it disarms
kashimo and sends the sorcerer crashing
through several Freight containers oh
like this battle was going to be so
insane boys and and girls of course
anyways instantly Hikari follows up not
giving kashimo any time to recover
having closed the distance the special
grade does a sick two-footed jump
throwing himself into the air and
delivering a flying drop kick to his
opponent's face the hejima just narrowly
avoids while still in media though akari
swings his leg straight back in an
attempt to land ahead with his opponent
just barely having his nose grazed
essajime stands there in shock hikari's
physical power is so overwhelming that
his kicks excess cursed energy dense
another shipping container and
completely deforms it sending opposite
her Gmail Hikari is a little certified
by the curse energy protecting his
opponent but also barely feels the bad
side effects from it Kashima was
impressed that his opponent can ignore
the electrification and asks his name
Hikari introduces himself while kashimo
is just completely fascinated by the
insane cursed energy output and
mysterious music surrounded his opponent
moving into his fighting stance kishimo
also introduces himself and as zakari
hears his name he realizes that he is
the player with 100 points knowing that
he needs them he cheekily asks if he can
use those points of his Victorious with
kashimo green and asking to know more
about sukuna if he's the Victor feeling
it coming in Hikari is suddenly and
orgasmically distracted as a large
influx of cursed energy received as a
bonus from hitting his domain's jackpot
envelops him noticing that something's
up kishimo uses the opportunity to
barrage his opponent with several hits
but quickly becomes displeased as akari
isn't resisting at all as he begins to
tell Hikari to not disappoint him the
special grade sorcerer switches things
up a little and rattles the ancient
sorcerer with an Abrupt right hop to the
sure that since kashimo absolutely
flying after posing literally playing
the ear guitar to go along with his own
damn theme song Hikari instantaneously
disappears from his body was in to
follow up with a fly need to hajime's
gut prompting him to admit that his
opponent isn't bad at all Landing back
on his fate Hajime regains his balance
grabs onto the lake a carrying Needham
with encounter attacks with a spinning
elbow straight to the chin of the
sorcerer overcoming it though Hikari
will stands the attack and forces
kashimo to release his grip by jumping
down and completely smashing the ground
beneath their feet with a straight punch
jumping back out of a Curry's range
Kashima who's charged back up discharges
the same lightning attack that defeated
Panda being able to see the approaching
lightning akari is able to avoid the
Direct Hit to his head but sadly his
arms blown off by the attack glad and
confident that his opponent won't be
able to recover in time after being hurt
kashimo rushes in to finish him off
however the carrier's on his Dawn level
of strength and literally does not care
about his arm at all instead he
surprisingly counters where they kick
straight to hajime's face and follows up
with a punch from the same that was
supposedly just seated blown away by
seeing hikari's arm reappear hashimo
just manages to block the attack and
assumes akari used the reverse curse
technique to quickly heal himself it's
then explained that when a Carrick had
the jackpot with his domain expansion it
resulted in a bonus of unlimited curse
energy throughout the round Hikari
himself never actually learned to use
reverse curse technique but the
unlimited curse energy coursing
throughout his body as a result of
hitting the jackpot automatically heals
his body with Earth in other words her
Curry is pretty much damn a mortal for 4
minutes and 11 seconds after hitting the
jackpot this time limit comes to an end
as the ancient sorcerer notices the
random music surrounding Hikari has
stopped causing his opponent's cursed
energy to recede to normal however
during the previous round and due to
hawakari's curse technique Works after
he hits the jackpot his curse energy and
technique is replenished allowing him to
cast another domain immediately so for
as long as akari continues to hit his
jackpot he can use his domain over and
over and over again so this is the main
reason why Harry is absolutely broken
and Gojo reasons that he could surpass
him someday man literally has figured
out an infinite cursed energy hack like
this is some game of magic or something
like oh my Lord but anyway anyway
because of the fact that big rari's
domain expansion is harmless he can be
as aggressive as he wants and his
activation is extremely Quirk probably
one of the quickest in the entire
universe like it states here that the
dude's activation is faster than that of
Mojito's John Shibuya as the roles of
the idle death game are sent to hejima's
mind he knows that since he's aware the
game is a probability loot type it means
he's likely to keep hitting the jackpot
as he activates increased probability
standing there akari asks him how he is
but Jimmy points out that during this
period he's not actually unkillable and
akari simply responds that the life of
gambling has always come with great
risks flashing in the two monstrous
Sorcerers traded flurry of brutal
punches before Kenji spins away and
activates his continuation effect
absolutely confusing her Gmail with
what's going on Asin explained that
currently Hikari is redoing one
consecutive effect sequence the normal
percentage chance of hitting the jackpot
is over 20 or one in five on its first
activation and because of that there is
usually a high risk of drawing a dud so
typically he only uses this activation
when he has increased probability
igniting the fight once more Hikari
throws another punch for Hajime blocks
it and completely bad as the bulked up
high schooler punching him in the side
of the head and kneeing him in his
stomach jumping back though Curry flexes
while screaming renewal leading the
potty emergency reichy scenario to occur
during this Raichu scenario as the dingy
wannabe who stuck on a hypothetical
train headed to yoyogi doesn't have a
bathroom or more specifically as it
implies here doesn't have any accident
at all will result in a jackpot reichy
scenario for Hikari as the train flies
forward it's shown that this fake
chainsaw man named hero just barely made
it to a stop without accident causing a
carry to once again hit his jackpot
standing there with his eyes closed and
just looking like the absolute King he
is Hikari suddenly reopens his eyes and
screams for his music to begin once more
sometimes you know like I I rarely just
personally wish I could make sound
effects like with my mouth and
everything just like boom as akari
finishes speaking his body once again
erupts with a flood of curse energy
restarting his invincibility and the
brutal Showdown time to like to really
kick things up a notch here boys so
subscribe to please save my throat from
the throat code and push this video to
like 5 or 10K likes just so I know that
you want a full like four hour jjk video
Drop because you know I'll compile all
these parts together and re-edit the
Gojo past Arc and you know I'll do that
or I'll do that or I'll tell you I will
don't make me anyway moving forward
standing opposite him a Jimmy notes how
this is the same form that will last for
four minutes and 11 seconds meaning that
he currently has no restrictions on
cursed energy and can automatically
activate a reverse curse technique
however he also notes that this time the
jackpot was not an even number meaning
that if he activates his domain
expansion right after this has increased
probability will have actually ended so
we won't get another jackpot again as
quickly after he states to himself
though that if he can make it through
the next four minutes and 11 seconds he
will win but as his smile grows larger
he recognizes that that line of thinking
is how losers think instead he screams
that it's time to turn up the volume
because this is a funeral for the living
He releases a massive burst of cursed
energy declaring that even though he may
be unkillable for the next 4 minutes and
11 seconds he will still kill him anyway
oh but before we go any further we skip
back in time to a moment 400 years ago
where her Gmail was approached by
kanjaku asking if he had fun with his
battle honestly any thoughts on who's in
the brain swapping fiend's body right
here I like wouldn't be surprised if it
was Naruto she Cameo to be honest but
who knows let me know what you think
down below anyways anyways after
replying that he didn't have fun at all
wanting to fight him instead kinjaku
asks him to spare him and says that he
is not fit for fighting currently but
reveals he heard something in michinoku
about the greatest cursed energy output
ever coughing up blood though Hajime
asks kinjaku who's the strongest source
for a he knows with the letter replying
that it's a Kona before Apollo
apologizing that it was from 600 years
ago and saying that it would never
change his mind on that fact realizing
that he will never get to fulfill his
own wishes Hajime responds that if
that's the case he will entertain what
kinjaku has to say so that he can fight
sakuna himself
back in the battle they fight between
kashimo and Hikari intensifies as they
both Chase each other at high speeds
around the port sajimay starts to get
away akari launches another Fat punch
that connects with a shipping container
sending it straight towards the ancient
sorcerer seeing it coming In Time Hajime
responds with his own brutal punch
filling in the container straight back
at the approaching student with him both
being on opposite sides of the container
they both exchanged a multitude of blows
on each side of the metal box completely
deforming and destroying it however
asakari breaks through ready to throw a
massive punch kishimo Dodges by jumping
off the ground before he manages to blow
half of a Curry's freaking face off with
his shipping container door exposing his
face muscles and jaw whether he fights
slowing for a moment hajimo deduces that
cursed energy comes from the guard but
he has to use his head to direct the
flow of reverse curse technique so no
matter how powerful his reverse curse
technique is it certainly can't be
strong enough to regenerate his head
therefore Kashima plans to use his
lightning to Target his head and
complexly split it open following this a
GMA sends his lightning directly at
akari connecting with his head yet I am
here to tell you that this is just not a
normal human this is Hikari kinji and
man just simply blows out all of the
energy from the attack straight out of
his damn nose as it destroys his face
literally allowing him to regenerate as
he breaks realizing that he almost died
there Hikari being as cool as ever just
lasted off and with only eight seconds
remaining on his jackpot shoots in
deciding to use even more brute force in
his punches now after taking a plethora
of punches to the face chin and body
Hajime darts back realizing that akari
is getting even faster as the Fight
Continues getting straight back to his
face though and with only a few seconds
remaining akari who's completely
unkillable decides to cut loose and
totally beat down on his opponent
elbowing him hard in his guards yet
surprisingly this turns out to be
exactly what kashimot actually wanted
and as he smiles he retrieves a massive
streak of electrical feedback using his
staff piston to the ground at some
distance the streak of instantaneous
lightning passes through the left side
of the Curry's tour also on its way to
Hajime before completely and utterly
blowing it to Pieces mortally wounding
the student just then the theme song
ends Mark in the Inn of akari's
unkillable period with Hajime then
stating that it's finally over however
to the public surprise of the ancient
sorcerer Hikari is not done yet instead
moving his hands into placement and
opening his domain once more sadly it's
showing though that Hikari is just
making a desperate attempt at casting
his domain after activating his domain
Hikari keeps trying to spin faster even
if the probability is only 1 in 239
immediately Hajime catches on though as
the rules are implanted in his brain and
once again Hikari somehow let the dude
is a complete another demon gains an
unexpected jackpot due to some kind of
increased probability allowing him to
roll an even number therefore he is
again unkillable for the next 4 minutes
and 11 seconds breathing a sigh of
relief Hikari states that his impressed
with kashimo as he's never faced death
this much in one day but now thanks to
some manga otaku he's got a big manga
brain and asks her Gmail if he also
likes manga with the letter stating that
he doesn't get any battle underway akari
flips things up a notch figuratively and
literally as he changes his domains
polarities making down up and also
Shifting the coordinates of his barrier
Over the Sea as a Gmail falls back
towards the sea below him he states that
because his cursed energy is like
electricity it won't stop discharging
until it's fully deplete heard here's
one of two options in the coming water
tussle either he can release his cursed
energy until it's all gone or shuttered
off until he's able to return to land
this obviously goes back to like what
Panda said about someone having that
amazing control over their curse energy
at the beginning of this battle but
anyway anyway however to avoid falling
into the water kishimo stands on the
coast spirits that burst out of the
ocean in an attempt to devour him on the
other hand Hikari who's got his manga
brain fully rolling absolutely pummels a
massive curse Spirit as it bursts out of
the ocean before shooting across at high
speeds towardsajimay and sitting in him
flying into the ocean below with a fat
Kirk then floating above him on some
like fat flying fish look and ask her
spirit he watches it's a Gmail slowly
begins to burn away all of his cursed
energy and the water however Kashima is
actually smarter than this he recalls
that there are two ways to any reverse
cursed energy user one by simply blowing
up their brains or two by using top tens
therefore he uses his electricity on the
sea water to produce a chlorine gas that
completely takes akari by surprise as he
floats above sadly Hikari loses his grip
on the curse monster and ends up falling
into the sea due to the Toxic effect of
chlorine gas it's explained that unlike
simple body regeneration addressing a
toxin in one's blood requires insane
skill as well as a higher level of
reverse curse techniques sinking down
through the ocean Jimmy notes that
Hikari doesn't seem to be able to
detoxify fast enough causing the round
to end and allowing hikari's immortality
Shield to fade smgma States this has
been fun preparing to finish him off
akari just like before dispels the
excess cursed energy right out of his
freaking nose and throws a vicious punch
straight into the face of a Gmail taking
him completely by surprise with the two
floating back from each other after the
attack it turns out that the legend of
Jujutsu Tech targeted the toxins in his
body and removed him unconsciously by
his automatic reverse curse energy with
only five seconds left in his jackpot
Hikari realizes casting his domain again
after this one ends will be dangerous
due to the effects of electricity
coursing through the water and the
steadily increasing temperature of the
ocean he Ponders going up to the surface
but it's like nah stuff that dude I
might instead just beat the absolute
hell out of this stood here and proceeds
to throw fairly talk to his opponent's
face kishime though battered and bruised
but still excited to continue drives
forth and grabs a hold of akari's arm
before releasing a massive blast of
electrified cursed energy in an attempt
to destroy hikari's entire arm and
prevent him from being able to cast his
domain again back above the ocean's
surface as all the water rains down we
find a cute baby panda who's changed his
form wandering around as he then comes
cross a curry seated hand as a
previously Lively battle now comes to a
seemingly abrupt end we'll see kashimo
pop out of this sea completely out of
curse energy however right as he is
about to consider himself the winner
Hikari emerges from the sea himself with
one arm and punches him back to reality
it's explained that during the previous
attack Gmail released before the
electricity could travel all the way
through the water and resulted in a
massive thermal explosion of hot steam
laying down on the ground completely
exhausted Hajime asks how he isn't
ripped apart from this explosion but
akari explains that he knew what his
opponent was up to and purposely
sacrificed his left arm through a
binding vowel so that the curse energy
that usually protected it protected the
rest of his body hearing this kishimo
finally tells his enemy to end his life
however akari offers him a deal instead
as he personally doesn't see this as a
win akari also brings up how kashimo
technically didn't use his technique to
which the Ancient One actually explains
that he is saving his cursed technique
to use on sakona as it is a single-use
one and ukushima wants as a fight for
sakona therefore the ancient sorcerer
agrees to side with akari in exchange
for a future duel with the king of
curses rolling onto the scene and seeing
the two hanging out panda is quite
shocked after hearing that Hajime is now
on the side because he wants to have a
future belt with sakuna Hikari discards
Panda's concerns by casually asserting
that a kohai has to obey his senpai's
wish before randomly leaving the small
panda with the ancient sorcerer to go in
search of someone else this is also
where the announcement of a new rule
being added to the game is made the rule
is that players can also give as many
points as they want to another player
allowing Hajime to send his points over
when like needed obviously it's actually
crazy when you think about it how like
all of these battles are happening
simultaneously like I love how Giga
hasn't given us a timeline per se to go
off but it's more or less just this one
kind of rule that we can refer back to
knowing that all of the fights have been
like in relation with her but anyway
anyway continuing shooting makeover to
the Furious wheel we find that Charles
has been chilling out after his defeat
after seeing Hikari rolling up he
confusingly asks what happened to his
his arm with the students stating that
he'll fix it later the two mates then
Becca about their fight hilariously like
akari is actually abusing the dude an
attempt to get the name of his monk out
of him because he'll Buy and read it
what you you know is very nice of him
big plot Twisted I'm gonna Chuck in here
myself that man uh no operator were
talking about for a sick what if Giga is
actually um French himself and this is
like a self-insert of him in the actual
story it'd be kind of funny to like go
back to after the story if Kiki ever
reveals himself and find out that this
was just like himself inserting you know
I'd love to know what you guys think on
that down in the comment section below
but anyway anyway continuing on big Momo
then cruises on and interrupting their
banter and asking if he managed to get
all their points necessary with akari
confirming that he indeed did so uh
quickly before the uh video ends I guess
I better go over their plan so their
plan is obviously to implement four new
rules the first was to make points
transferable to new players which was
done the second is to allow the use of a
hundred points to create a substitute
player so individuals can actually leave
the game third is to remove
communication blocks on these zones and
then finally the fourth is to allow
people in and out of all of the barriers
without Consequence the shimaya states
that she wants to forget rule three for
now in place of going to get four first
the reason they like are doing this
obviously is because Marquee can
actually pass through barriers leaving a
carry shocked at this news that you can
thrill you into them he asks how it's
possible with Momo stating that it's
because she has turned into a complete
monster
so like remember how right at the end of
The Last jjk Arc we found the monster
herself Marky and the sakurajima colony
well after dispatching the toughest
curse spirits and players she runs into
Naruto shikemo who's undergone like a
clean ass looking transformation man
literally had to switch up his entire
look after realizing he's named after
the worst sorcerer in their family's
history but anyways anyways they both
acknowledged the change in each other's
lock with narutoshi confessing that he's
lost his possession as became a family's
ear and is fallen from Grace while Marky
has become formidable Naruto he asks
Maki to meet with you you once he leaves
the colony as you know like remember
because of her race and transformation
he can freely travel between colonies
but suddenly their planes are
interrupted by the sudden appearance of
a formidable cursed Spirit as it enters
shooting them through the barrier it
disregards kogane's request to become a
new player telling her to shut up anyway
skipping away from like the action as
per usual and going into a moment it had
been a few days prior we find a hurry
Naruto shikamo running through the house
searching for people until he comes face
to face with a Sino Shino by the way
like has anyone notice the dramatic
change in gega akatami's art style from
like the beginning of the series till
now I feel like the culling game
especially has changed into this like
darker Arc where his art especially is a
lot more scratchy and like has this more
of a horror style feel to it but anyways
anyways continuing on they say no old
dog asks how kamo gotten claiming that
ever since the guard was taken over it's
been completely useless narutoshi tells
the old fart though that it doesn't have
any time for jokes but Shino eerily asks
him he's forgotten who's actually the
next head of the family as you then
continue spouting more bizarre nonsense
a worried narutoshi presses on and
enters the house inside he is greeted by
the body swapping creep himself kinjaku
who's literally just chilling out and
relaxing as he was waiting for narutoshi
to arrive kinjaku greets narutoshi with
a smile and offers to filament on his
plans he explains how he used Jujutsu
terrorism the ceiling of Saturday Gojo
and the killing game to eliminate all
the uncorrupted members of the Jiu Jitsu
Society he knew that because ganji is
considered trustworthy and had influence
whether he said hi fire up narutoshi
would have wanted to play with him in an
attempt to retract those notices from
the headquarters you know like talking
about the notices that was handed out
earlier like the ceiling of Saturday
Gojo and the killing of Yuji sidori
anyway anyway so he took care of
everyone who wasn't on his side like
Gojo Goku ganji masamichi and others
like that we probably never even met to
start with by the way the actual text
that goes over this is like much more
confusing where they explain pretty much
how kinshaku managed to take over like
the conservative faction of the Jitsu
World anyways sitting there konjaku's
lived impressed as Naruto she's only a
mere student they can already see the
bigger picture and acts how he needs two
I silly let down himself narutoshi asks
kinjaku if he's already removed the
people responsible for initiating
sukurukito's execution twitch is
confirmed along with a person who named
Yuta as yuji's executioner chuckling and
narutoshi's efforts to approach
gakuganji and fix everything kinjaku
confidently exclaims that I Cameo Clan
was the conservative seat but now it's
all utterly belongs to him along with
the title of the 25th chemo family hid
feeling challenged narutoji Sparks up in
preparation to battle but kinjaku
quickly waves to dismiss him like man
literally laughs at him as like nah bro
just just chill out for one sec confused
narutoshi asks what the hell he's on but
kanjaku just tells him that it's fine
because even if he is alive nothing is
going to change plus he doesn't want to
mess up the new house he tells him
instead to get lost allowing narutoshi
to eventually make his way to where we
find him at the very beginning of this
Arc beckinsucker regime narutoshi and
Maki are left on high alert as they both
spot a supposed curse Spirit chilling
above him in the sky looking at it Marky
just has this weird and uncanny feeling
instantly approaching him at lightning
speed the curse Spirit Rampages towards
Mahi tearing up in utterly obliterating
everything in his path it connects with
a blocking Maki it's in a new crashing
back and allowing the disgusting
amalgamation of a curseberg to pin her
against a cliff not having seen this
happen narutoshi watches as Maki
struggles to break free she attempts to
hit it but the cursor at speed is too
much further to handle as it Dodges out
of the way of the attack and sends a
shooting into a nearby cliffhanger
completely deforming Earths despite
being at a disadvantage Mikey refuses to
give up since he's something weird about
this cursed spirit with determination in
her eyes she quickly Dodges out of the
way of the monster's thundering right
Hawk however the curse manages to flick
its snakey behind around destroying a
few trees and its wake and trapping the
sorcerer up against the cliff emerging
from the head of the cursed Spirit no
one other than the misogynistic goon
himself Nao yazinen now reincarnated as
a terrifyingly strong cursed Spirit
reveals himself pinned up against the
wall and unable to move Marcus just left
stunned asking if it's actually him or
the older cousin replying that he's
finally arrived at the other side of
course like if any of you are confused
on how this man managed to like actually
come back Maki thought she took her
brother out with her fists yet is like
we all know and she isn't privy to Noah
was actually murked by marky's mother
wielding a plain steak Knife so he also
wasn't killed by Jujutsu with her and it
resulted in him coming back as a special
great curse Spirit but like I don't even
know why I write these scripts without
reading the next chapter sometimes like
literally right as we jump out of the
battle where so we flashback that takes
place this time between Naruto Shi and
kakuganji where they talk about
itadori's recent death sitting there
gakuganji asks what to keep in mind
while killing a sorcerer to which kaimo
like I just mentioned responds they must
be eliminated using Jujutsu the story
then shoots back over to sakurajima
winnea still has Marky penned up against
the wall his face continuing to push
even further out of the cursor's shell
quickly Maki comes to the realization
that because she doesn't have curse
energy she failed to finish naoya off in
their previous fight however Naomi
denies it telling Maki that she simply
doesn't understand and instead claims
that it was her mother who finished him
off while Marquis left shocked with this
news nayoya takes full advantage of this
situation and declares that he's
returned to completely end her luckily
for our Queen though ignorotoshi blasts
off a shot from his curse tool alloying
Maki to escape the grasp of the cursed
bird that in a way she thanks him but
also asks if he only used intuition to
aim as obviously you know he can't sense
her nearby in the woods narutoshi who's
getting ready for another shot is easily
able to introduce nao's location through
the cursor's prisons however he notices
to do see maki's location as a bit more
difficult which is obviously because the
only energy actually coming off her is
the Jiu Jitsu emanating from the sword
that she wields and I'm like pretty sure
that that doesn't actually happen in the
first place that's just headcan and wine
right there anyway anyway continuing
finally shooting off his three arrows
technique narutoshi is able to expertly
navigate all his arrows around the trees
and other obstacles on their way towards
the curse now yeah swatting the arrows
bursting through the trees behind him
because Spirit mocks the arrows in their
pathetic Spade taking the monster by
surprise though Maki grabs a hold of him
then using the momentum from his massive
size since I'm flying directly into the
path of the arrows which penetrate
deeply into his body as neoyo screams in
pain Markie immediately pulls up and
slices him in half with a cursed hole
for my distance narutoshi watches as
Maki Falls onto the buildings below her
while wandering to himself as she
actually managed to exercise naoya to
this shock though our high school of Duo
are left helpless only able to watch is
nowhere's Curse spirit loads people
collapsing in on itself like some kind
of cursed energy dark hole seeing this
in the sky above her Maki immediately
begins to recognize what's actually
happening as it fully begins to form
into a ball of energy she screams out to
narutoshi telling him to shoot at it as
she knows it's a cursed one that's
currently evolving the Ravine disaster
and just looking like hella clean by the
way as well like I'm loving the new drip
on narutoshi he immediately throws up
and destroys a bloodbag then uses his
curse technique piercing blood to stop
nailya from completing his
transformation The Beam of blood pierces
directly through Neo's cursed womb
causing a massive flood of blood to
begin pouring out the other side
thinking that he could have possibly
exercised the cursed worm narutoshi
watches as the burning ball begins
falling to the ground below yet as he
begins to ponder how insanely fast it
could have been if it survived it's
revealed that Alia did indeed Dodge the
attack and has evolved into a much more
terrifying form Maki screams from to
dodge but before naoya even his time to
react he's hurt with a devastating blow
that's in some rocketing back through
the forest around them turning around
and calling narutoshi utter trash we see
really grotesque in harrowing sight of
nayoya's full transformation into a foul
repulsive curse Spirit noticing that he
managed to defend himself in the attack
nayoyo state that narutoshi is indeed a
clan head after all as kamos sits there
recovering from the blow it's explained
that if he hadn't used his blood to
block the previous blow he would have
died getting back to his feet with a
revived look of determination on his
face he activates his flowing red scale
ability to attack the quickly
approaching curse seeing the curse
hitting narutoshi's way Maki rushes over
and manages to jump in front before
diving straight towards the curse and
cutting him open with a blade watching
this happen in front of him the Juiced
up narutoshi activates his Crimson
binding technique restraining the cursed
spirit and allowing Maki to strike at
him once more yet just as a swing is
about to land naoya spun at a high
velocity to deflect his strike
completely catching monkey by surprise
the combined efforts proved to be
utterly ineffective against naoya who
still retains his ego from his previous
life getting ready to re-engage Mucky
states that Nagoya can still use his
curse technique which explains is being
so monstrously fast in
retaliation's prolific projection
sorcery sending out a bunch of frames in
Mikey's Direction which frees anything
that he touches watch also in this
regard is literally the ear between the
two as he instantly touches the set of
frames it creates a devastating
explosion that Maki and narutoshi barely
Dodge undeterred by this naoya takes off
at a speed faster than sound confusing
narutoshi who wonders of his flame but
Maki corrects him stating that he's
actually just speeding up as the coast
is inan is off boasting around that you
will discuss what they're going to do
now touch Mahi says that if he's going
to approach them at the speed of sound
then they can lie and wait and deliver a
killing blow since in the cursor's
Direction Changed towards him Maki
bravely steps forward to face nail your
head on telling your companion to stay
back as narutoshi also activates his
technique around her in an attempt to
add some protection with the curse
Spirit destroying every shot of glass in
the building as it builds up its speed
it's explained to us that this
misogynistic demon of a curse brings ear
and through the inlets on its back and
compresses it along with the curse
energy till then inject it out its bag
for even more speed with its max speed
of freaking Mark III achieved now your
strikes were such a devastating force
that it leaves Maki almost completely
unconscious and badly injured standing
above her now now you're mocks Marky
disgusted with himself to ever think
that he could have possibly lost to her
now your state there are things that
children can never do that adults easily
overcome after you grow up you don't
even remember the times where you
constantly failed laughing at the
stupidity of this though Marky mockingly
asks him when he was ever actually an
adult twitch nailya easily tells her
that maybe she should ask who did sister
fearing with anger over how his sister
was disrespected Maggie swiftly stands
back up and in perfect coordination with
her narutoshi unleashes two more arrows
until the malevolent entity that's in
him behind narutoshi then employs his
own blood-bending technique slicing into
the curse and Landing a devastating blow
leaving nayo you're stunned with the
amount of blood being expended by the
sorcerer coming to though he makes a
connection that narutoshi could possibly
circulating the blood outside of his
body and then bringing it back in
continuously that way he won't die of
blood loss knowing that only Mark he can
defeat him though narutoshi tells His
companion that he'll hold off naoya
while she makes a run for it but Mikey
refuses just asking for five minutes
narutoshi argues though that she's
probably suffered internal damage and
just a brief break won't be enough yet
still Maggie denies it and tells him
that she isn't bluffing and really does
just need five minutes to fully heal her
injuries I don't know how she's like
actually healing herself I'm assuming
that she's probably running over to one
of the healers from Jiu Jitsu high and
getting healed there but that's just a
thought of mine either way hearing this
he tells her that he won't make any
promises as honestly it doesn't really
matter whether he lives or dies
reigniting the battle Neo your blasts
towards the duo but Naruto she uses
another technique to form a blood fins
before diving out of the way as naioya
effortlessly burst through it noticing
it Mark is vanish and because of the
fact that she's like toji he can't see
into her Naomi asks where she's gone
narutoshi in this moment analyzes the
situation and realizes that although his
curse body is incredibly fast it's not
durable he also observes that naoya has
a binding valve that requires him to
curl up at high speeds to avoid tearing
thus increasing his toughness but due to
that binding vow itself we're not moving
at high speeds he's extremely vulnerable
all of a sudden striking faster than the
speed of sound narutoshi is completely
taken off guard and blown back through a
bunch of defenseless trees by Nelly is
blow immediately following up the
misogynistic demon speeds up and Rams
straight into the vulnerable sorcerer
causing him to start spewing up blood
with narutoshi Falling Towards the
ground below nayoya gives Chase and
jokes they're blowing blood into his
Inlet was a dirty move however narutoshi
refuses to give up and claps his hands
together before delivering a powerful
blood beam straight to naoia's head
despite his efforts though naioya
remains completely unfazed and declares
that the Battle Is Over causing
narutoshi to fall into a childhood
flashback so you know big man himself is
having you know his life flesh before
his eyes right now he believes that
honestly he's failed he was never able
to create a safe place for him and is
broken family then coming back to
reality he now sees a malevolent figure
that is naoya leaning over him again
narutoshi is hit by the shell of naio's
curse sitting him shooting back a few
feet but this time the sorcerer quickly
regains his footing thinking to himself
and knowing that no one in his personal
life needs him anymore narutoshi
attempts to retaliate with a straight
punch while proudly stating that now
it's time to completely burn away his
life then one day in the future his
comrades can do the same upon his Fallen
ashes and I'll say Giga man you gotta
chill out you turn into a bit of a bit
of a poll at some of these lines right
here just then as neoya is about to step
forth and in narutoshi's life two brand
new random ass players screaming Sumo
and Katana arrived to join the fight so
that Rainer man screaming for a katana
is actually an old schooler who goes by
the name of dido Hagane like the Sumo
dude he was summoned into the current
time period but right in the middle of
the kagoshima sakurajima colony he
switched far and wide night and day
looking for a beloved Katana until one
day while searching through in an
abandoned child's room he
first form water surface slash sword
Hidden Away In A Box on the other hand
and also on like the 2nd of November the
other random Cullen game player Mio who
was just summoned walked around and
challenged everyone that he came across
for Sumo he challenged every man and
woman and even a tamed dog but no one
accepted his challenges and the end as
he walked around brokenhearted he heard
the phrase nakota and immediately
smashed a Granny's door down to see a
game of sumo taking place on her
television finally happy with finding
that good stuff he asks for the location
and was told that the fight is happening
in ryogoku Tokyo I actually love how
smooth brain looking this dude is p GE
meme character right here but anyway
anyway man's like hmm ryogoku Tokyo the
capital of the East but you know man is
the biggest smooth brain dude about and
wins the wrong direction he actually
went right and eventually strolled into
the sakurajima colony becoming a killing
game player with narutoshi initially
taken off guard by new people showing up
now it takes advantage of his situation
by sending some tentacles his way hidal
girl quickly shows back up and cuts off
the attacking arm seeing the weapon that
Marky wield Dido screams for a katana
and runs in a direction beginning to
scream and cry for her sword knowing
that the battle is in a bit of a
stalemate right now Mucky throws her
Katana in the direction of The Old Man
and the hope that an external Pace to
this fight would alter its outcome
instantly as the old geez's fingers
touched the held of Marquis Katana and
grab a hold all four players feel an
overwhelming presence of power emanate
from him it was not cursed energy but an
overwhelming presence of sheer lethality
like a brutal master of death standing
before them it said that this Dido is
The Reincarnation of a nameless
unmatched swordsman who fights only with
a swordsmanship and not with cursed
energy so like he probably does have
curse energy but doesn't know what it is
or doesn't use it for that purpose
anyway anyway slicing at the curse
nayoya is just barely able to dodge out
of the way of Dido's attack randomly
though the ancient Samurai gets annoyed
and the katana not actually listening to
him and begins yelling at it asking if
it was trying to shame him like Maki
Dido also has no no curse energy and
cannot see the curses so because of that
he asks if there's some kind of ayokashi
in front of him confused as Maki assumed
that he could see it she asks if he
can't he explains that if you can see
everything else besides the cursed
Spirit then it isn't technically the
same as saying it once finishing his
sentence he brings the blade down
connecting directly with nayoya and
slicing him in half taking him
completely by surprise Blown Away with
what she just witnessed Mikey tries to
understand how she couldn't land any
lethal attacks on aoya but Dido easily
could under the same conditions she
Ponders what it is that she isn't saying
and what if there's still some kind of
difference between her and toji in the
end Maki sent us a simple domain appear
behind her turning around she sees Mio
and is challenged with a Sumo belt Maki
decides to enter his simple domain and
notes it only functions when he wants to
do SoMo it's an extremely simple barrier
focused on only one thing so you know
how he was rolling around previous to
this asking people for super matches
well it's actually because during his
pre-suma belt both the Challenger and
opponent must degree to a match to
complete his domain due to this Mio asks
Marky for a belt or if she's like
everyone else and is going to refuse to
do Sumo to Naruto she's annoyance though
Marky nonchalantly ends up agreeing to
take part in the belt the massive open
grin appearing on his face Mio finally
achieves Bliss and his domain begins
surrounding in both confuses to why
Marquis entering narutoshi asks what she
was thinking but Maki actually responds
that she was in fact overthinking and
just needed to blow us some steam with
the domain fully covering the duo now
Maki enters the ring and as she gets
into her pose begins to wonder what the
hell it is she isn't seen thinking more
she sets upon the true question that
everyone has been thinking since the
introduction of toji what is she since
in the approaching attack Mio easily
manages to Dart behind Mahi before she
can grab him and as she turns to counter
instantly Ducks under her lift grab then
quickly spring him back up he manages to
lock his arm perfectly around hers then
uses maki's previous momentum to throw
her over to the edge of the Ring winning
the first bout standing above her
Victorious Mio asks Marky if she's got
another round and her as the moment that
he laid eyes on her he knew that she was
much more powerful doing like the
ballsiest Crouch ever in front of our
Queen he asks what's up and to tell him
what's wrong why why can't she focus
it's explained that Maki never relied on
anyone to become stronger despite having
teachers at the Jujutsu High she always
believed in doing everything on her own
and being self-reliant that's why she
just doesn't know what to say to him
here our smooth brain Mio though seems
that she was still thinking about what
Dido had said earlier given her silence
all this time cutting off her Chain of
Thought he asks her to stand up and have
another Sumo match as that's the only
way he knows how to explain things as
they continue a number of countless
matches Mio begins explaining to her
that she has become entangled in it all
and because of that she's limited her
own progression too much she needs to
instead let herself loose and experience
what it's like to finally be free while
fighting her opponents then everything
before her eyes like the idea of Victory
and the possibility of defeat will
become meaningless or in other words
exactly what the samurai was talking
about Freedom thanks to the wise words
of the ancient Sumo goat Mio and the
multitude of sumo matches Marky finally
knows what to do next and all she has to
do is experience it for herself whether
to begin in another bed of sumo it skips
fourth and soon comes to an end as she
finishes her match with Mio stepping out
now Maki leaves all of the others
shocked as we see our Queen smiling for
the first time and over a decade finally
ready to be free having exited the
domain it's explained that the exchanges
Mark ahead with Mio hadn't even taken
one minute kind of like in a Dragon Ball
Z with a hyperbolic Time Chamber time
moves slower in Mio's domain and the
time it takes for a thousand Sumo belts
is less than one minute fed up with all
of it though Nao your boosts off into
the sky like last time and begins
raising his speed looking over to the
randoms narutoshi notices them
cooperating and asks who they are but to
his surprise they explain that it
doesn't matter who they are others can
think what they want all they care about
is the new to hold a katana and cut what
needs to be cut or they want to get back
in the ring to wrestle with Marky some
more back in the battle as nario boosts
around destroying this city he becomes
annoyed at the fact that he should be
overwhelming her with speed yet for some
reason he can't even touch her sprinting
across a roof now Marky season area
shoot up and boast off in front of her
completely shattering all of the glass
from all of the nearby buildings as he
reaches near top speed somehow like I
don't know how she's got this much gas
now all of a sudden making it over and
in front of Naomi's trajectory Maki
drops down and begins to feel everything
around her and they passed she couldn't
see without glasses but once she gained
this body thanks to Mai she became
content as she was finally like everyone
else but toji he wouldn't just reach
that height he would have pushed
forwards without hesitation and even
being able to deflict nayoya's top speed
attacks with ease seeing what no one
else sees for the first time Marquis
states that it's not enough to be like
everyone else there are things that only
the chosen ones like toji and and
herself can save
boom instantly it's now you're going to
tears through the building directly in
front of Maki trying to hit her with his
top speed once more Marky quickly pulls
herself into a ball and manages to dodge
Neo's top speed attack and midia without
anything to actually move off it's just
freaking insane a lot of the fights in
the series play off like how you can
catch a person off guard in the sky as
they are unable to completely Dodge
because there's nothing to move off the
skies like untangible so this just goes
to show how much of a beast Marcus is
right now she's literally smoking on
that now you're packed through but
anyway anyway moving on Mucky knows that
the air around them may seem empty but
there are my new differences in the
temperature and air density all marking
needs to do is use them to her Advantage
as naoya then attempts to boost it her
once again Maki easily Dodges and
punches the curse down towards the
ground below monkey's like also got that
Mega Juiced up brain as somehow she just
knew that Mia was directly below her
allowing him to land a direct head butt
to the side of the cursor's exoskeleton
not done Dido also reveals himself and
slices at the curse almost completely
cutting through the entirety of naoya
and kellingham coming in as well though
and seemingly Landing in the finishing
blow Maki kicks the back of namu's curse
but I said in his top half tumbling
across the street in front of her
screaming in denial over his possible
defeat now you're tears his hands
through the shell of his curse womb
fully revealing his human shell while
saying that the only one who deserves to
stand with him is himself before
activating his domain expansion with his
domain expansion time cell Moon Palace
active we see a massive malevolent eye
at this Center staring directly at
everyone within its height instantly now
who activates his ability on both Mio
and Dido causing frames to erupt from
their bodies taking the ancient ones by
surprise however even more to their
surprise it disappears allowing them to
begin their attack again though as soon
as they move both of them drop to the
ground absolutely overpowered banayoya's
sure hit technique for anyone as
confused as these old boys are it's
actually because of the fact that anyone
naio touches has to move like him or
they freeze for one second what makes it
all the more brutal as house domain
amplifies his innate technique making it
even more precise not only this he can
even manipulate every cell inside of his
opponent's body and when his opponent
moves every cell would become out of
alignment which explains exactly why Mio
and Dido were severely injured by just
taking one step with Mio collapsing to
the ground he states that it's indeed a
good domain however nayoya only made
this domain expansion for Marquee but as
he tries to sense where she died he
can't find her slightly confused because
this is like his space obviously now you
knows that she lacks curse energy like
toji but thought his domain would be
able to locate her suddenly dotta
purposefully moves his right arm in an
attempt to slice nayoya only to
instantly have it decapitated by the
annoyed cursed Spirit you see though and
typical bottom G Behavior now you
thought it was pointless however Dido
was constructed of the same material as
our girl and was able to sense her
location checking the katana and Mark
his direction from within his own
Shadows Maki suddenly appears and grabs
her blade before Plunge engineer
straight through a traitor's cousin's
back as we all knew but like obviously
this man right here just he just
couldn't accept the fact Markie and toji
have no cursed energy so they can easily
enter and exit barriers unless the
barrier uses a physical object as its
shell or unless there is a specific
condition placed and because naioya
didn't do that within his domain he
cannot trap her inside of it going into
the twins Dream World for a moment the
sisters are able to reconcile together
as they both recognize that Maki finally
broke free from her curse
correspondingly it's explained that they
sawed my left behind as the replica of
the curse tool so Liberation blade that
Sid sword and now Mark is obviously
ignores the hardness of everything and
cuts this Soldier Rex Lee but to use the
full potential requires having a pair of
eyes that can see the soul of anonymous
objects Marky has achieved this and in
the end as NAIA screams at her telling
her that she is lost because she can no
longer move inside of his domain it's
explained to us that this domain's
guaranteed hit can't recognize my due to
her lack of curse energy as I've been
going over so much already and because
of that an oblivious now area is
completely sliced in two subsequently
causing his domain to explode well the
battle seemingly coming to an end and
both Dido and Mayo shocked to somehow
still be alive it said that 12 years
after the death of toji xenon a demonic
fighter of equal strength was finally
born honestly you know it's just so nice
to see Mark even a smile on her face in
each panel such a lovely change from the
angry monkey even though she looked
gangster and was just ready to mess up
anyone's day it's nice to see her with a
smile on your face for the first time as
like her Mission technically has
completely come to an end now she's just
here to be like a goated warrior and
then in the coming battles pretty much
anyway anyway gotta move forward
otherwise all the bottom G's out there
can't take it and they hate it when I
build up amazing female characters which
is really cringe to them for some reason
but anyway so with the aftermath of
Marquis and area's fight it's shown that
she was fully successful in exercising
her as kamo confirmed the one Maki
claims that the win was thanks to the
randoms that had shown up and here
during this narutoshi asks about their
condition just like kaimo Dido and Mio's
conditions are also severe but what Mark
is most concerned about is how narutoshi
just nonchalantly decided to throw his
life away Naruto she tells her though
that he should know his situation
because he's from one of the big
families like her he feels worthless as
he's failed to become the head this also
how he was named by his mother after the
most evil sorcerer in history he asks if
Maki asked hers to what she says that
she did but then she murked her but now
after hearing what the cursing area told
her she doesn't know if it was the right
decision and honestly just worst then
talked more skipping away for a moment
we've witness a glimpse of camo's past
we remembered his family and how his
name actually originated more or less
the reason as to why she named him
narutoshi was that it was the first
thing that came to her mind and she was
paved at the time she didn't know
exactly what was good for him but just
wished that he would abandon the kamo
family and safely return home to her
this little dude who like I initially
thought was camo is actually kamo's half
brother I I just had no idea and I
thought this was a flashback with camo
to start with my brain my brain but
anyway anyway he asks if Naruto she's a
nice guy twitch's Mumsy says that of
course he is after all he's my son
so kicking things back off we shoot over
to Tokyo Colony number one where Hannah
kurasu mysteriously greets an Awakening
Mega me as my fated one still Dosey
Mickey asks how long he was out for with
Yuji who's looking like the maddest King
ever dropped out on a robe sipping on
some wine remarked that he'd been
unconscious for two entire days and now
it's almost the 15th of November having
collected some food himself takaba
enters the room and as Hannah settles on
the couch with a tub of ice cream the
group began discussing how it's quite
odd that the power is still on in Tokyo
Megami presumes that kinjaku may have
colluded with the higher-ups to keep the
power on so it wouldn't interfere with
the cullingham herself and then goes off
to take a dump and because he was out of
the action for the last two days asked
to be filled in on what happened while
he was out let's explain that Yuji
bumped into zacaba and chose to join
forces in an attempt to locate Mega me
eventually takaba was able to locate
Hannah carrying megamik through the sky
and that's how they ended up all here
together bringing him fully up to date
Yuji shows migumi how many points both
Hikari and Yuta have telling him that
including his own and Carver's Point
they've met the quota now all that's
left is to figure out how many points
are needed to actually leave the goddamn
culling game curiously Mega me turns and
asks Hannah if she's the player named
angel that they were looking for and
asks also why she saved him in the first
place as Hannah confirms who she is a
mouth suddenly appears on the side of
her face telling them to cut ask any
check so many questions leaving everyone
stunned By Yuji who exclaims that there
is someone else just like him answering
migami's question Angel then goes to
tell him why he was saved but Hannah
randomly cuts the mouth off obviously
hiding something continuing Angel
witches like the incarnated sorcerer
inside of her if anyone's confused on
why I keep referring to like her as
Angel and Hannah while she explains to
us how exactly her technique Works
simply it negates curse techniques seals
and barriers because of this it allows
her freely to travel between colonies
hence how she was like originally in
Tokyo Colony 2 as they thought the
reason that she even left this colony in
the first place was because her main
goal is to purge all incarnated players
and Tokyo 2 was saturated and cursed
Spirits as we like obviously saw in the
Last Arc her reasoning for this is
because the vessels of incarnated
players are usually suppressed and
destroyed upon Incarnation which goes
against the laws of God therefore Angel
chose to coexist with Hannah sitting
there making me asks if she could use a
curse technique to free Gojo to what she
affirms it's possible but first wants
something in return the disgraced or the
Fallen one she promises to the boys that
if they manage to take him down she
won't hesitate to help well let me all
tell you things certainly take an
interesting turn as Yuji is summoned
into his or sukunas in a world right
here stepping forth both loathe each
other's side yet there isn't any missing
around this time as no sukuna the king
of curse reveals himself to be the
disgraced one which like absolutely
flips the series on its head and let me
tell you right now you ain't ready for
what's about to happen and I I still
can't literally fathom what's just gone
down in 213 but anyways anyways Murphy
Ford noticing that something's up with
his boy making me calls out his name
asking if he's okay looking like he
freaking died on the inside Yuji says
that he just ain't really feeling that
well and asks Hannah to switch places
with him so that he can lie down man's
actually suffering after realizing he's
been hunted by yet another ancient
sorcerer having moved out of Hannah's
point of view Yuji then begins trying to
gesture that the disgraced one is sukuna
Man actually I love migami's confused us
face right here eventually though and
after sitting down with Hannah he
realizes what Yuji is trying to say
Megami Ponders on how they needed help
to save Gojo but now they're completely
back at square one as her Target is
technically ug similarly Yuji Muses
about why sakuna told him to keep quiet
and concludes that angel must have some
sort of ability that can completely
obliterate sukuna without any chance of
return Yuji obviously being Yuji thinks
that this is a cheap price to pay to end
the cursed spirit and decides that as
soon as the others implement the roles
required to save sakumi he will die with
the two comparatively overthinking
everything angel speaks again breaking
their thoughts and remarking that it's
odd how a large number of people are
currently entering the colony quickly
the group command equal game to show the
current culling game player base while
they're revealing 807 active players
with more joining every minute so right
now in this story with Yuji and stuff
we're in November of 2018. well taking
things back quite a few months until
February we find that kinjaku and
sukuna's Chef urume are explaining to
the U.S officials the existence of curse
energy and cursed Spirits so apparently
Chris is a usually only observable by
the Japanese population with some
exceptions this includes the fact that
they are mostly invisible to like the
naked eye obviously curses and curse
energy themselves live within like
specific wavelengths of visible light
that the normal human brain can't pick
up on and man-made cameras don't
actually capture the correct light to
view what's really happening through
their lens which by the way if you've
watched yellow Monster's Dope video
going over Jujutsu kaizen's Iceberg well
it goes into the theory that due to
kaizen's Cursed realm is the same place
as in gigo agatami's first story called
number nine and which the main character
who I think like looks exactly like a
man
uses weapons and shikagami-like
creatures that he summons from nine
different boxes that interact with a
shadowy realm plus remember that one
time sakuna told the black box to open
just before he used a flame Arrow to
sing jogo to the cursed realm honestly I
just didn't move on right now otherwise
I might just start dropping series
changing theories that have hit Cannon
right on the spot so anyway after having
handed out the cursed glasses udemy lets
everyone know that they function as a
screen and will allow them to see curses
along with the Menifee stations made by
kusk energy and certainly after placing
on the glasses the U is President along
with his secretary's react in shock
horror asking what kind of disgusting
trick this is Cyrus one of the US
presidents officials speaks up telling
them that they all need to calm down as
they'd already been able to confirm that
this is all reality and if they don't
cease this opportunity they'll fall
behind as a global power the two
Sorcerers then exercise the cursed
Spirit assuring the officials that they
mean no harm elaborating some more on
how curses don't appear on man-made
cameras uramae state that they have
video footage recorded using Jiu Jitsu
technology that works by capturing a
puppet's vision specifically they show
footage to the officials that was taken
through kokichi's puppet's vision giving
him a taste of sukuna Gojo nanami and
Toto's abilities the president like
who's just watched all of us makes a
joke about it not being IMAX quality
however secretary stylist ah oh my God a
stylist secretary Cyrus declares that
they just don't get it cool Synergy has
the potential to become the cleanest
energy source in history replacing every
other form of known energy on the entire
planet Cyrus stresses that even the
blonde dude they just watched through
hands possesses enough curse energy to
power an entire country sitting before
them the body swapping goon then informs
them that in November Tokyo will become
a domain of pure viciousness where all
Jiu Jitsu users will be forced to
congregate for a ritual hearing this and
becoming enraged the president of the
good old USA demands to know if he's
being told to kidnap Japanese citizens
and use them as research subjects
standing there himself Cyrus insists on
the importance of tapping into curse
energy is an alternative energy source
he emphasizes that sorcerer's defied
modern science in technology because
their brains were wired differently
however the whole idea of abducting
people for human experimentation truly
horrifies the president and an attempt
to fully convince the big pay C Cyrus
goes on a mad ride citing various
Nations like China Russia Saudi Arabia
and the Middle East who would surpass
him as a world power if they did not do
anything beginning to twist facts it
declares that their operation would be
to form a protection for the Japanese
people against other countries that
could Target them indiscriminately
sorcerer or not his advisor also
suspected that because this negotiation
was being kept Under Wraps the failure
to comply with Force kinjaku to
negotiate with other countries having
overheard them kinshaku added that
because Sorcerers were a minority even
among Japanese citizens the November
Gathering would be an excellent
opportunity to collect specimens knowing
that there are Japanese descendants in
the US the president orders them to be
heavily guarded in order to protect them
from attacks by foreign countries
quickly following this up hitting turns
and asks for Gary K this Special
Operations Commander how many soldiers
they should deploy to Japan Gary who
calls himself like a military man mate
bro we obviously all figure that one out
ask for more confirmation about the
average strength of sorcerers after
learning that the main threat in Gojo
would be locked away in November Gary
becomes confident that one battalion of
60 soldiers would suffice given that all
the sorcerers were amateurs he declared
that even with his supernatural
abilities they couldn't compete with his
skill weapons and experience of trained
U.S soldiers kinjaku casually agrees but
States he'd still recommend a full
Battalion of at least 800 soldiers to
deal with this Sorcerers effectively
hearing this Gary dismisses the idea
mocking the Japanese people and pretty
much calling them weak empathetic
speaking up odomay proposes a test and
moments later kinjaku Snidely guessed
that the 15 men guarding their meeting
room definitely wasn't everyone here so
I always lose it here but the mixing
actually ends and the special ops
manager goes in depth to the president
about how in addition to the the 15
Secret Service agents guarding the room
men from Sac the caa's paramilitary
division were patrolling the White House
along with them there's another 45 elite
soldiers ready to bring down sugodu gito
having moved from the East to the west
side of the building now they believe
that gitto would never be able to defeat
all of them a new West office and
wanting to wrap this up ghetto gets
ready to unleash his technique in a show
of dominance opposite them on the east
side that crazy ass man Gary states that
these silly old Japanese people should
stick to anime and cars right now the US
objective isn't to win but to instead
present such an overwhelming show of
force that is America instead though
man's instantly shocked when all of his
soldiers began falling from the sky
oblivious to how it even happened though
after chucking on his sunnies Gary
finally realized the true horrifying
power that is conspirate manipulation
back inside kinjaku throws down all 45
name tags in front of the president
asking if they Now understand so
skipping away from our February like
just then and Todd traveling all the way
up to November and first of all mind if
I like just blow your minds for a moment
here but remember Raco she wasn't
actually the only one that was a star
plasma vessel like I actually thought
there there was only one star plasma
vessel hence why tingham was like no I
guess I can't anyway she wasn't Yuki was
actually also compatible with tinken but
the reason tenkin chose Rico was because
no one existed with her potential making
her the ideal vessel which just keeps me
wondering like is Yuji someone who's
compatible with sukuna because he also
fits the same potential as a vessel I
don't know it's just an idea that I've
had wall scripting obviously let me know
your thoughts on that down below when
Yuki demanded to know why tingen hadn't
rest not merging with another vessel The
Immortal sorcerer stated that they had
simply accepted reality Tinker knew that
it would eventually happen and he might
become a threat to humanity upon
evolving but reason that they could
retain their sanity using barrier
techniques which does make sense as
tingen is the most proficient barrier
user currently known in the series was
sukuna being the greatest RTC user of
all time as well and since by the
explanation Yuki asks a really good temp
question was it reasonable to burden all
of the children with his own
responsibilities like it's honestly just
said that this thumb of a man doesn't
see these star plasma vessel as humans
but more it's just Expendable paces and
that's why Yuki was so paved with how he
casually disregarded them think he'd
only passed now Yuki grumbles that she
could have helped the start organization
if the aim was to Simply prevent the
merging instead of killing the vessels a
theme revealed that Yuki is able to hear
the voices of past star placement
vessels unlike tinken itself tingin
asked Yuki to tell them what their
voices were saying but Yuki refused
stating that the immortal sorcerer would
only use those words to justify their
decision to evolve sign over not really
getting anywhere Tegan states that they
would have liked to chat some more yet
they're unable to as it's shown that the
megalomaniac body swapping Fame King
jaku was able to break through and enter
the area above the Tomb of the star
Corridor if you all remember from way
back at the beginning of the preparation
Arc well chozo had teamed up with the
Yuki to protect tinken from this exact
issue due to this choso our brother is
the first to intercept kinjaku or
standing opposite his disgusting father
he States his intent to finally end him
kinjaku though simply dismisses him as a
dispensable Pawn declaring that the
preparations for the merger between
tengen and the Japanese civilian
population had been completed with a
culling game having now served its true
purpose he then also states that once he
gets his hands on tingen it's all over
Japan and the world are done for
suddenly we then move into a theater as
kinjaku shows his son one version of
what could possibly happen later on if
everyone remembers during Shibuya and
how Yuki mentioned that optimizing
cursed energy through tenken will cause
non-sorcerers to assimilate well kinjaku
adds onto this theory of who's here
revealing that he believed that to be
the step which preceded the merger and
unlike Yuki he didn't want to create a
world without cursed Spirits kinchaku
wanted to cause kuspirus to evolve to
the next stage to create a new form of
cursed energy so in order to achieve
this it began citing his earlier
experimentations including the creation
of the death painting wombs but deemed
him all to be utter failures we all know
from stuff that we've learned so far
that an evolved tengan is more curspeed
than human so emerging all non-sorcerers
with him would cause the Consciousness
to technically cause tingen's
Consciousness to become one with
everyone in Japan this means in
kinjaku's eyes that a hundred million or
so people merging together would be able
to create a god-level monolith with
infinite power with kinjaku's film
coming to a close and the realm changing
back to normal choso just asks why why
is he even doing this to actually
craziest sorcerer alive stated that a
just sounded like fun with kinjaku
trying to drop a joke an infuro edachoso
claps his hands together before
beginning an attack with piercing blood
although you know typical gear fashion
we don't actually get to see that
piercing blood attack straight away and
said we go back to before the fight
kicked off but now with big bro choso in
the room as well there he tells yukin
tingen that he'd like to face kinjaku
alone
Yuki though stated that he'll die if he
did so to watch choso like the absolute
G he is counted by asking if she would
prefer to fight kinjaku alongside him he
admitted that in such a situation he
would only be a hinderance so the best
bit was for him to engage kinjaku in
combat and force him to reveal more
about his cursed techniques giving Yuki
and tingen an advantage Yuki states that
he'll still die but chosu stated that it
didn't matter if it allowed them to end
his and his brother's manipulative
father flashing back as chosu's passing
blood shoots off hinjaku watching the
approaching Tech manages to easily Dodge
out of the way of the attack while
releasing a centipede-like curse to
attack his opponent having destroyed the
curse along with a large section of the
Tome choso watches kinjaku shoot out in
front of him and fling a large piece of
rubble in his Direction seeing it chozo
screams that he's been underestimated
but instantly he's proven wrong as
several cursed Spirits burst out from
behind the throne piece of concrete
throwing a condensed orb of blood
forward himself choto uses Supernova to
eviscerate the cursors however the cloud
provided conjug with a quick opening to
engage the death painting and
hand-to-hand combats after being pushed
back and realizing that he was at a
disadvantage so as he tried to buy some
time by asking how kinjaku intended to
use Yuji since he was undeniably
different from the death paintings so
obviously it's explained here by kinjaku
that he doesn't really have a plan for
Yuji other than being sakuna's vessel
Yuji and sakuna are catalysts as long as
they told live the chain of curses will
never end choso aslian raged by his
opponent's conviction that Yoji was the
reason for all of this Bloodshed
declares that it was kinjaku whose
existence fueled the chain of curses not
his brothers being taken off guard toso
looked down to see some small curses
tugging at him when all of a sudden King
Jaco takes the opportunity and pummels
his face sending him spinning backwards
and suddenly following up he Stomps our
poor boy's face and condescendently
declares that he's only been using
low-level curses on him but maybe that
was unnecessary since choso was so
pathetically weak just straight up and
rage now Joseph foot again but he gets
nowhere as he's quickly slammed back
against the floor kinjaku asks the
defending cursed wound if he even knows
what the rank of special grade stands
for which also unable to block any
longer because overrides and completely
decimates him all the while this body
swapping freak remarks there is the
ability to single-handedly destroy
Nations those like Saturday and suguru
with special grades because of their
obvious abilities to completely
obliterate Nations or create an army of
unparalleled monsters hinjaku added that
by strengthening pathetically weak
curses with curse energy he can easily
deal with a failure like choso playing
there a boy berates himself for failing
to be a good older brother to Yuji and
his other siblings he needed to protect
them and be there to be dependent on as
that's what big brothers do but now he
couldn't even Land one hit against his
creep of a father man will never go down
and still like the king he is chozo
stands back up refusing to evaluate his
brother's names be disrespected
screaming he demands and all his
brothers lend him their strength as he
prepares to deliver a raging attack from
behind him choso all of a sudden begins
to feel the support of his younger
brothers pushing him forward ESO kachizu
and Yuji assure him that he's got this
subsequently an emotionally overwhelmed
choso begins attacking kinjaku using all
his power and cursed technique standing
there the letter observes that the
passing blood's initial velocity is its
top speed dodging the attack he
continues explaining that the ability
loses its lethality once the opponent
gets used to its speed and changing the
trajectory will only slow it down
watching hinjaku effortlessly Dodges
attacks Tricia decides to further use an
approximation of one king the most
powerful version of Esau's rot technique
which if you've forgotten what this
technique does well when the lines of
blood connect with its Target they are
instantly burned by the corrosive
effects of the death penis blood as
chosu darts and throwing a fat right
Hawk hinjaku calls his version of eso's
technique just a cheap substitute
however troto releases the technique
sending four beams of blood shooting
towards the body swapping vein having
summoned a curse hinjaku backflips out
of the way using the curse as a shield
before sending a bunch of low-level
curses towards chosen as well having
been head directly back in jagu's
previous attack the letter explains that
iso's ability was not as fast as
piercing blood and wouldn't even affect
him as he's his father chilling over on
a tree branch now he asks the cursed
worm if there was even a point to
everything that he's doing now beaten
and bruised Jose declares that he must
fight with the grace of eso the freedom
of kachizu and the domineering strength
of Eugene suddenly kinjaku was taken off
guard when chosu's arm fully detaches
and begins blasting towards his enemy
using the connecting blood as a robe
using this arm is a freaking grappling
hook chosu latches on and pulls the
megalomaniac sorcerer towards him
destroying the ground in the process
before reconnecting his hand to his body
and utterly pummeling his fat right hook
into the face of kinjaku still like my
man's way too quick somehow big brain
kinjaku managed to use a curse shield to
protect himself and lie on their
unharmed he asks of his son as done
choso would just like the fattest grin
on his face like like man's entire
purpose has been for this moment right
here asks the dumbass what he thinks
releasing another burst of Asus ability
he does his best to attack the fleeing
Sorcerer And if you just didn't catch on
to what he's doing right now oh bro big
freaking choso is actually Omega third
eye level of pre-planning and uses his
brother's technique to create a funnel
to purposely trap kingjaku within giving
him utterly nowhere to run as he
releases a few supernovas on either side
of the malevolent entity instantly as
Supernova activates something destroys
the entire floor all around kijaku only
leaving a precise place where kinjaku
was standing intact kind of confused
chozo Ponders if he missed but just
knows that he didn't he activated
simultaneous attacks all around him so
how could it be due to this he quickly
deduces that he was finally able to get
him to use something other than cursed
Spirit manipulation finally revealing
herself as well the special grade
sorcerer Yuki sumoku states that she may
have been an only child but thanks chosu
either way as your older brother for all
of his efforts having heard what Yugi
has to say trustly faints as relief hits
him and falls through a gap that appears
in the barrier looking at her opponent
Yuki states that she likes it wrath but
will have to beat him into shape so as I
said just before Yuki is a special grade
sorcerer yet even kinjaku reveals that
because of the security around her
technique he was unable to acquire any
information on her unwilling to face a
close range attack from an unknown
technique kinshaku decides to maintain a
safe distance and summons the curse
spirit that he had used at the White
House the school spirit here like I
think everyone presumed isn't even
originally from Japan still it's
actually a special Great Divine being
which uses a technique that removes
obstacles by using Concepts or logic
against cursed technique targets more or
less it's freaking broken Yuki who's
like obviously interested to see how
strong this Bane is begins darting
forward while raping up his shikigami
called gruda into a ball dropping a
shikagami down towards your feet you're
hitting boots it with all of her mind
sending it blasting towards fine curse
From Below kinjaku completely blown away
can only watch as his special grade is
utterly annihilated with a single blow
quickly following up Yuki taunts him for
being cautious against an unknown
technique before revealing her ability
revolves around the idea of mass which
like we all learned in school Mass is
the true weight of something and to
figure out something's mess all we got
to do is divide mass by gravity so 30
kgs times 9.8 meters a second squared
equals 294 Newtons but I don't even know
if that actually matters to the story
here I just thought I'd Chuck it in
because why not ferociously she punches
kinjaku in the face synonym shoots him
back across the room in fact the blow is
totem strong and not only rips off both
of his arms but also seems from flying
across the empty space within tengen's
barrier utterly pulverizing any
generated structure in his path it's
actually shown that kinjaku was hit so
far that he completely exited the
confines of the barrier itself sitting
there kinjaku realizes that Yuki uses a
specific concept to Target acoustic nag
creating mass overwhelming enough to
obliterate anything and it's path Yuki
standing there and just looking like a
babe explained that she can give herself
any amount of virtual or imaginary mass
and that she calls that technique star
rage having heard this information
kingjaku also deduces that virtual mass
and boob by star rage doesn't actually
affect Yuki as your speed hasn't
decreased at all something super
different about Yuki is the fact that
she also defies Concepts meaning that
kinjaku is completely unable to use a
high grade curse Spirit like he had in
Shibuya looking at her the body swapping
douche wonders if you really can take
down this Beast of a sorcerer
recognizing that kinjaku's previous
ability involved gravity and leaves Yuki
convinced that kinjaku has at least
three other techniques beside ghetto's
curse manipulation and body hopping
technique he doubts that he has many
more as well as without an external Aid
like Yuda arakatsu's Rika the user's
brain would explode under such stress
she guessed that in the worst case
scenario kinjaku has yet another full
technique upper sleeve thinking as well
kinjaku deduces that yohi's special
grade rank suggests that she probably
has a high course energy output
extension technique what you'll use as
your trump card Yuki's plan here though
is that she's actually going to force
kinjaku to use his domain expansion
which as we've learned so far throughout
the series will make it more difficult
for him to use multiple curse techniques
afterwards in the end she decides to
systematically weaken kingjaku's domain
before striking the final blow but that
isn't actually what's going to happen if
you think alkai's plans ever worked out
and to do to Kaizen you are smoking on
the wrong pack this is kinjaku's world
man has the plan planned out all right
like you guys need to get that in your
mind nothing goes anyone's way in the
series he knows that they find each
other tricky but unlike Yuki he doesn't
like the confidence to unleash pure
dominance having moved his hands
together kinjaku releases his domain
expansion the burialless womb profusion
instantly Yuki screams out to Tinker
wondering if there's still enough time
so good older good old yeah again taking
things back a moment tingen explained
that during the battle they would
confront king jaku and a labyrinth
Barrier located directly below the coast
warehouse and just above the too many
Star Corridor each room inside of the
celebrant themed barrier is empty this
allows a skilled sorcerer for say like
this example kinshaku to be able to
alter its structure or at least that's
what they would want him to think as if
that's the case then he'll most likely
feel comfortable and lower his guard the
reason they need him to feel comfortable
is so that he'll nonchalantly use the
domain expansion within tenkin's empty
barrier and if this is the case tinken
who's extremely proficient at barrier
control but obviously from what we've
seen but under the condition that Yuki
can hold off conjunction for 10 seconds
be able to manipulate and dispel the
theme's domain so obviously Yuki could
have also used the domain expansion here
but using her during that time would
also cause her domain to be dispelled as
that's literally their plan here with
tingen instead to protect herself from
tangent she had planned to use a simple
domain Yuki pondered a fusing her domain
would be a more efficient way of forcing
their opponent to open his domain
however tingen reason that her domain
would be dispelled first as it's
technically the outer layer am I also
give kinjaku the opportunity to counter
with a simple domain or Hollow wicker
basket lastly he warned her that kinjaku
is one of the very few people who can
equal him and bury her usage so don't
assume that his domain is like everyone
else's which was the biggest
foreshadowing to what we've just
freaking sane yet kingjaku's true
potential was even higher than tingen
ever suspected as just like the goat
during Shibuya these body swapping
genius cast a burialis domain leaving no
outer boundary for tingen to remove at
all instantly in retaliation to The
Domain you could cast a new Shadow style
simple domain however almost immediately
and judicinjaku not having a barrier on
his domain tingen's technique actually
began stripping away Yuki shell with no
other option she Sprints forth in an
attempt to take hinjaku down slowly
tenkin also begins stripping away the
body swapping structuralist barrier
however kinshaku remained unfazed and
screamed that unlike tingen he has lived
for over a thousand years and a cursed
world of Rife with conflicts and
alliances
then out of freaking nowhere Yuki who's
left with no defeaters is utterly rocked
by the pure force that is gravity
pounding down on her sending her
shooting through the floor of Tegan's
empty labyrinthine barrier now in the
Tomb of the star Corridor itself and
with Yuki completely and utterly crushed
kinshaku staked they had this special
great sorcerer used her domain instead
of relying on an old fool she may have
feared better man this old dude must
have no friends cause holy he just loves
talking to himself he even further barks
on that tenkaku had hidden a vital piece
of information regarding the culling bro
can't even finish his sentence as he
notices Yuki shikagami still hasn't
disappeared and certainly shooting at
him Garuda destroys the area around
kinjaku forcing her back kinjaku guess
that this sorcerer was trying to buy
herself enough time to heal using RTC
however man is just completely wrong and
Yuki looking like he just got out of a
washing machine after 24 hours still
somehow continues to relentlessly attack
disregarding her injuries and giving the
villain no chance to recover kinjaku
just blown away asked why she is
inhaling but Yuki just utterly doesn't
care continuing like the pure demon she
is Yuki lashes out and kicks the ancient
sorcerer until it seemed as if she may
have finally reached her limit dropping
to the floor saying this kinjaku asked
her if that was it leading Yuki to ask
the villain if he had forgotten her
declaration she likes it wrath they're
right on freaking Q the big man himself
chosu returns to the fight entering the
empty barrier from behind kinjaku with
its technique fully activated doing the
Giga as per usual though would skip back
just before the battle broke out this is
if any reason their domains neutralize
curse techniques so he wouldn't open his
domain if he expected choso to join the
fight later meaning that he should as he
mentioned before fight first he
suggested that he face off against the
madman first following him into
believing that his only opponent for the
rest of the fight was Yuki then finally
reappear back in the battle now and
completely stunned kinjaku is
immediately restrained by Garuda laying
him down firmly landed on the ground
chosu slaps his hands together and tells
his brother others to watch as their big
bro is about to commit petrified
incidentally our boy uses pissing blood
on his dad at a point-blank range yet
bro have your brain even managed to
dodge there Yuki and choso are also just
like blown away as they get a glimpse of
kinjaku's True Form if he observed that
the villain had spun his hair
deliberately to deflect the attack which
is just actually insane when you think
about it man's got like a his skull is
literally just a cap at this moment like
he's wearing it around like Chuck like
it's crazy let me interchange caps
change hairstyles and stuff is what I'm
wondering right up anyway I need to
continue on she concluded that conjuga
was desperate enough to do such a move
because he was also becoming troubled
knowing this the duo keep up the heated
bait down attacking in tandem laying fat
kicks punches and elbows on the sorcerer
using your RTC Yuki easily manages to
fix her mangled arm and other injuries
but the momentary distraction weakened
star rage just enough to allow King
jacket to escape welding Garuda like a
whip now Yuki swings at kinjaku only
just missing but the energy released
from the attack as early demolishes the
floor and walls of the star corridor
around him with everyone falling down
onto some water below shotsu takes the
opportunity to attack through this smoke
screen while simultaneously Yuki elix
lose another attack using a star rage
and viewed cursed Hall korov got
themselves though ochoso and Garuda
dropped to the floor under the weight of
kinjaku's overwhelming gravity and
replenished technique Yuki shikigami
lashes out trying to move but it's
unable under the gravity and while Yuki
runs into collect it she deduces how
kinjaku's technique Works she concludes
that the ancient sorcerer's attacks have
a radius of two or three meters and
remained active for at least six seconds
swinging hookah root at him she knows
that once he's caught something within
his gravity trap Ninjago will then
finish it off with a cursed Spirit but
doubt that that will even work against
her and she's not gonna stop until she
baits him down and wins though she
should have honestly just won and not
internalized her as ginjaku was able to
Parry off a vicious head punch before
grabbing Yuki's arm and directing a
miniature Uzumaki at her face with Yuki
completely fried from the point-blank
blast she begins to Dart backwards when
all all of a sudden kinjaku follows up
and forms another miniature Uzumaki
while remarking that her density may
have increased due to Star rage but her
tensile strength didn't releasing the
ability kinjaku leads choto screaming in
horror as he attacked his straight
through Yuki's abdomen really damn
abruptly rear game fly into a flashback
where our team is sitting at a bar there
Yuki asked choso if he didn't want to be
there for Yuji since it seemed like he
was thrown his life away now not
answering the question though chosu
asked if he's even human he remembers
thinking back to the time when his
brothers took form and realized that
they would never be accepted by humans
because of their deformed locks so from
this chose to decided to live as a curse
with his brothers hence why he killed so
many people in Shibuya and why now he
burdens themselves with their deaths
said him with his choices big bro choto
states that if he had chosen to live as
a human he wouldn't have lost them
weeping he wonders why chose the easy
path was it because he didn't want to
see his brother suffering as humans
however a human thinks showed up who
just happened to be suffering himself
those four were meant to be brothers and
fight together as one but instead he
took the easy Road and left Yuji all
alone returning to the battle choso
gearing up to unleash a spinning wheel
of blood at the enemy states that the
only way to make it up to all of his
brothers is to use up all of his life
here but before he could even do that
the G himself like this is the only time
I'm calling Tegan a g because I don't
know his ulterior motives right here the
G removes him forcibly from the barrier
Yuki looking like Gojo for real tells
him that this battlefield was where the
death paintings Life as a curse ended
and his time as a human begun so because
of that he must live above the falling
choso Yuki's body also falls to the
ground but in two pieces for this
seemingly defeated by kinjaku's previous
blow behind the two tingen then reveals
themselves causing kinjaku to actually
start laughing at his thumb's appearance
even comparing him to sukuna's original
form which actually has to have some
kind of freaking mirror in the story
right there tingen is like dude check
your kills all I had to do was distract
you for literally two damn seconds
allowing Yuki's top half the glue I
don't understand this as well you his
top half she just reaches out and grabs
his leg to literally reach out and grab
your cankle bro not taking him seriously
though kinjaku just tells her to die
before all of a sudden and out of
freaking nowhere a massive Force becomes
ripping the sorcerer down towards Yuki
as I mentioned at some point earlier on
Yuki's techniques alteration and mass
doesn't actually affect her up to a
certain density that is and you remember
when kinjaku asked choso what makes a
special grade well nothing you've seen
so far from Yuki would actually give our
girl the ranking of special grade but
yeah she's insane her strength alone is
mental but this next technique is what
makes her the threat to every freaking
life form on this planet when Yoshi goes
beyond her next entity control point the
sorcerer can add an infinite amount of
mass with her curse technique and if you
somehow haven't caught on yet yes she
can create a goddamn Black Hole by just
continuously just pushing more and more
density into it the end result of what
she had just formed was the creation of
a black hole which not only consumed
Yuki's entire body but trapped all
matter and even light with inert right
before disappearing you hear the clear
to kinjaku that he should have seen this
coming as gravity mass and time or need
to be wielded with Extreme Caution with
the black hole fully formed it began
sucking away literally everything from
the surrounding area inside of the Tomb
of the star Corridor as the energy from
the black hole then finally begins to
subside it's revealed that even the
ceiling of the Tome began crumbling away
with natural light breaking through and
lighting up the underground Chambers by
the way you know I'm just going to say
this right here rest in peace Yuki I'm
pretty sure she died from that so rest
in peace what an insane attack but
despite the immense gravitational force
exerted by the black hole kinjaku
somehow manages to survive climbing out
from underneath the collapsed deer
Breeze stunned by this himself Tegan
asked if he had used the reverse curse
technique in combination with his
gravity technique but kinjaku actually
makes a shocking Revelation declaring
that the true nature of the technique
had not been gravity at all he admitted
that his third curse technique
originally belonged to Eugene mother
kaori itadori with its true form being
the anti-gravitational system kinjaku
added that he had taken a risky Gamble
and used laps to reverse the effects of
the technique stabilizing the output and
activation by using his own body as a
domain like I said this is like
obviously kinjaku's freaking world man
has pre-planned absolutely everything
for a millennia so I don't know how our
boys are going to actually end up
wanting here like the famous jjk scholar
broken Ronin also once said every word
in the series has Merit so think on this
kinjaku as he watches tingen's operation
disappearing states that this was just a
warm-up then finding the Letter's body
encased within the trunk of a tree and
the star Corridor kinjaku says goodbye
to his friend so remember how we leave
things with Yuji and his group at the
end of like the last period well as the
influx of American soldiers entered the
culling game a multitude of code games
appeared and began registering the
soldiers as new players elsewhere
kinjaku and a roommate are seen at these
in inclines Warehouse which surprisingly
has explained that there is a secret way
to transfer between colonies simply
someone could not leave a colony unless
they've answered the code games call
unimpressed by this automatic instead
suggested that this space would be more
suitable as the bar for sukuna's Revival
flying back over to the American troops
as they invade Remy's room which is just
like the biggest Alpha who are not gonna
lie in military fashion they throw
flashbang before rushing in and trying
to immobilize her with a taser allowing
them to then easily inject her with a
sedative outside a group of soldiers are
seen remarking that his Sorcerers were
nothing special and simply wondered why
their Lieutenant was so worried in the
first place rolling up we see another
group of soldiers who had taken out
their target instead of capturing it as
ordered the soldier in charge rebuked
her but the letter flippantly said that
it didn't matter since the brain was
unharmed she further complained there
was really nothing worked against the
Sorcerer And even a 50 cal bullet didn't
Pierce through the target's skin so
remember the helicopter dude usually
absolutely pummeled well that's actually
the person her Squad took out here
having heard that the dude had a
helicopter type head the soldier was
hesitant to believe her until he saw
just how damaged the female's comrades
were in the end she concluded that there
must be Sorcerers of various power
levels and she just got stuck with one
of the tougher ones which you know like
to us readers is absolutely hilarious
thinking that Harbor for some reason as
op is too good I can't actually wait
until they find a proper a grade or
above sorcerer and have to fight them in
like some kind of way funnily enough we
pop over and see the Ruffian himself has
a Noki exploding some poor unsuspecting
soldiers Vehicles as they rolled nearby
noticing that the enemy was a foreigner
the sorcerer remembered Reggie's words
from earlier and wondered if this was
the bomb he suggested kinjaku would drop
now back with the megalomaniac himself
and ultimate the letter guessed that the
curse energy of every Colony would be
increased by petting sorceress against
non-sorcerers and any custom but for the
merger with tinken kinjaku though
admitted that what uduma had guessed
there's only about 60 of his plan
elaborating that the curse energy levels
in every Colony except Tokyo and Cinder
still an efficient also kinjaku did only
say that Tokyo was the Battleground to
the US so I'm assuming that they like
aren't anywhere else in the country
other than Tokyo Colony number one or
two but we're gonna find out about that
later on What's even funnier I've had
the military is that kinjaku had only
sent in the foreign military as
insurance and was already aware that if
fighting would not be very intense
having manifested a curse to clean up
the mess that was okizen kinjaku claimed
that unlike reincarnated players those
who had only recently awaken their
cursing next would be reluctant to fight
and the US may even Retreat if they get
too many casualties it'll make question
if the military had been sent in at
night to give them an advantage and also
wonders since non-japanese individuals
would not release curse energy so how is
it actually going to help him yet it's
actually revealed that in the moment of
passing there is an exception as the
stress of seeing curses pushes them to a
new level it's also considered natural
law that non-sorcerers can't win against
Jujutsu sorcery elsewhere as one poor
poor American Soldier notices a
terrifying her spirit at further goes in
depth that King jagu had released
multiple curse Spirits in every Colony
that are specifically active only at
night to force out that higher level of
cursed energy from these new soldiers
back over with the main crew now Angel
quickly deduced that kinjaku had sent a
non-sorcerers to be killed by cursed
Spirits as a Fail-Safe to produce more
curse energy having left the room now
and made their way down some stairs the
group ran into an empty cafeteria right
as a stunning grenade lands in front of
them obviously thrown by the military
boys noticing it Yuji quickly kicks the
flesh being away before it could explode
in front of them seeing the squad pull
up Megami initially assumed that these
soldiers were trying to protect people
but instantly discarded the possibility
as their soldiers with their second
thought began shooting at the sorcerers
abruptly within seem to skip away and
see what seems to be the past memory for
make her spirit feeding three young
children inside of an abandoned building
then back with a group all of a sudden
we see good old Mega me interrogating a
Japanese soldier who was actually acting
as a guide for the foreign military
forces when henna asks why Japan had not
taken the option opportunity to become
energy self-sufficient sooner the
soldier responds that Jesus headquarters
controlling the country is too proud and
everyone here is obsessed with
self-responsibility so it never would
caught on like it would have in other
countries it can be also realized that
kinjaku had only lured the military to
the colonies under the false proteins
that curse energy was up for grabs as
another energy source from thus Mickey
with introduces that this soldier's
death would increase the cursed energy
in their colonies and complete the
ritual preceding tinga's merger with the
wider Japanese population making me you
know like obviously it's so damn big
brain that the dude even suspects that
King Jacob has likely orchestrated the
culling game as a distraction for his
true plan stepping in Yuji asks if they
should help them prompted to Kaba to ask
why they should even help people who
wanted to abduct them for experiments
making me reasons that if they allow
kinjaku to fulfill the ritual everyone
would be caught up in the merger with
tingen yet Angel Cuts in telling them
that it's no use since Tokyo Kalani 1
has already reached the required level
of curse energy Yuji challenges Angel's
decision though stating that it didn't
and validate their saving of other
people's lives the letter tries
explaining to Yuji though that it has a
symbiotic relationship with its vessel
so putting Hannah at unnecessary risk is
akin to put any curse living within her
body at risk itself shooting over we
didn't see the true Terror that some
soldiers are being put through after
having fun with its first Soldier the
predatory curse then picked up its next
prey which just happened to be the same
Japanese soldier the group was
interrogating before laying there and
suspecting the worst this Soldier thinks
back on the times he had believed that
he was ready to pass on but feels that
now this is different and seeing what
awaits him truly shatters his resolve
nearby Eugene migami just happened to be
running through an Alleyway Megami
insists to his boy that he doesn't need
to be so hostile and asks a Fuji's
comment about not trusting henna was a
reference to bands like sakuna and Angel
skipping away for a moment and referring
back to the random like flashback that
we had just before well it was actually
henna as a child sadly she had been
forced to live with that curse spirit
for almost a year eventually though she
managed to escape after following a
white dog with a fluffy tail of course
it was no one other than migami's white
Divine dog who had little to safety
before returning to him in Gojo as henna
watches the three Ryu night and begin to
leave and flashes back to the prison as
she remembers the kind nurse because of
their moment during her childhood she
decided to try and help people herself
as she's always believed that someday
they would meet again and she would
proudly stand by his side all Megami
wanted was for Yuji to be a bit more
considerate twitch like after hearing
all of this a boy confesses that ever
since they regrouped he was just scared
that Hannah would take no virus place
but you know oh my Lord Giga we actually
got some nobara crumbs for the first
time in like how long it's we're damn
fiends out here absolutely wanting
anything to do with her or Gojo man just
come on come on please anyway as
becoming scold shuji and asks him to
apologize to Hannah the queen whose ever
pierced before the boys bringing the
crew fully back together let the
ripening begin if you guys know what I
mean then you know I mean it's huge
beings of light suddenly emerged from
every Colony throughout Japan they can
subtract any attention of everyone
throughout the entire country not
understanding what's happening many
people just know that something doesn't
feel right like the ear had become a
naturally dry returning to our crew Maki
gives everyone a full rundown of
everything that's happened up till this
point she explained that chosu had
managed to protect the back of the
prison realm but relay the news of
Yuki's defeat in tinga's capture in
another location our boy choso clutchini
bet gay or literally hope itself in this
case here I guess weeps as Carrara asked
him about Yuki's whereabouts pretty much
to me at least confirming her demise
Maki further told the first two years
that the ritual precedingly merger had
already ended calmly Machi concluded
that taking down the villain would be a
challenge leading Yuji to wonder how
they merge ahead and actually started it
yet Angel points out to the group that
the sorcerers inside of the colonies
could probably reject the merger with
tinken because of their cursed energy so
because of that nothing is going on
around them being able to travel inside
and out of the barriers herself though
he disagrees and informs them that apart
from a few affected people most of
Japan's population is unaffected as of
now making me suspect that dick and jaku
either couldn't start the movie yet or
didn't want to however since there was
no way to find out right now they
decided to focus on friends to make me
first intervening in the conversation
himself Yuji decides to list off the
four rules that they decided to
implement mikami again clarifies that
rule 1 does indeed subject a player to
acoustic Nick removal or subsequently
death through something missing with
their brain the purpose of this first
rule was just to start fights with
people but now they can obviously
circumvent theirs Mucky though remarked
that it was actually rules two and three
which were the tricky ones as they
involved somehow creating a form of
movement and communication across
colonies stepping forth herself Hannah
declares that she could move across the
colonies by virtue of Angel's curse
technique Maki asked if it's possible
that she could use a curse technique on
someone else to help them leave but the
voice of Angel replied that they could
only extinguish a barrier technique by
destroying the root of the barrier
itself if they can't locate these
so-called Road they're only able to pass
through the colonies without actually
destroying them with the group realizing
that adding new rules might not actually
allow them to move across colonies that
decide to add the fourth Rule and focus
on allowing players to withdraw from the
game entirely so earlier on NL was back
well like Megami was recovering user had
transferred all the accumulated points
over to Mega me bringing his total
number of points up to 359. by the way
there is actually like a tiny mess up by
gear right here notice that it already
says one rule while Giga had messed up
and spoiled everyone in some kind of way
letting them know that Mega me did
indeed Implement at least one rule
speaking of himself making me attempts
to add a rule allowing players to
withdraw from the game but cogaine
rejects it states and that it clashed
against rule seven Mega me try to gain
asking if the game master would allow
players to withdraw if they invited a
substitute into the colony to take their
place but still cocaine refused however
out of nowhere it actually states that
the culling game has a suggestion it
says that it would indeed let players
leave the game on the condition that
they provide at one substitute and spent
100 points unable to negotiate any
further and utterly paved with the
result making me agree despite knowing
that adding the new rule would require
them to take out at least another 20
Sorcerers to just leave with all of the
negotiations complete Megami created a
new rule rule 11 a player can leave the
game by expending 100 points to invite a
new player into the colony as a
substitute looking over to the clan
killer herself which they don't actually
realize there are monkeys even taken out
of Clan yet mikimi asks if it's okay for
her to transport sakumi to Tokyo Colony
number one Yuji asked though if it would
be safer to transfer the points to her
remotely since she was already outside
the colonies however Megami pointed out
that since the rules illicitly stated
that a player must declare their
participation in a colony within 19 days
trying to circumvence it might lead to a
sister being substitute acoustic Nick
removal when she tries to leave the game
fledging forth now to the fateful day of
November the 16th we see that after
reconnecting with samiki Mahi led her
and the assistant manager ojichi to the
outskirts of Tokyo Colony number one so
when it actually comes to who's going to
be the substitute for uh simeki here
achichi had previously agreed to take
the role due to marky's lack of curse
energy as it prevents the barrier from
even recognizing her or allowing her to
become a substitute so Mickey is visibly
conflicted by the idea but it gives you
reason that they didn't have enough time
to find someone out as it had literally
been 16 days since everything begun
literally only given you three days
before like her brain goes poof standing
there ajichi reminisces on past memories
and how they always wanted to be a
source where they helped people yet Gojo
a demanded that he get his license and
become a manager instead back then
ajichi had thought the sorcerer to be
harsh but now he realized that he would
have been dead by now if he continued
down that path he had previously chosen
so he thanks Gojo for putting him on the
right track so remember like the spawn
glitch Yuji and mega me previously went
through back a little bit well somehow I
don't even know how she managed to do
this but to me he hacked the game and
got insanely lucky appearing directly
before Mega me and Yoji upon entering
the barrier completely stunning the both
of them with no time to lose let me not
even speaking to her transferred 100
points to a sister asking her to declare
her withdrawal from the game however to
the complete and utter shock to me he
used the points to instead add a new
rule to the game she immediately makes
the 12th rule granting players and
restricted entry and exit across Colony
borders more to fight and literally just
standing there unable to Fathom what
just happened making me asks his green
sister Who and the Royal she really was
I wonder so have you ever felt pain and
those few moments before what we now
know his pain crawled its way out of the
dark abyss itself Yuji had just assumed
everything was sweet now samiki was safe
migami would be all right and you would
follow up after and then kill sakona
along with Yuji and release Gojo who
would in turn take care of kinjaku the
plan literally had no folds apart from
the fact that they don't own the playing
field that they're standing on I'm
honestly at the point right now that I
think they just lose here the story ends
on a sad note and will be the first
Shonen to do so with all of the bad guys
winning unless like somehow JoJo gets
out and goes utterly god mode that
that's the only way they win right now
in my eyes it's exactly crazy however
samihi was then revealed to be an
imposter watching this thing in front of
him cackle Megami asks the Imposter who
they are Twitchy hysterically gloats
that she's definitely his big sister
stricken and at a loss for words Megami
remembers that the incarnated players
are given access to the memories of
their host thus because of their it's
entirely possible for them to
impersonate their hosts feeling like a
complete idiot now Mega me berates
himself for either thinking that his
sister had automatically awakened like
hagaroma and takaba so this person
inside of Mega me is actually called
igorozu a sorcerer from at least 1 000
years ago just like a few of the other
people here Megami who obviously just
wants to know why is told as she
pretended to be his big sister to use
the three points for her own game she
hasn't had a good fight in at least a
thousand years and wants to choose her
battle along with this location claiming
that she wants to take on sakuna first
moth like wings began forming on her
back before she jumps off the building
and begins boosting away Yuji and Hannah
like instantly go to give Chase not
wanting her to escape however like
everyone please just remember back
episode 7 right here and right now
already in a moment of Despair sukuna
uses that opportunity to appear on the
side of yuji's face and utterly words in
chain as per The Binding vowel showing
in chapter 11 or episode 7 who he is
intently forced hand over his body to
sakuna without any hesitation sakuna
immediately appears on the back of henna
taking her out for the complete ease
looking over at me and me whose brain
must be going through it right now
secunda explains that he once made a
vowel with Yuji having explained that he
can't harm anyone to Mega me he knows
they're from here on out everything that
he does is just a complete gamble
sending some form of like channeling
curse energy to yuji's finger sukuna
then proceeds to freaking tear his
entire finger off screaming at this
moment and like pure joy he explained
that it was a gamble because he wasn't
even sure if Yuji included himself in
the veil when stipulating the condition
that zakona must not hurt anyone
typical man like instantly pulls out the
arm movements to do maharaga but I
honestly can't blame him he doesn't
really have any other choice at the
moment so as he tries to summon maharaga
zakuna Datsun grabbing his face and
restricting the summoning seal before
shoving his finger down her boy's
unsuspecting throat with the cursed
energy pulsating through Mega me an
unconscious Yoji comes to not even
realizing what just happened as as per
the vowel stipulations however standing
opposite his boy he hears sakuna say
that indeed he's something interesting
in the future didn't they raising his
head we see that no one other than the
king of curses himself has supposedly
fully reincarnated inside of Mega me for
shiguru's body well they're just Heaven
boys and at this moment we very possibly
could have lost yet another of the
original Trio yet in my eyes we can't
lose them we can't lose them all unless
the bad guys actually win in the series
so if down the line it's confirmed and
the bath is completed and everything has
just turned to utter trash remind me
that hope itself was utterly sucked out
of the series at this exact moment
please just come back and let me know
down below anyway going back probably
for a last time I would say into the
inner world of sukonas we see him
monologue about the intricacies of his
plan for Mega me back during the day
when he confronted Mega me as Yuji for
the first time he sensed unmatched
Potential from him his acoustic Knicks
and his abilities he knew that he could
have forced Mega me to eat his finger
then and there that day but it
purposefully waited until build up
enough strength instead of Yuji to
initiate the vowel actually they have a
great Theory here and like how we all
know that hinjaku had made Yuji
specifically forskona well what if
kinchaku also made it a binding Veil
that yuchi would not be able to use his
curse technique while sakuna was caged
inside of him versacuna finally leaving
our boy's body now we may see for the
first time that Yuji actually like has
his mother's technique or possibly
something that even relates to a literal
thing that'll bring up right at the very
end of this video anyway I top the
building meguna which is like sukuna
Mega me mix up I'm just going to call
him that sometimes the absolute Beast
himself stands there leaving Yuji
stunned asking for his friend to just
talk to him yet as we all probably
expected was just about to happen the
demon Megami asukuna comes in will they
charge and punches Yuji like and this
wasn't any ordinary level of punch as
well meant to separated the fabric
around the area that he hit on Yuji like
it made Yuji freaking throw up or
sending him hurling through a multitude
of different skyscrapers eventually
though Yuji ends up finishing his
destructive path on a rooftop of another
building completely unconscious and
covered in rubble noticing some people
approaching the area sukuna states that
in every damn age and sex always come
crawling out of the woodwork placing his
hands together it informs the sign of
megami's 10 Shadows technique more
specifically the hand signs for no way
instantly a monolithic sized Norway is
summoned out of a nearby Skyscraper with
everyone reacting in pure shock and or
at the size of no way it releases it's
usually pretty ineffective attack that
simply stuns people yet this time it
rains deadly lightning down on everyone
from the sky above having recovered from
a previous beating henna quickly makes
your appearance by shooting over showing
up behind the revived demon saying her
sakuna realizes that Hannah and the
angel co-exist and thus she can recover
very fast to say like in comparison to
him and Yuji in the past given that
Hannah is extremely in love with me give
me I would say probably from what I've
read so far she screams in hesitation
not wanting to hurt Mega me however
Angel insists that there is no other
choice he is is the disgraced one and
must be eliminated right away thus as
Hannah cries to get migami back Angel
becomes reciting the Incarnation to
dispel evil itself speaking to God now
she tells him to purify all remove his
anguish transgressions and guilt to
guide him on the correct path instantly
Jacobs later initiates filling the sky
with some form of holy symbol before a
mess of pure light energy strikes down
upon the disgraced one himself in
another note boys just quickly cut it in
here and after browsing the interwebs
myself I'll discover that Jacob's letter
is actually referring to a line from
Genesis 28 10-19 I don't know if that's
actually I think that's how you say uh
Bible lines I shouldn't know I used to I
was raised in the church this part of
like the Bible narrates the story of
Jacob dreaming of the Angels descending
from the heavens and the letter
appearing to take these Souls from Earth
to heaven so in other words the attack
simply dispelled evil while sending the
person's soul on the correct path or at
least that's however interpreted her
attack as with the mass of light bearing
down on it begins tearing at sakuna's
soul in an attempt to bring me back as
Hannah is crying screaming that Mega me
belongs to her it appears as if the
technique has actually managed to work
dispelling sakuna's Spirit from migami's
body but remember like honestly hit just
how I said before that incarnated
Sorcerers and people like sukuna can
mimic how their body used to behave
while Angel realizes that sukuna is
still in control and manipulating henna
with migami's voice not paying attention
though henna falls into migami's arms
saying that she's always sadly though
she's unable to continue her sentence
has sakona fully reveals himself before
going to strike on an unsuspecting henna
calling her a foolish human shakuna like
an absolutely rabid dog bites in tears
at Hannah before throwing her across the
entirety of the building causing her to
smash into the side of the protective
railing Yuji down below watching this in
shock and not even able to comprehend
what just happened Witnesses Hannah thud
onto the ground below with no indication
that she'll ever return looking down
from the top of the building himself
sakuna is astonished to see you somehow
alive after the previous blow with rage
beginning to fill up inside of him and
after realizing that he's lost the one
thing keeping him together and giving
him meaning in life Yuji breaks and a
complete flash usually jumps across the
building breaking the ground below him
and causing the entire skyscraper to
collapse he Graves to Cone his neck and
screams his name before laying in a
ferocious punch on the king of cursor's
face forcing him to dub back across the
street for gaining his footing sakuna
wonders just just how in the world uses
so strong all of a sudden then in that
freaking moment Yuji takes him off guard
throwing a massive section of the
previously collapsing building into the
Demon's face seeing him shooting back
once again sprinting towards them
himself yuhi grabs a piece of rebar to
beat down onto Kona worth with him
darting him behind the king of curses
Schooner remarks that he should have
seen us coming after all Yuji is from
back then and what do you mean by that
sakuna right there eh anyway having
blocked yuji's strike with the bar
sakuna counters by disarming and kicking
him in the face while noting that
kingjaku jaw is Twisted I'll expand like
more on what this means in a moment but
honestly in my opinion this all relates
back to Yuji and him having his curse
technique suppressed or I like it being
suppressed while he was being used as a
cage for his Kona so don't be surprised
if our guy manages to manifest and
inherited technique and the near like
very near future but yeah asuji
continues to approach a Kona trying to
attack him he screams asking him why why
is it that he just can't live normally
like everyone else why can't he live a
life without causing everyone to suffer
Yuji continues approaching when all of a
sudden takuna uses his acoustic name
slash to cut Yuji across the chest
replying to his previous statement
sukuna rebuttals him asking him why so
weak continuously trying to cling to
life he continues by saying that this
suffering is only natural and they are
meant to live life with this misery for
a moment there Yuki forgot that there is
no reasoning with him as they are and
always will be curses do he dares to
Kona to chew on his misery and suffering
instead while beginning to March towards
the Demon Lord self passing them off is
just absolutely pathetic zakuna uses his
curse technique to continuously cut Yuji
over and over and over and over again
yet our boy is just built different and
with a rage-filled heart he puts the
pain aside and stuns sakuna by not
slowing his Approach at all standing
there and actually confused now on like
like what is going on shakuna wonders
how in the world is so tough then out of
freaking nowhere and just like during
Shibuya once again proving that the body
and soul are won making me hold sukuna's
movement allowing his boy to follow up
and Pamela's face with a fat right Hawk
elsewhere and literally just boasting it
over on the Blowfish Express ultimate
enkenjaku are seen traveling towards
what I assume to be the current bait
down back in the battle and having
smacked sakuna in the face maguna
remarks that fushiguro is indeed
stopping his curse energy output which
is allowing him to only use 10 of his
maximum output hence how doji has
managed to survive they blows so far
sakuna notes that well it's probably
expected when the job's only half done
but still considers it enough to easily
take out ug interesting so I wonder what
the other half of this ritual to fully
take over megami's body will be probably
something to do with the bath and
that'll happen at the zenith's household
which is their fitting scene at Mega me
is actually like from these in its
bloodline and all standing there maguna
is completely taken by surprise as he
couldn't see to Maki actually slowly
moving towards the epicenter of a fight
I want you to know what in the world
corsicona's body to switch into migamese
Maki asks to be brought up to date with
Yuji just completely bedded and bruised
telling her to just kill him as he's not
gonna die either way boo sinan Maki
attempts to land a fat head kick in
collaboration with Yuji however mikimi's
body is functioning extremely well
obviously you know from what we've seen
so far and he's comfortably able to
counter his opponent still Mahi with her
immense speed is able to break through
his defenses and send him flying
smashing into some railing nearby taking
the opportunity jujit then grabs the
other side of the railing beans in it
around sakuna before Mikey follows up in
combination and kicks him into a
building nearby seeing the unharmed
Damon Waltz out though Maggie wonders if
it's impossible to actually inflict
damage with his soul Liberation sword
because sakuna will use his reverse
curse techniques to heal himself knowing
that no matter what happens here they'll
have to kill sakuna Maki charges in
saying he'll have to keep up with his
speed probably running at speeds faster
than sound right now sukuna is
surprisingly able to keep up with the
attacks of Marquee and hugee but knows
that whenever he tries to attack them
with curse energy they pull from Mega me
inside him as stronger and thus to get
around megame sakuna like the absolute
big brain man he is uses his curse
technique cleave spider threads on the
ground below to utterly destroy the
ground and disbelance Yuji and Marquee
with the ground around them now falling
to but zakuna is able to easily Dart in
and lazy fat right Hawk yet Maki simply
spits out a tooth or two leaving him
completely impressed with how she's
hardly even worried with taking damage
asakuna falls back a little and
mysterious fold and randomly appears
from the side and uses a maximum output
technique called Dead Calm the resulting
aftermath from the attack not only
freezes the entirety of the area but
also Marky and Eugene so their
mysterious person happened to be no one
other than the coldest woman out
sakuna's right-hand woman urume who
apologizes for a grand entrance while
saying that she's still awakened the ice
around Yuji just in case they need him
secunda though literally doesn't care
for him anymore and instead just
compliment her stating they're focusing
her energy on Maki was a good idea
believing that everything here is sweet
now sukuna then summons Noe saying that
this body is still not complete so they
need to prepare for the bath immediately
in that moment though our goat though
looking more Baden than Bros than ever
after this Escalade burst his way out of
the ice noticing this or maybe proposes
taking him out but Sakura says that they
should just look at him and have a good
laugh flying away for what seems like
good in yuji's eyes sukuna having taken
the body of yuji's best friend and urume
laugh at his face noticing that he looks
just like the person from The harima
Province which is exactly what I was
referring to and goes back to kinjaku
using a binding vowel on Yuji at Birth
or even beforehand The Vow would not
allow him to use his technique in return
for Yuji being used as a vessel for
sakuna to help restore his strength
obviously we know that kinjaku would
like purposely found a bloodline that
has some form of durability as was seen
in Yuji possibly to just keep sukuna
safe during his time in Yuji announced
confirmed that Yuji actually has true
Heritage that originates from a family
in the harima province and this harima
province was established in the 600s A.D
and ran up to the late 1800s so
definitely before like the current time
period so you all thought the arc ended
here well no no no sakuna is Mega me
actually speed ran this damn bath and
after having arrived at the Zenith
household we see him falling deeper and
deeper into evil itself outside the bath
urume dressed up in ritual robes asks
hinjaku whether or not he plans to end
the Cullen game to which kinjaku
explains that his assimilation of The
Wider population can't actually have
until the game ends the recently culling
game was even able to be constructed in
the first place was because kinjaku had
shouldered the burden of an equally
unreasonable binding vow yet instead of
getting on with Indina currently he's
more interested in sakona's bath and how
it works kinjaku himself knew that the
bath was originally a ritual to
transform vessels that had been
treasured as family heirlooms into
cursed holes to do this the clay must
make a solution of curse energy which
was created by straining organisms
chosen in a kodoku ritual once it has
prepared the vessels are soaked for 10
months in 10 days in the solution so
what's actually really cool about this
ritual is it's actually something from
real Japanese folklore it's a derivative
of the Chinese go magic and it's a type
of poisonous ability and how real life
to create kodoku sorceress would make
civil insects in HR and let them kill
one another until only one survived the
fluids of the insect that survived would
be used to poison an individual with a
curse that would control them causing
Misfortune or kill them the remaining n6
would also be used as a a sort of luck
charm granting the one who performed the
ritual great wealth this ritual could
also be used as a death curse by giving
the riches to an ignorant individual
perhaps like kinjaku if the uh if he's
ignorant enough in this example here but
I don't actually think he is the term
kodoku can also be applied to the spirit
which is the Incarnation of this
particular magic funnily enough this
technique was even used in the Nara
period in like real life which we now
know as the era just before the Golden
Age of sorcery and Jujutsu Kaizen so
kinjaku was actually surprised that they
specifically chose to use curses in this
ritual especially for the fact that they
become dust upon their deaths urume
though like the cold queen that she is
actually figured out a way to get around
verse simply if she carefully pins down
the spirits before freezing the cause
they don't turn into dust and it allows
them to strain away the toxins they need
confused with the purpose of it all
kinjaku asks why and urma just tells him
as to get closer to evil the entire
purpose of this ritual is to suppressed
Megami fujiguru's Soul deeper into the
deeps as they further down his thanks
the easier it is for sakonas to control
the cage he's currently controlling
having completed the bath the Demon Lord
himself rises from the depths of evil
symbolizing that migami fujiguro has
lost his small hold he head over sakona
hinjaku questions why didn't change his
appearance but takuna just reasons that
if he's gonna be battling Sorcerers then
it's better to maintain migami's
appearance honestly this is just
probably for the fact that whenever he
runs into a group of people from like
Jujutsu High it'll just completely and
utterly shatter their resolve as he
never actually expected something like
this would ever happen so remember
samiki which is now you got to do well
it was actually a do that reincarnated
inside of her and after leaving Yuji the
traveled back to the hometown before
later heading to the Sendai colony which
was the closest uh I guess barrier to it
having got the rundown on this from
kinjaku sukuna says that he doesn't give
a damn about Yoda Zoo but instead wants
to destroy samiki for shigro to
completely sink Mega me soul inside of
him as they then leave on the Blowfish
Express kinjaku tells him that he'll
give him a ride to the Colony but once
they point an exchange so I truly wonder
what on the world he's about to do with
the 200 or so points that he's just
received from sakuna here let me know
your thoughts on that down below do you
reckon he's going to like actually pay
for himself to to leave the game
entirely and just let everyone else do
their thing while he causes Havoc
outside of like the colonies and stuff
but anyway I'd love to know your
thoughts down below shooting back to the
Sendai Colony for the first time in a
while both uro and Ryu notice a mass of
bloodlust appear from afar uro utterly
breaks down muskraine that here he comes
the king of curses instantly sukuna
arrives in front of Ryu and as he slowly
begins walking up to him he asks if he's
gonna run or not but before Ryu could
even act sakuna activates a slash
technique and slashes real across the
chest blown away though because he like
obviously thought he was going to get
cut into a multitude of Paces so Cooney
just laughs and apologizes saying that
he underestimated Ryu but won't hold
back again filling the bloodlust Rising
Ryu jumps back and tries to use Granite
blast but before he could even finish
his attack sequence zakuna slices Ryu
across the face utterly destroying one
of my favorite characters in typical
Giga fashion having left the area that
he was just at and now arriving at a
football field in Sendai zacona finally
encounters Yoda Zoo taking things back
off after the sakona Revival part of the
story and standing there in the middle
of the football field after a
mind-boggling 1 000 years yarazu has
finally reunited with her love as we
learned at the end of the sukuna Revival
part of the Cullen game this
long-awaited confrontation takes place
and the Heart of the Sendai Colony more
specifically and assuming I'm correct
for the old Googles here this is most
likely the Eurotech football stadium
located in Sim does nanakita Park as the
two reincarnated Souls stand facing each
other it's clear that both yorazu and
sukuna have the same thoughts on their
minds they are literally a killer couple
zacona the king of curses exudes
confidence firmly believing that goddess
who stand no chance against him with no
time to spear yodazoo Springs into
action launching a blistering attack on
sakona but he effortlessly evades the
strike swiftly retaliating with the
devastating cat hold on there's a this
is a price twist in store yodazoo never
won to miss a chance to lighten their
mood playfully tasers sakona pulling a
funny face to catch him off guard
sakuna's like primary goal here is to
obtain yodazoo's vessel as he plans to
eliminate megami's sister sakumi and
ultimately consume Megami Soul by
accomplishing these nefarious Deeds
sakuna aims to solidify his claim as the
most formidable and most powerful entity
in existence yodasu expresses her
curiosity about what sukuna could offer
her if she actually emerges Victorious
and a stunning twist sukuna confidently
assures yaduzu that if she doesn't move
Victorious he will grant her any wish
that her heart desires these Stakes have
never been set higher the others who
then like whether mischievous Glenn to
know I playfully suggests the idea of
marrying sukuna surprisingly sukuna
seems like ugly in phased by this
unexpected proposal as if it's happened
a multitude of times before or something
with excitement bubbling a new voice
yodasu exclaimed that them now made a
promise Jonas whose enthusiasm knows
absolutely no bounds as she excitedly
invis versions they feature together
plotting the destruction of three
specific villagers yorosu then reveals
her Twisted plan for their wedding
reception which includes adorning the
trees with the most handsome men from
the village it's fairly evident that
like Yoda zuhava's Sinister intentions
Eric Simon Peaks as she mentions her
favorite meal which is monkey brains out
of all things honestly like this scene
here has to be some kind of reference to
Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom the
whole monkey brain thing just like
instantly made me think of that just has
so many different references to Great
forms of different art like the bath
same with hiromi hugoroma or our man
Hikari and is like his entire
underground fighting Reign being a
direct reference to fight club by the
way as yarazu continues delving into the
winning details she is abruptly
interrupted by the arrival of the Divine
dolls surprisingly yorazu
single-handedly takes down the onslaught
of the Divine dogs and realizes this
Akuna isn't even using his own technique
on her saguna advises yodazoo to utilize
her very own techniques as well but she
declines tsukuna stand in there
contemplates various possibilities
within his mind he understands that in
order to sink Mega me soul deeper into
the spear he must first destroy his
vessel's sister it turns out that aside
from cursed holes he ought to do his
construction can replicate any substance
she is familiar with through diligent
practice the seasoned sorcerer has
mastered the art of manipulating liquid
metal allowing her to change its shape
and volume automatically through cursed
energy control the armor that yoruzu
wears is inspired by a fusion of various
evolutionary strands making it an
incredibly formidable weapon skipping
away though for a moment and
transporting ourselves back to the
hearing era we find yarazu lost in deep
contemplation so in a similar aspect to
Ryu when it comes to Pure curse energy
output yodazoo was quite powerful and
one of the strongest Sorcerers of her
time however her curse energy
consumption rate posed quite a challenge
but then out of nowhere a rumor then
reached yaruzu's ears about a legendary
butterfly capable of Crossing vast seas
and guess what yodazu saw a glimmer of
hope in the efficiency and energy of
those tiny insects but her Newfound
Revelation didn't end there turns out
that these insects possess superhuman
strength capable of lifting objects
hundreds of times their own weight a
strength befitting a formidable sorcerer
like yodazoo through this yarazu soon
realized that her insect armor was the
Pinnacle of construction techniques
allowing her to recreate various
substances except for those special
grade cursed tools I kind of think of
her ability as just like the most jacked
out version of my xenon's construction
ability that she could possibly have or
the ability that she might have gotten
if say she wasn't actually a twin but
you know that's I guess another entire
video that someone could talk about
someday I ain't gonna be me continuing
onwards this unique combat style of
yoresus turned the tables on the
notorious Goku show the five void
generals earning her a place of respect
in the fujiwara clan back in the present
yodasu unleashes her hardened armor
bursting up through the air before
landing a powerful blow that connects to
rexley where the king of kusa's face
yorazoo determined to when Rebel
sukuna's plans boldly questions him
about his intentions regarding his
Shrine technique how however the tide
suddenly turns asakuna unveils his
devastating tranquil deer technique a
formidable counter to any summoning and
his shocking twist of fate Yoda Zoo
loses control over her liquid metal
making her realize that the Tranquil
deer has neutralized and nullified her
curse energy within the meat hole it's a
game changer that leaves you really and
something we never even still Mega me
think about using to make matters worse
fate can be cruel and in a single brutal
moment sukunu strikes yodasu with his
devastating piercing ball attack
inflicting a deep agonizing wound to her
abdomen it's revealed that sukuna
intentionally used the 10 Shadows to
keep the shukigami partially unstable
allowing for a larger effective range
without them falling apart both the
Tranquil deer and the piercing Bowl were
summoned using the original 10 Shadows
technique but the independent movement
was restricted resulting in reduced
overall movement however since okona's
immense cursed energy was reserved their
form remained stable despite enduring a
life-threatening wound themselves the
odyssu holds on like a champ and wants
Akuna to not underestimate her she
tackles the piercing ball grabbing its
haunt and Landing their powerful blow to
its head yodasu notices that
sukunuchigagami only moves in straight
lines and in exchange its power
dramatically increases out of nowhere
though a swarm of bunnies appear
blinding her vision and making it almost
impossible for yarazu to track down
sakona sukuna you know like being the
trickster that he is Hills Max elephant
downwards while he floats in mid-year
and a surprising Twist Again yorazoo
transforms back into her original form
again looking like sakumi except like
the sakumi here just looks way more
jacked up and cooler than she did in the
past where she also becomes determined
to teach the Kona love suddenly a moment
of realization hits godzu though which
he wonders a sakona already knows about
love which begins to actually make her
mad man yodasu is actually one of the
most random characters which is cool but
like oh my Lord she's like Sheba from
house Paradise if you know her like in
some aspects with that super out there
personality anyway skipping away from
the current day and heading back to the
Golden Age of Jujutsu we see that in
mesmerizing Harvest ritual is taking
place some individuals in the crowd
can't help question and why they're
offering prayers to a fierce a monster
like sakona little do they know these
folks belong to these Celestial Squad
the five boy generals who seem to have
conveniently forgotten sukuna's previous
atrocities against the estamed fujiwara
clan amidst the hustle and bustle a
helper approaches yodazoo addressing her
as master and informing her about the
upcoming Harvest Festival damn Yoda was
a total Baddie man she responds to the
helper demanding that they lower their
voice and if that wasn't enough she gets
even more annoyed when they help her has
the audacity to suggest that she puts on
some clothes in preparation for the
festival like how dare she got a zoo
however manages to find some form of
excitement in the festival as it
promises to offer delectable Chinese
pastries to the gods out of the blue
yorazoo then spotty man calmly sitting
down also half naked she approaches him
with confidence and straight up hugs him
assuring him that he's not alone in this
world however another meddlesome helper
intervenes urging yorazoo to step back
undeterred yonazu boldly declares that
she'll take the place of that man's
Helper and refuse us to let him feel
lonely yes my friend it was love at
first sight a once in a lifetime
encounter that made yodesu's heart
Skippy beat yet this wasn't the usual
beat skip when it came to love no this
time as she proclaimed her right to be
with sakuna a slash appeared on her body
and she fell to the ground finally
proving that love does indeed kill
honestly what a turbulent backstory and
I wouldn't expect any less from such an
out there character like what are you
what are your thoughts on her right now
the Ambitions are kind of random to me
like a little bit like shija I guess
fast forward back to the present now
where the air is thicker with skeptical
tension as yorozu and sakuna continue to
engage in their first battle yodazoo
more determined than ever to insukuna's
existence conjures up a sphere filled
with Darkness sukuna can't help you to
notice the peculiar Perfection of that
sphere okay so giggy this chick is
absolutely crazy but you go and give it
one of the most cracked abilities in the
entire and the entire story so far I
don't even know what the sphere is
considered in regards to like her
technique like is it a maximum technique
or is it just an extension of a creation
I don't know but like for a moment and
just nerding out on this thank you to
Reddit Juju sushi for like being the big
brainery because I would have never
figured this out but a perfect circle is
a shape that has an infinite amount of
points all at an equal distance from a
center this means that no matter what
angle of attack you come from your first
point of contacts will always be a
single infinitesimally small point
pressure is like defined as a force
acting on a cross-section if you keep
the pressure the same but reduce the
cross-section size this means that any
amount of force acting upon an
infinitely small area will have infinite
pressure yodes perfect sphere will
technically destroy anything it touches
because it will be an infinitely small
point of first Contact regardless of
what angle you hit it from anyway
sending the ball forth go to zoo reveals
that a true sphere is thought to be
impossible due to its lack of contact
area which generates infinite pressure
then bring your hands together yorazoo
attempts to unleash her domain expansion
threefold Affliction but as she looks
towards sakuna she's shocked to see that
he didn't even open his domain as well
so kuna being the debatable chair that
he is drops this random wheel that he
had and summons another shikagami which
just happens to be the freaking
strongest of them all the eight-handled
sword Divergent Cilla Divine General
maharaga instantly maharaga thrusts her
sword upwards obliteratingly perfectly
formed sphere and her domain with the
others of having fallen to the floor
fatally wounded as well and utterly
gobsmacked sukuna smugly points out that
her energy and efficient curse technique
will always make the same fate
regardless of the substance she
constructs be it liquid metal or insect
armor sukuna in his eyes he has already
adapted to it ringing it and effective
against him lying there seemingly fading
away and with a smile on her face though
you'll just do others some final words
of Happiness before gifting something to
Daddy sakona flashing on to the deaths
of Mega me though we see that as he lays
there curled up in a fatal position some
forms of light begin to break through so
what do you think do you think uh she
gave something to sakuna that helped
with like subduing Mega me and making up
fall deeper into the darkness or was it
something that like broke through and
made that light appear perhaps or was it
light already there and it was slowly
set in the clothes and it was just my
incorrect assumption on the same anyway
this stage is now set for a brand new
day of Darkness as kinjaku not content
with the game's existing challenges
decides to add some new sick roles that
will push our new Sorcerers to their
limits kinjaku orders his loyal servant
colgaine to introduce a new rule that
bans any new players from joining the
game but man gets instantly denied as it
conflicts with another role either the
Shima kinjaku attempts to decipher the
motives behind tengen's decision to
place barriers all around Japan he
wonders if King gets intention is to
suppress the cursed outbreak by creating
purification barriers that enhance the
effectiveness of barrier techniques
there are four particular barriers that
hold great significance in this grand
scheme of tingens one such barrier
surrounds the Imperial Palace and the
other around the Tomb of the star the
third barrier is in the Kyoto yamakuni
Imperial Mausoleum and the final barrier
is situated at the hate a Holy Mountain
the foundation of this brutal culling
game rests upon the awe-inspiring Bond
barrier and even better barrier than
pure ones according to Big Kenny this
game has no true Master more that he's
forced tinken into that position walking
around like what seems to me the inside
of the heater Mountain Shrine area or
whatever their um tinken head kinjaku
comes up with all sorts of possibilities
including the deactivation of the
barriers he reveals that if Tink and
deactivated the barriers after the
events of Shibuya the culling game would
have actually come to an end all of his
Sinister planes would go down in vain
however if tenkin did follow through
with that it would cause the underwing
of 1 000 years of process and endless
Wars against different curses having
revealed just how in control of
everything he is kinjaku once again
repeats the cocaine to prohibit the
entrance of any new players otherwise
he'll destroy the purification barriers
and Force the game to close this
literally causes the cocaine to glitch
out allowing the rule to get added to
the game he also added another rule
which is that the game would mean of all
players except Mega me fushiguro and
suguru ghetto are dead as kinshaku and
tenkin then Venture 4 throughout the
area tengen questions the fact that if
he truly wanted to end the game why
don't he just remove the barriers like
he threatened but the reason for this is
because he actually needs those barriers
for tingen's eventual merger what's the
Japanese population having made it to
the center of the barrier they encounter
the very embodiment of evil itself which
was most likely being held here for
safekeeping as it was inside like a
barrier so why let these guys are
playing this Sinister game of Robin
mummies and you know trying to ruin the
world and everything in a hallway at the
exact same time Maki and wiwi are seen
discussing things related to the Cullen
game and how killing sakuna and kinjaku
would make him win the game which is
just wrong only Mega me and tsukona can
physically win the game now which is why
I narratively say that the killing game
ends from here however they also discuss
zato and wonder if killing sakona would
be as hard as killing Gojo a new
flashback and back after sekona sent
like hanakurasu flying freaking miles
she was luckily saved by Amaya and
cushioned from her fall and then like
the greatest Sorcerer of them all in my
opinion takaba stayed with her
throughout the rest of that battle to
keep her safe when she wakes up at the
hospital later on she hears Joker saying
that she's definitely not in a good
condition to participate in the game
anymore Yoda asks her if she's able to
transform into another human form three
vessel like sukuna Angel who herself
explains though that one of the reasons
she and the other sorcerers of ancient
times took kinjaku up on his offer was
because none of them knew how to become
cursed items after death this fact Still
Remains True to this very day but the
Fallen himself is completely different
in the scenario she also explains that
After experiencing death once sukuna
most likely stumbled on her way to split
his soul as a cursed item which I
weirdly kind of think is like a horcrux
from Harry Potter and how like big
baseball has sold seven times to escape
death either way henna also reveals that
her role will come to an end once she
dispels the seal on Saturday Gojo
outside the hospital now Amai found
himself consumed by self-love thing as
he constantly compared himself to the
stronger individuals he beared his soul
to ethadori confessing that he always
carried a deep sense of Shame and
inferiority around others in response
edidori opened up about the unsettling
emotions he experienced upon meeting am
I despite his eagerness to change and
fight alongside edudori and my admitted
to feeling a profound fear knowing that
Amaya had managed to save Angel after
sukuna sent to hurling through some of
the nearby buildings Yuji thanks him as
now they still actually have some kind
of chance and this messed up situation
this confuses our like Jewish Japanese
man because from what he's heard Yuji
had no way of fighting without sukuna's
strength bath however alpoy explains
that just recently he was informed that
his body is like a cursed object dipped
in sakuna's energy now he's gonna eat
anything to Pummel that creep and save
his mate more determined than ever Yuji
then returned to the hospital and
encountered due to Marquis and the other
sorcerers hoping to offer them some
suggestions on how to save migami choso
then presented him with a book
programming with information about the
prison Realms dark secrets and tsukomo's
meticulously documented research on the
soul watch before their battle in the
kinjaku extermination art she entrusted
her to choso so like that's how we ended
up getting it and stuff so don't get
confused and show how like choso has
this hearing whatnot I'm pretty sure
yuhi knew she was going to die in that
battle and that's why she handed it over
also and mental hint is given to us on
what yuji's technique could consist of
Joseph says that it's fine if the
siblings are blank as long as they can
go on living as a part of the ug which
begs the question what happened to their
siblings did Yuji ate them like it's
insinuating throughout this part of the
story I don't know I don't know I'd love
to do her thoughts down in the comment
section below I'm pretty sure like I've
mentioned this beforehand in another
video but it's extremely interesting to
me by the way on the other side of the
room chilling up against the wall when
smoking a big old black Shoku just
thinks back on how Gojo promised he
wouldn't leave anyone alone back in the
day she used to be in love with one of
the duo but that could never happen and
now they're idiots all alone and there
are a bunch of monsters needing his help
please go Joe come back so with like
everyone still big chilling inside of
the hospital could have so the warrior
of the group is deeply concerned about
Gojo's state of mind and rightfully so
being trapped in the prison realm could
actually mess with one's head as time
does not flow within it whoever whatever
is trapped inside cannot die due to
starvation or old age kurusu knows the
danger there could be caused of the
strongest Sorcerer of their time turns
out to be crazed and starts killing
everyone he sees but Shoku has like her
own reservations here as everyone's
talking about unsealing Gojo she
believes that unsealing him in a
combined space of the hospital is a
risky move like who knows how large the
explosion could be so to fix this
predicament I'll determine judicious
sorceress embark on a journey to saitama
prefecture specifically to the koroko
mines interestingly the Croco mines is
training ground number four for Jujutsu
High revealing that they have other
similar like locations about but what I
find more interesting is that the actual
location of Kuroko and Japan is located
in Hokkaido so does that mean that
they've traveled up there and not
saitama or is this just like a mistake
on my Googling skills it's probably a
mistake of my Googling skills to be
honestly don't blame me boys I'm sorry
about that one either way as enumaki and
edadori huddled up together behind some
makeshift barriers could a suit takes to
the skies soaring above and preparing to
unleash acoustic link like no other the
legendary Jacobs later kurusu takes aim
and with one salmon directs the full
force of Jacob's Lair towards the prison
realm itself and the hope to finally
bring back Gojo with the brightness of a
nuclear blast kurosu's technique and
ghostly present realm but a shocking
Revelation unfolds before the eyes and
the entire realm disappears Into Thin
ear yes the prison realm an extremely
formidable presence if you ask me is now
nowhere to be found Pena confuses
everyone rushes towards the spot where
the round once stood only as we met with
dispersing dust utterly confused Yuji
looks over to the vessel and Hannah
tries to explain to him that it isn't
her fault like that he's suspected
earlier Gojo might have just turned to
evil and the light from Jacob's later
could have made him disappear amidst the
the chaos kurosu's mind starts to wander
questioning whether Gojo as truly an
evil spirit bringing her back to reality
though an earthquake suddenly shakes the
entirety of the continent taking the
whole group by surprise back inside of
the barrier and also I'd say bikini
heroes in Tokyo Colony number one or the
ihe colony as its closest to where I
assume the hay day mountains are that's
if that's where sakona's body was either
way like that's where they were last
seen as kinjaku is having a discussion
on the prison realm with a special
someone he reveals that currently the
prison realm is placed at the subduction
zone which is 8 000 meters below the
surface of the ocean in the deepest part
of the Japan trench and just if it had
an extra level of security he placed
extra curse spirits to act as senses
beneath layers of extra seals that he
created the reason he went to such
extreme lengths is because tengen told
him about the back of the prison realm
and this way he'd still be able to take
Gojo down using the environment he's
placed in that depth is a crushing 800
atmospheres of pressure like you'd
literally be vaporized if you were
naturally subject to that dip but well
goju is just uh he just he's built
completely and utterly differently as
all of a sudden he now appears staring
down looking absolutely magnificent and
asking hinjaku if he's ready to end
everything kinchaku tries to irritate
the greatest sorcerer to ever live but
Gojo tells the fame that he should be
choosing his words carefully as these
These are his final moments taken by
surprise himself though because you're
easily manages to block a few random
strikes from the other body swapper
taking his new appearance and goju just
states that Mega me has indeed changed
from the last time they saw each other
so remember back on like episode 1 or
whatever it was when saguna mentioned
that him murt Gojo first once and for
all when he's finally revived well now
with him finally having swapped up his
skin just mentions that it turned out to
be this Brat's body that he's now in but
either way nothing's changed after a
rumor shows up as well and her along
with the king of curses continue to
verbally abuse Gojo sukuna Reveals His
intentions of defeating the legendary 6
eyes user but Gojo just calls him
pathetic a roommate witnessing this
whole situation gets mad and tries to
attack Gojo but in a fraction of a
second gets slammed with one punch
knocking her into a wall and causing the
poor check to start fading from reality
standing in there and saying that the
two beasts are about to throw hand
kinjaku rushes towards sakuna urging him
to fulfill their promise hearing that
sakuna as following orders Gojo deserves
him some more but here's the catch Gojo
has got more than just defeating sukuna
on his mind at the moment makes the
chaos of battle strategies swelling in
his head hit initially into the barrier
to retrieve ghetto's body from kinjaku
Little did he expect the shocking twist
that awaited him sakuna joining forces
with kinjaku via a binding vowel
continuing with light Kenny's check
though Gojo asks for the current date
and after hearing that it's like nearing
the end of November proposes that the
entire battle takes place on December
the 24th hearing this kinjaku cracks up
at the Romanticism of that specific
situation and agrees these Stakes are
extremely high as goju finds himself
himself under Gyros watchful gays
questioning whether Gojo truly believes
he can emerge Victorious from his epic
battle do we all remember back at the
very beginning of the series when Yuji
had asked Gojo if sukuna is stronger
than him of course at the time Gojo
stated that it may be a tough fight
after never gains all of his powers
causing Yuji to ask if he'd lose Gojo
probably been like slightly cocky to the
newcomer had replied that he'd win and
here just like in the past and now Gojo
unveils the truth stay team no before
the two strongest characters and the
entire verse face off we take into a
roommate delivering to Kona some fingers
and apologizing for not being able to
locate the final one so somehow a
roommate managed to survive that punch
to the gut that made her fade from
reality for a bit sukuna reveals that
like the last finger may already be and
go your position causing a roommate to
get annoyed they got you for a second
time managed to outdo her zakuna gets up
and begins eating the shinbotsu Mami a
cursed mummy that in his eyes can
compensate for one finger's worth of
cursed energy the same thing shifts to
kinjaku who's having a discussion with
cocaine the discussing the killing game
that still hasn't ended cocaine reveals
that there are a total of 61 players
that died by cursed technique removal
because they never entered a colony
wanting to know if they fear death or
take any life kogane reveals that those
61 players simply lacked intuition after
all one takoroma added his role they
could have avoided both of those
scenarios he realizes that the people of
Japan have convinced themselves they
have no control over their reality even
when their lives are tasering Brank he
knows that not everyone has the courage
to put their own life at stake but if
they're forced to by someone else then
have no choice but to act however with
no hope of the present or future these
pathetic humans in his eyes are willing
to die at any time directing his speech
towards Tinker now he tells the thumb
that he despises those who never learn
the feeling of approaching their ideals
one step at a time what does Super sus
kinjaku we all know what you had to go
through with kaori and the fact that you
cherished every step is crazy bro either
way I think it's kind of safe to say
here that with no one else being able to
join the Cullen game it's ended yes it's
still active but cocaine is kind of
stuck in a leg lock and unable to
proceed further with adding people so
like what's the entire point the game's
now glitched it can't even continue we
know that the next step is for kinjaku
to merge tank and what the population of
Japan and when that happens the Cullen
game is truly finished at that point but
that could happen for all we know the
second to last chapter of the entire
series with giga's current pace so here
in my eyes is where the killing game
comes to an end as it leans perfectly to
what we go into from here watch my guys
if Giga isn't lying on this being the
last year of Jujutsu Kaizen then this
next stuff has to be the final Arc for
sure he's probably lying but you know I
don't know how man can end this story in
the next 18 chapters with all of the
info that we need to know but I'm not
home here's the Holy Scripture so I'll
let him decide his face not me some
random old YouTube also if you have
enjoyed this compilation of I guess what
is pretty much all of my Jujutsu Kai's
in Arc videos kind of compiled into one
here to make this culling game video
then make sure you do hit the Subscribe
button and also be sure to leave a like
on this video here as well and just let
me know what kind of series you want to
see in the future but also do make sure
you go down and check out War Thunder
through my link in the description to
get a bunch of really dope goodies
including that forbidden anime body
pillow by the way for now it's been your
professional degenerate diavolo and I
will see you all enabertz bye